ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS AP BAKER
LARGEST BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORTEZ THREE DALLY DODD DERON.
EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERTZBERG HUESO HER TADO JOHN.
AIRED LEYVA MCGUIRE MELENDEZ
MAN NEWMAN NIELSEN A CHIRLA BUG
HAN PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO
SKINNER STERN. BURKE MY COW SKI
WIENER WILK. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE REAL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON
BY SENATOR DORADO AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR REID SENATOR TORONTO
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. GRACIOUS
AND TRUSTING GOD POURED MY
ANGELO TELLS US A BRAVE AND
STARTLING TRUTHS ABOUT
OURSELVES AS HUMANS. THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO CREATE
PEACE AND FREEDOM FOR ALL. A
BRAVE AND STARTLING TRUTH BY
MAYA ANGELOU. WE THIS PEOPLE ON
A SMALL AND LONELY PLANET
TRAVELING THROUGH CASUAL SPACE
TO A DESTINATION FOR ALL SIGNS
TELL US IT IS POSSIBLE AND
IMPERATIVE. THAT WE LEARN A
BRAVE AND STARTLING TRUTHS. AND
WHEN WE COME TO IT. TO THE DAY
OF PEACEMAKING WHEN WE RELEASE
OUR FINGERS FROM FISTS OF
HOSTILITY. AND ALLOW THE PURE
AIR TO COOL OUR PALMS. WHEN WE
COME TO IT. WE THIS PEOPLE ON
THIS MINUSCULE AND CATALYST
GLOBAL. REACH DALY FOR THE BOMB
THE BLADE AND THE DAGGER. YEAH
TO PETITION IN THE DARK FOR
TOKENS OF PEACE. BUT OF SUCH
CHAOS OF SUCH CONTRADICTION WE
LEARNED THAT WE ARE NEITHER
DEVILS NOR DEVINE'S. WHEN WE
COME TO IT. WE THIS PEOPLE ON
THIS WAYWARD FLOATING BODY HAVE
THE POWER TO FASHION FOR THIS
EARTH. A CLIMATE WHERE EVERY
MAN AND EVERY WOMAN CAN LIVE
FREELY WITHOUT SANCTIMONIOUS
PIETY WITHOUT CRIPPLING FEAR.
WHEN WE COME TO IT WE MUST
CONFESS THAT WE ARE THE
POSSIBLE WE ARE THE MIRACULOUS
THE TRUE WONDER OF THIS WORLD.
THAT IS WHEN AND ONLY WHEN AMON.
PROBABLY I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG OKAY. C. YEAH. STRONG.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS TO THE
WE HAVE SO LEE PURCHASE A RE
REMOTE GOOD AFTER SIR AND WELL.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DO YOU READ MESSAGE FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE READ REPORTS
OF WILL BE DEEMED READ
AMENDMENTS AND- MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
MEMBERS WE WILL COME BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
INTRODUCTION AND THE FIRST
READING OF BILLS BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ UNDER CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM
PRESIDENT TYPES MOVE ON THIS
AND I'LL LET HIM FOR WHICH IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF KATRINA
HAGEN AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS PRIOR TO THAT TO HER
TO THIS ROLE MISTAKEN SERVICE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION. IS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES WE INTERVIEWED-
AND SHE TESTIFIED VERY WELL AT
THE RULES COMMITTEE AND SHE WAS
APPROVED ON A VOTE OF FOUR TO
ZERO I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THIS CONFIRMATION THANK YOU
CENTER HERTZBERG MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. BAKER FIVE LARGEST FIVE
BRADFORD. FIVE CABALLERO FIVE
COURTESY HI DOLLY I DODD FIVE
TORONTO I EGGMAN. GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ. FIVE ZERO. I
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO HI HER TADO
I JONES I LAYERED I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE HI FIVE MELINDA'S I MEN.
I NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN I A TRAIL
OF BOTH. HI PAN I PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH. FIVE RUBIO. I SKINNER
FIVE STERN HI I'M BURKE I WOULD
TRAVESTY. I WIENER. I WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN I BATES. I EGGMAN. I
HEARD- I. WILK HI. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE IS CONFIRMED
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SENATOR ERTZBERG THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MADAM PRESIDENT THIS
A CONFIRMATION OF JOSEPH KERR
FOR THE APPOINTMENT THE WATER
QUALITY CONTROL BOARD SANTA ANA
REGION DISCOURAGE BEEN A
BUSINESS AGENT FOR THE ORANGE
COUNTY PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION SINCE
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE IS ALSO A
PART TIME INSTRUCTOR FOR THE
ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF BOATING AND
WATERWAYS HE WAS APPROVED BY
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
FEBRUARY SEVENTEENTH
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE SERVER
NUMBER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LET ME JUST ADD MY
VOICE TO SENATOR HERTZBERG
VOICE IN URGING THE
CONFIRMATION OF JOKER I'VE
KNOWN JOE FOR DECADES HE AND
HIS WIFE TINA AND SON JOE WE
HAVE BEEN LEADERS IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND I KNOW HE WILL
PERFORM HIS NEW DUTIES WITH THE
INTEGRITY DEDICATION AND TALENT
THESE BROUGHT TO ALL OTHER
ASPECTS OF HIS LIFE THANK YOU
FOR GINGIVAL THANK YOU CENTER
AMBERG MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION. AND OR DEBATE
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESENT I'D LIKE TO ADD MY
VOICE TO CALL. AND SUPPORT
MISTER CURTIS. APPROVED A POINT
THAT YOU WILL NOT MEET A FINER
FIREFIGHTER YOU WILL NOT MEET A
MORE COMMITTED SEDITION HE WILL
MAKE AN EXCELLENT ADDITION TO
THE BOARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN CENTER DORADO.
SORRY NO PROBLEM ANY OTHER
FURTHER FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THAT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA. AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES FIVE BAKER HI
FOR JUST I BRADFORD FIVE
CABRERA HI COURTESY HI DOLLY. I
DODD I TO RAZA I GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO. I HER TADO I JONES I
LAYERED I LEYVA HI MCGUIRE. I
MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION HI NEWMAN
I NIELSEN. BY A SHOW OF BOTH.
HI PAM I PORTANTINO. I ROTH. HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. I STERN HI
I'M BURKE HI MIKE HOW SKI. I
WIENER. I WILK. HI FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT ZERO THREE POINT IS
CONFIRMED MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. SENATOR ATKINS FOR
WHAT PURPOSE TO RISE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THERE IS A
RESOLUTION AT THE DESK
REQUESTING PERMISSION TO
SUSPEND ARTICLE FOUR SECTION
EIGHT A- OF THE CONSTITUTION
AND JOINT RULE FIFTY FIVE FOR
THE PURPOSE. OF ALLOWING SENATE
BILLS INTRODUCED IN THE YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THIS CALENDAR
YEAR ONLY TO BE AMENDED HEARD
AND ACTED UPON BY THE SENATE
BEFORE THIRTY CALENDAR DAYS
HAVE ELAPSED THESE REQUESTS
HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR- SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SENATOR ATKINS BALANCE
PLEASE READ THE RESOLUTION.
RESOLVED THAT PURSUANT TO
ARTICLE FOUR SECTION EIGHT A OF
THE CONSTITUTION SENATE BILLS
INTRODUCED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BEING MAYBE HEARD IN COMMITTEE
AND ACTED UPON BY THE SENATE
BEFORE THIRTY CALENDAR DAYS
HAVE ELAPSED SINCE INTRODUCTION
AND THAT THREE WILL FIFTY FIVE
BE SUSPENDED TO PERMIT SUCH
HEARING AND ACTION PRIOR TO
BEING IN PRINT FOR THIRTY DAYS.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AT OR DEBATE
SENATOR NIELSEN MONITORED
INQUIRY. PLEASE BECAUSE I MISS
THE INQUIRE OF THE PROGRAM ARE
THESE TRAILER BILLS OR JUST
REGULAR SENATE BILL. THANK YOU
FOR THE CALL- THE ARE. BILLS
THANK YOU. BILLS. TO THANK YOU
CENTER NELSON MAY ANY DISK FOR
YES SENATOR. IT'S IN MY MIND.
BERMAN. OKAY THANK YOU MEDICARE
I UNDER THE SCHEDULE IN THE
NEED DISK WORK HEARINGS IN THE
MOST WAY ESPECIALLY DURING THE
COLD WITH THE AND HAVE HOWEVER
SINCE BEEN THE CON OF THE STATE
LIMITED TRANCE BY NOT BILLS TO
BE IN PRINT FOR THIRTY DAYS IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT I CAN
SUPPORT JUST AS WE SAW IN
REGARDS TO COPE WITH NINETEEN
DATA CALIFORNIANS WANT MORE
TRANSPARENCY FROM THEIR
GOVERNMENT AND THEIR AND THEIR
GOVERNMENT TO WORK BETTER FOR
THEM BY NOT ALLOWING THE STATE
IF AT BY NOT ALLOWING THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND ITS CITIZENS
THIRTY DAYS TO READ AND DIGEST
THE BILL. SO THAT THEY CAN
MOBILIZE IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION AND FRANKLY JUST
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN THIS
BUILDING AND IT COME UP AND
COMMENT ON IT OR ACTUALLY ZOOM
IN A COMMENT ON IT NOW IT'S AN
UNACCEPTABLE AND I THINK I
DIMINISHES BOTH TRUST AND
CONFIDENCE IN OUR INSTITUTIONS
I'M ASKING ALL OF YOU
COLLEAGUES NOT TO SUSPEND THE
CONSTITUTION THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH HE DO WE SWORE
TO UPHOLD AND STAND BY THE
VOTERS IN THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA DEMANDING
TRANSPARENCY AND NOT LESS AND.
I URGE A NO VOTE ON THIS MOTION.
THANK SENATOR GROW FROM FOR
JUST. OR DEBATE. CENTER
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I AM A STUDENT OF
THIS INSTITUTION. I HOLD THE
CONSTITUTION IN THE GREATEST
REVERENCE THAT ANYONE CAN. THE
GENIUS OF OUR CONSTITUTION AND
THE FRAMEWORK THAT HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED AT ITS CORE IS UMAN.
WE ARE FACING AN EXTRAORDINARY
GLOBAL PANDEMIC. WE AS A BODY
TRYING TO REPRESENT THE NEAR
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE THAT
REPRESENT OUR TRYING TO CONDUCT
OUR BUSINESS IN A WAY THAT
CREATES THE GREATEST LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCESSIBILITY
TO THOSE IN THIS BUILDING WHO
ARE SUBJECT TO THE- TO THE TO
THE RISK TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
STAFF EVERYBODY INVOLVED. AS
WELL AS TO A PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO THE PUBLIC TO BE
HEARD. WE SAW LAST YEAR'S WE
TRY TO COME UP WITH WAYS TO
BALANCE THOSE INTERESTS THAT WE
HAD HEARINGS THAT LASTED INTO
THE WEE HOURS OF THE MORNING.
WE HAD MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
SITTING ON PHONE LINES FOR
SEVEN EIGHT HOURS THAT WAS
WRONG. WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE IS
A REQUEST TO PROVIDE SOME
ABILITY TO IN FACT INCREASE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE. WE ONLY HAVE TWO
HEARING ROOMS BECAUSE WE CAN'T
SOCIAL INJUSTICE THIS CHAMBER
AND FORTY TWO OH THREE. HOW DO
WE MANAGE A SEVEN WEEK SCHEDULE
AS A SENATE. THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE
TO PARTICIPATE TO NOT SIT ON
THE PHONE FOR SEVEN OR EIGHT
HOURS AS THEY'VE DONE BEFORE.
WHAT WE DO IS WE INCREASE THE
TIME PERIOD WHICH IS THE
UNDERLYING REASON FOR THIS VERY
LIMITED REQUEST TO SUSPEND THE
JOINT RULES IN THE CONSTITUTION
TO ALLOW US TO HAVE HEARINGS
TWO IN THE MORNING AND TWO IN
THE AFTERNOON. TO ALLOW PEOPLE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE TO BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE ONE OF THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES NOT
ONLY THE PEOPLE OF THE WAIT SO
LONG BUT THAT ACTUALLY THEY
WERE THAT MANY PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE. THEY DIDN'T TRAVEL
TO SACRAMENTO TO AS WE FACE
THIS EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGE
FOR THE PANDEMIC EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES REQUIRE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO BE
EXTRAORDINARY. AND I WOULD JUST
SUGGEST THAT YES THIS IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO DO. BUT UNDER
CIRCUMSTANCES ANYTHING LESS I
WOULD SAY I WOULD JOIN. US
SENATOR GROSVENOR POINT OF VIEW
BUT I THINK THAT UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN THE VIDEO PER
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE PEOPLE THE
ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE THIS IS
A THOUGHTFUL AND REASONABLE
SOLUTION THAT TO ME IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE UNDERLYING
FRAMEWORK OF OUR CONSTITUTION I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THE MOTION.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
MEMBERS ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CENTERVILLE'S. NOT A
PRIVILEGE ON THIS I THE MADE
REFERENCE TO THIS BEFORE QUITE
OFTEN THAT I REPEATED RIGHT NOW.
AS FAR AS. IT THE INPUT OF THE
PA. WE REALLY DON'T DO THAT
HERE PROTECTING IN THE
COMMITTEES. WE'RE ALLOWING THE
PRESENTER. THEN WATER PEOPLE
SAYING I LIKE THE BILL AND GET
SUMMARIES. THANK FOR THE
OPPOSITION. EVERYBODY FROM OF
THESE PEOPLE FIT HOURS ON THE
PHONE. THEY GET SAY. I'M JAMES.
J. I'M AGAIN THAT ALL. I SUBMIT
IS NOT PUBLIC AND I HAVE THIS
NOT BEEN TO THAT. IN THE- BUT
I'M GOING TO BEGIN TO. THAT IS
NOT WHICH PUBLIC INPUT JUST
TAKE CAL. THE AS YOU PRIORITIZE
YOUR MAIL LOAD AND PUT SURE THE
MASH FOR OF LETTERS COME IN.
YOU DON'T GET A PRICE EVERYONE
YOU GOTTA TELL. WHICH IS THE
ONLY WAY WE COULD DO. RIGHT NOW
WE ARE BY I SEE THE CAR TO MORE
IN. THAT'S JUST TAKE A CAB THEN
BY A LOT OF TIME IT'S NOT
PUBLIC INPUT ALL YOU DO IS SAY
I JIM I'M AGAINST. THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON. THING NO
FURTHER JUST. OR DEBATE SAID
ATKINS WOULD YOU LIE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU YES MA'AM PER. I
WOULD JUST MAKE A CUP OF FINAL.
OF THE- ACTS ALLOW LA. TO TAKE
ACTION SUCH AS THIS. AND I
FURTHER SAY IT IS A RESPONSE
ACTION. THIS YEAR WE'VE HAD
OVER A WE HAD EIGHT HUNDRED AND
NINE BILLS- SUBMITTED. OVER TWO
HUNDRED OF THOSE ARE SPOT BILLS
WHICH MEANS MORE INFORMATION
NEEDS TO BE PROVIDED BEFORE
THEY ARE SET FOR HEARING AT
COMMITTEES. LAST YEAR MEMBERS
IN THE SENATE AND I WANT TO
AGAIN THANK YOU REDUCE THEIR
BILL LOAD SIGNIFICANTLY BECAUSE
OF THE SITUATION THAT WE WERE
IN WITH THE PANDEMIC AND THE
UNCERTAINTY. THIS YEAR WE HAVE
SOME MORE CERTAINTY BUT WE ALSO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SCHEDULE
THINGS APPROPRIATELY SO THAT
PEOPLE WILL BE SAFE PROTECTED
AND WE CONTINUE TO ALLOW PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. I THINK ONE OF
THE BENEFITS OF OUR DECISION AS
A SENATE BODY TO ALLOW REMOTE
PARTICIPATION AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. WAS TO ENSURE THAT
MEMBERS OF THE GENERAL PUBLIC
PEOPLE THAT DON'T USUALLY GET
TO COME UP HERE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN- AND AT
LEAST SAY THEIR NAME WHERE THEY
RESIDE AND THAT THEY AGREE OR
DISAGREE. AND I THINK THAT HAS
BEEN SOMETHING I HOPE WE FIND A
WAY TO CONTINUE BEYOND THIS
PANDEMIC TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF
MEMBERS OF THE GENERAL PUBLIC
SO. I THINK THIS IS A
RESPONSIBLE ACTION I THINK IT
IS DUE. TO WHAT THE MAJORITY
LEADER HAS SAID IN TERMS OF US
TRYING TO BE RESPONSIBLE AND
YET DO OUR BUSINESS I SAID THAT
OUR BILLS WERE SIGNIFICANTLY
CUT LAST YEAR. THIS WOULD BE A
SECOND YEAR IN WHICH WE AS
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE.
OUGHT WERE WE TO ACT
DIFFERENTLY AND DO WHAT WE DID
LAST YEAR AND REALLY PUSH TO
CUT OUR BILL LOAD. WOULD NOT BE
DOING THE JOB THAT WE FEEL LIKE
WE NEED TO DO TO PRESENT
LEGISLATION SO. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THIS BODY TO SUPPORT
THIS ACTION FOR THIS CALENDAR
YEAR. GIVEN ALL OF THE COMMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE. BY MYSELF
IN THE MAJORITY LEADER THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT VIRGIN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
MEMBER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA.
HI ATKINS. AYE BATES I BAKER.
FIVE PORGES. BRADFORD. I HAVE
ITEM HI PROTESTING FIVE DALLY.
NO DODD. FIVE THE RYZEN FIVE
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG. I HUESO
BY HER TADO I JONES. LAYARD I
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S
NO MAN BYE NEWMAN. FIVE NIELSEN
NO- CHAU VOGUE I PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO HI RALPH FIVE RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER. I STERN HI I'M
BURKE I WAKE CAL SKI I WIENER I
WILK HI. FIVE THIRTY TWO KNOWS
FOR THEM CARE THINKING MEMBER.
WE'RE STILL MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. Q. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH THROUGH
EIGHTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED
BY THE MINUTE CLASS. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO AA WILL BE WAIVED FOR
THE BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE TO MEET ON THURSDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY FIFTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITHOUT FOUR DAYS
NOTICE TO THE DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO SENATE THIRD READING WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM.
NUMBER. SIX MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTEEN BY SENATOR SKINNER AND
AFTER LEADING TO THE BUDGET ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. CENTERS
SKINNER. HE WAS BORN IN. OKAY
YEAH. YEAH. YEAH WHEN MOMENT.
THANK YOU MADAM MEMBERS AND-
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
ONE MOMENT. THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES. WHICH IS AN
ACCOMPLISHED IN SB THIRTEEN AND
OTHERS ARE BEING SENT OVER TO
THE ASSEMBLY FOR THE PURPOSES
OF BECOMING BUDGET VEHICLES AND
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE SENDING A
SIMILAR NUMBER OF BILLS TO OUR
HOUSE THESE BILLS ARE VEHICLES
WHICH WILL ULTIMATELY BE
AMENDED TO EITHER BE A BUDGET
BILL WORRY BUDGET TRAILER BILL.
THE LANGUAGE THAT WE ULTIMATELY
VOTE ON WILL BE ADDED TO THESE
BILLS AS WE VET THEM THROUGH
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS AND THEN
ULTIMATELY THE FLOOR. SO THE
ACTION WE ARE TAKING HOURS
SIMPLY AND SOLELY A PROCEDURAL
STEP. FOR THOSE WHO MAY WONDER
ABOUT THE NUMBER THAT WERE
ACTING ON NOW IN PREVIOUS YEARS
WE HAVE DONE. A BILL SWAP.
MULTIPLE TIMES OVER THE COURSE
OF A SESSION. FOR THIS YEAR WE
ARE DECIDED TO DO THE SWAP IN
ONE ACTION BECAUSE SO FAR THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION WE HAVE
ALREADY NEEDED TO SUCH
VEHICLES. AND TODAY WE ARE
VOTING ON SEVEN SUCH MEANING WE
ARE VOTING ON SEVEN BILLS THAT
HAD THAT WERE SWAPS FROM THE
PAST. AND WITH THE EXPECTED
FEDERAL ACTION AND OTHER
ACTIVITY WE KNOW THAT THIS YEAR
WILL BE VERY ACTIVE IN
RELATIONSHIP TO BUDGET BILLS.
AND WITH THAT I ASKED FOR AND I
DON'T THINK YOU CENTER SKINNER.
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SENATOR NIELSEN. NOT A
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN OF THE
SENATE ON THE- OF THE FOUR
PLEASE PROCEED. ON THE
CONDITION OF THE- EVERY YEAR.
WE UNDERSELL ELSON SENATE ONE I
WAS HARD I'M SHOOTING I GOT
AHEAD OF. PARDON ME SENATOR
NEAL YOU MAY SPEAK THIS. AND
LET US KNOW WHAT YOUR FEELINGS
ARE ON IT BUT YOU CANNOT SPEAK
ON CONDITION OF THE FILE TO THE
END OF THE SESSION SO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SAY WHATEVER YOU'RE
GOING TO SAY. YES I NEED TO I
WOULD REQUEST PERMISSION TO DO
SO BEFORE WE BEGIN VOTING ON
THAT LONG LIST OF. AFTER WE
CLOSE THE ROLE IN THIS VOTE
THAT'LL ASK YOU TO SPEAK ON
CONDITION OF THE FILE THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. FIVE ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES NO BACKER. I
PORGES. BRADFORD. FIVE CABRERA
I PRETENDING I DALY NO DODD. HI
THERE. I EGGMAN. FIVE GLAZER.
FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG. I HUESO. I HER TADO
HI JONES. NO LAYERED I LEYVA
FIVE MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ NO MAN
I NEWMAN. I NIELSEN. NO A TROVE
OF. NO PAN FIVE PORTANTINO BY
ROSS I RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER FIVE
STERN FIVE AMBERG FIVE WACO SKI
I WIENER. I WILK. NOW HIS
TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES CENTER NELSON
PLEASE NOW IN ADDITION THE
FILENET AND PRESIDENT PLEASE
PROCEED. BUT LAYS DOWN ON THIS
I'VE RAISED OF THIS AND MIKE AS
ALL THE EVEN ALLOW BY THAT.
PROLIFERATION OF SO CALLED BY
TRAILER BILL. THESE ARE FOR
THEY ARE FOR THE STATURE TO
CHANGE REQUIRE. TO UP THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BUDGET AND
EVERY THE NUMBERS INCREASE NOW
APPROACHING NINETY OR MORE. IN
HIS HOUSE NO SOME OF THE BOOK
GIVEN WILL NOT BE BRING IN ALL
THAT MANY UP BUT WHEN YOU GET
IN THE NUMBERS OF NINETY. YOU
CANNOT CONVINCE ME THAT THEY'RE
ALL NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BUDGET. AND
WHAT DOES HAPPEN A LOT OF FUN
AND GAMES OCCURS IN THESE BILLS
THAT ARE NOT THROUGH THE
DELIVERY PROCESS OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. AND EVEN
SHORT CIRCUITED IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES. SO THEREFORE THE
PUBLIC THROUGH US DO NOT HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON AND FUN GAMES ARE
INDEED. INVOLVED AND
INCORPORATED IN THE STATE OF
BILLS. I WOULD ASK US TO
DISCIPLINE OURSELVES
PARTICULARLY SINCE WE SEEM TO
HAVE SUCH A PROBLEM PROCESSING
LEGISLATION HERE. LET'S NOT BE
CARING AND ADDING TO THE BURDEN
WHAT CAN AVAIL SPOT WELDS NO
KNOWS WHAT YOU VOTE FOR. I
WOULD JUST STICK A CLASH TO THE
SAN. THANK YOU SAID NIELSEN
MEMBERS THE- BILLS WILL BE READ
A THIRD TIME. SO BILLS ONE
FORTY THREE OH TWO. FILE ITEMS
TO NINETY FIVE IF THERE'S NO
OBJECTION THE PREVIOUS ROLL
CALL OF ICE TWENTY NINE. KNOWS
EIGHT WILL BE APPLIED TO SENATE
BILLS ONE FOURTEEN THROUGH
TWELVE- TO. THING OF JACKSON
THE BILLS ARE PASSED THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
ONE OH FOUR SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. AB EIGHTY FIVE IS A
CENTERS IN OUR APOLOGIZE FOR MY
MISTAKE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
SECRETARY READ YES. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTY FIVE BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND ACTUALLY INTO THE STATE
BUDGET AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BELT.
SENATOR SKINNER THANK YOU. AB
EIGHTY FIVE IS A BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY.
HIGHLIGHTS OF THIS BILL INCLUDE
APPROXIMATELY NINE HUNDRED AND
NINETY THREE MILLION FOR THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS GRANT
PAYMENTS TO CAL WORKS. AND FSI
S. S. P. OR CAPPY RECIPIENTS
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT MORE IN
THAT ACTION. TWO HUNDRED FORTY
TWO MILLION TO DISREGARD
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION FROM BEING
CONSIDERED AS INCOME FOR CAL
WORKS ELIGIBILITY. THIRTY
MILLION AUGMENTATION FOR FOOD
BANKS AND FIVE MILLION FOR
DIAPER BANKS. TWENTY FOUR
MILLION FOR THE HOUSING FOR THE
HARVEST PROGRAM TO ASSIST
FARMWORKERS. A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION FOR A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOR MERGING SEA STUDENT
AID AND STUDENT RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION TO ADDRESS WHAT WE'VE
SEEN WHICH IS A DROP IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ENROLLMENT.
FIVE POINT THREE MILLION TO
EXTEND FAMILY WAIVERS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS ON AB EIGHTY
FIVE. THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER.
SENATOR WILL FOR WHAT PURPOSE
ZERO. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I HAVE A AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK.
THANK YOU SENATOR- WILK MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
AMENDMENT. AMENDMENTS BY
SENATOR WILK SENT ONE. PLEASE
PROCEED SENATOR WILK THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT AMENDMENTS BEFORE
YOU REMOVE THE FIRST FOUR
SECTIONS OF THIS BILL THAT
RETROACTIVELY AUTHORIZES A
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
VOTER REACH CONTRACT.
UNDERTAKEN BY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE LAST YEAR. AND
HE'S A MINISTER FOR TWO FOLD
ONE WE ARE ADVOCATING OUR POWER
TO THE MINISTRATION. BY IT BY
APPROVING THIS CONTRACT THAT WE
DID NOT AUTHORIZE. THE NUMBER
TO THE FIRM THAT WAS HIRED TO
DO THIS WITHOUT THE PROPER
PROCEDURES IN PLACE ALSO RAN
NUMEROUS- POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS.
THEY RAN FOR- HIGHLY TARGETED
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS AND THEN
ONE TARGETED SENATE SEAT I AM
MADE THE REQUEST OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE FOR ALL THE
DOCUMENTATION CONCERNING THESE
CONTRACTS. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY WERE IN FACT PROPER I
THINK WHEN WE SHOULD NOT IT WE
SHOULD. SUPPORT THIS AMENDMENT
ONE BECAUSE IT'S GOOD
GOVERNANCE NUMBER TWO I DON'T
WANT TO SEE US END UP WITH EGG
ON OUR FACE IF IT COMES BACK
THAT THE WORK PRODUCT WAS
ACTUALLY POLITICAL AND NOT GOOD
GOVERNMENT SO WITH THAT. I ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT TODAY'S
AMENDMENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
WELCOME SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY A MATTER PER I MOVE LADY
MAY ON THE TWO. THANK YOU
CENTER. CENTER HERTZBERG SAYS
FOR AN VOTE TO LAY THE MOVE ON
THE TO. AND SAID CAUSE HALF FOR
AND VOTE SIR PLEASE THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES. NO BAKER. FIVE FOR
JUST NO BRADFORD I CABRERA I
CORTESE I DALLY NO DODD I
DURAZO I EGGMAN FIVE PLEASE. HI
CAN. I GREW. NO HURTS FOR. I
HUESO I HER TADO I JONES NO
LAYERED I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MULLIN. NO MAN. FIVE NEWMAN
FIVE NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO A
TRUCK VOEPEL. I ROTH I RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER. FIVE STERN FIVE
I'M BURKE HI KELSEY I WIENER
AYE WILK. NO TWENTY NINE NEWS
NINE THE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
LAID ON THE TABLE MEMBERS WE
WILL GO BACK TO THE BILL IN
CHIEF IS THERE ANYONE WHO HAS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
BILL IN CHIEF. CENTER DOLLY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT JUST
WANTED. TO SAY THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF GOOD THINGS IN THIS
BILL. AND WE HEARD IT DURING
BUDGET AND I DID BRING UP THE
FACT THAT THERE IS THE THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. THAT IS
THE LAST YEAR'S CONTRACT AND
SO. FOR THOSE REASONS I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW WE SHOULD. NEVER
ALLOW. A ONE OF OUR AGENCIES TO
GO OUT AND DO AN R. F. P. WITH
A HANDFUL. OF- WILL BE ABLE TO
APPLY FOR IT AND NOT DO IT IN
THE DAYLIGHT AND SO. FOR THOSE
REASONS I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL I THINK IT'S WRONG.
THAT WERE SLIPPING IN. THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FROM LAST
YEAR'S CONTRACT IT IS- QUITE
FRANKLY THERE'S A LAWSUIT ABOUT
SO FOR THOSE REASONS. I URGE A
NO VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
CENTER DOLLY SEVERAL CHOI BOGUE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE WITH CONCERNS
ABOUT ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY FIVE
THIS HAS SO MUCH GOOD IN IT
MONEY FOR A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY FUNDING FOR
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS TWENTY FOUR
CHILD CARE IN OUR CAL WORKS
FAMILY MANY OF WHOM I'M HERE TO
ADVOCATE. ON THEIR BEHALF. YEAH
THERE'S A PORTION OF IT THAT
SEEKS TO MAKE AN ILLEGAL
CONTRACT LEGAL BY RETROACTIVELY
CHANGING STATUTES. AFTER TAKING
TIME TO REVIEW THE BILL I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
TODAY. BUT I HAVE GRAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PROCESS. AS
A FRESHMAN LEGISLATOR
LEGISLATOR I'M DISAPPOINTED
THAT A BILL WITH SO MANY GOOD
THINGS AS AN ITEM THAT IS
CURRENTLY SO CONTROVERSIAL.
MOVING FORWARD I'M READY TO
WORK WIH ALL MY COLLEAGUES TO
DEVELOP POLICIES THAT ARE IN
THE BEST INTERESTS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR OCHO BOGUE CENTER
BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I HAVE A HARD TO
BEGIN WITH I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR. IF
FIVE THE- SHE WOULD BE WILLING
TO TAKE THOSE. SENATE RATES I'M
SORRY WHAT DID YOU SAY. I HAVE
A COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR IF SHE'S WILLING TO TAKE
THAT. YEAH THERE ARE USUALLY
TAKES I'M GOING TO TAKE
QUESTIONS YES PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU- THE AMERICAN WITH MY
COLLEAGUES WHO PREVIOUSLY
SPOKEN THAT THERE IS A LOT OF
GOOD IN THE BILL THAT I THINK
THAT THE ISSUE REGARDING THE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. HI
TO COVER THE SECRETARY OF STATE
EXPENDITURE FOR LOCAL ELECTIONS
IS THE ONE THAT'S VERY VERY
QUESTIONABLE SO I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK- IF THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE HAS INDICATED THAT THE
AMENDMENT IS ADEQUATE TO
ADDRESS HER CONCERNS. AND
NUMBER TWO CAN FEDERAL FUNDS I
THINK THERE'S TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT UNDER THE HELP AMERICA
VOTE ACT LAWFULLY BE USED FOR
THE GET OUT THE VOTE
ACTIVITIES. AND I'D LIKE TO
RESPONSIBILITIES AND THEN ON I
WILL SPEAK ON MY OWN. YEAH
THANK YOU. FIVE FIVE- MEMBERS.
PLEASE OKAY. YES SO WE HAVE
BEFORE US IS A TECH FIX THAT
BOTH THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAVE WORKED OUT WHICH CORRECTS
WHAT WAS RAISED BY THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AS
AMBIGUITY IN THE LANGUAGE AND
THEY BOTH NOW BOTH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AN THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AGREED
THAT THIS LANGUAGE REMOVES THAT
PAYING. AMBIGUITY AND IN
RELATIONSHIP TO. THE FEDERAL
QUESTION THIS PROGRAM THAT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE PROGRAM. WAS
AFTER STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS THAT
WERE CONVENE WITH COUNTY
OFFICIALS AND THE WORK GROUP OF
COUNTY OFFICIALS INC AND OTHERS
RECOMMENDED THE STATE WIDE
CONTRACT FOR PUBLIC EDUCATION.
NONPARTISAN AIMED AT VOTERS WHO
ARE VOTING BY MAIL FOR THE
FIRST TIME AND WHO SPOKE EIGHT
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH SO
THAT'S WHAT THE PROGRAM WAS
DANTE AGAIN IN ANSWER TO THE
DIRECT QUESTION ABOUT THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE YES THIS
MEETS THE NEEDS OF THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AND IS AN
AGREEMENT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
HI MY OWN TIME MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU FOR THAT RESPONSE. I
THINK IT KIND OF MISSES THE
POINT HERE SO I DO URGE
OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE.
RETROACTIVELY CHANGING THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
ALLOWED THE VERSION OF MORE
THAN THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE AND FEDERAL
MONEY. MEANT TO HELP COUNTIES
AND I WAS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR
AND I KNOW THAT THAT MANY
DURING OUR ELECTION IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT- IT HELPS
COUNTIES COVER THE COSTS OF
HOLDING ELECTION DURING A
PANDEMIC. I TO A PARTISAN AND
POLITICALLY CONNECTED FIRMS WAS
JUST NOT RIGHT IT IS WRONG FOR
ALL OF OUR COUNTIES IS WRONG
FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS THE FIRM
THAT WAS SELECTED PRETTY
PROMINENTLY STATED ON ITS
WEBSITE. THAT IT WAS ON TEAM
BYTON IT ALSO IT IS ALSO THE
CASE OF THE FIRM WAS DOING WOK
ON SEVERAL TARGETED
CONGRESSIONAL RACES IN
CALIFORNIA. THE CONTRACTOR NOT
COMPLY WITH THE PUBLIC CONTRAST
CODE AND THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
BROUGHT UP. IN THE DISCUSSION
HERE TODAY THERE'S A QUESTION
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDS UNDER THE HELP AMERICA
VOTE ACT CAN LAWFULLY BE USED
FOR GET OUT THE VOTE
ACTIVITIES. AND I WAS HERE WHEN
THIS INCIDENT OCCURRED WHEN
PRIOR SECRETARY OF STATE KEVIN
SHELLEY HAD TO RESIGN. DUE TO
HIS MISUSE OF HAVE A FUNDING.
ARE YOU SURE THIS BILL DOES NOT
TAKE THE LEGISLATURE DOWN A
PATH OF MISUSE OF HAVE A FUNDS
I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT THE
ISSUES SURROUNDING THE SHADY
CONTRACTOR CURRENT. LEASE
SUBJECT TO LITIGATION WHY WOULD
WE THE SENATE WANT TO GET IN
THE MIDDLE OF SUCH A MASS RIGHT
NOW. LET'S GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THESE ISSUES LET'S SEE WHAT
COMES THROUGH THE AUDIT OF THE
CONTRACT. AND RATHER THAN TURN
OUR BACK ON IT NOW I URGE YOU
KNOW THE- THANK YOU SENATOR.
SAID MELINDA. THANK YOU MAY
PRESIDENT I WOULD AGREE WITH
THE COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND JUST ADD
THAT I TO RISE. IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL AND SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE OF THIS THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR CONTRACT WHICH
IT SEEMS WE ARE TRYING TO
RETROACTIVELY SAY WAS
APPROPRIATE WHEN IN FACT. IT
WASN'T APPROPRIATE WHICH IS WHY
THE BILL WAS NEVER PAID WE SAW
THIS THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
JUST SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WE'VE SEEN
THIS WE SAW THIS. WITH THE
FEDERAL MONEY THAT CAME IN FOR
HOMEOWNERS WERE UNDERWATER THAT
THE BROWN ADMINISTRATION AND
DECIDE TO USE FOR SOMETHING
ELSE AFTER THE FACT. THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A BILL IN
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE I BELIEVE.
THAT SAID IT'S OKAY THEY WE DID
IT RETROACTIVELY NINETY I JUST
DON'T THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE
WAY TO HANDLE THIS FOR THOSE
REASONS- I WILL BE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL JAY THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
MELINDA'S SENATOR JONES DID YOU
HAVE YOUR MICROPHONE UP. THANK
YOU. SENATOR ATKINS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS HI-
FIRST WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FROM BERKELEY ARE BUDGET CHAIR
FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL AND
OTHERS THAT WE WILL HAVE BEFORE
US TODAY I WANT TO THANK HER
FOR HER LEADERSHIP AS WELL AS
THAT OF THE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE CHAIRS AND EFFECT ALL
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES FOR THEIR WORK BOTH
ON THE ONGOING BUDGET AND THE
EARLY ACTIONS SUCH AS THOSE
WILL BE TAKEN TODAY. COLLEAGUES
WE ARE IN A YEAR OUR A YEAR
INTO FIGHTING COVERT NINETY
NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE A HALF A MILLION PEOPLE.
HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES IN OUR
NATION. COUNTLESS LIVES
DISRUPTED AND SO MANY DREAMS
DELAYED. OUR ACTIONS TODAY WILL
ONCE AGAIN PROVIDE MORE RELIEF
FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING IN THE WAKE OF ALL
OF THE DAMAGE COVERED NINETEEN
HAS CAUSED. THE RELIEF WE
PROVIDE TODAY WILL HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN TRIED SO HARD THIS
PAST YEAR JUST TO KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON. THE RELIEF WE
PROVIDE TODAY WILL HELP ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN HIT HARD
BY THE PANDEMIC AREN'T LEFT
OUT. OR LEFT BEHIND FROM THE
HELP THAT WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
AND COLLEAGUES I'M ASKING FOR
TWO THINGS FROM YOU TODAY
YOU'RE AYE VOTE OF COURSE. BUT
I ALSO ASK FOR YOUR AGREEMENT
THAT WE AREN'T DONE HERE. THIS
WORK ISN'T DONE. THERE'S MUCH
MORE THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES AND THERE'S
MORE FOR US TO DO SO LET'S
PASSED THE BILLS BEFORE US
TODAY AND GET RIGHT BACK TO
WORK FINDING MORE WAYS TO HELP
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES OUR
SCHOOLS AND OUR COMMUNITIES
MADAM PRESIDENT I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MADAM
PROTON CENTERS CAN OR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I THANK YOU
MADAM I THINK WE HAD A GREAT.
DISCUSSION SO FAR AND- IT'S A
GOOD BILL I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
BEEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES NO BAKER FIVE
PORGES NOPE BRADFORD. HI
CABALLERO. HI CORTESE FIVE
DALLY NO DODD. HI TORONTO HI
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ FIVE
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG AYE HUESO.
HI HER TADO HI JONES NO LAYERED
I LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ NO MAN HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO A TURBO. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH. FIVE RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER. FIVE STERN HI I'M
BURKE HI WACO SKI HI WIENER AYE
WILK. NO. THERE WE GO FIVE
THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE OH TWO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANG AN ACT
RELATING TO THE CODED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY DAHLE
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. CENTER
SKINNER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. AB EIGHTY
TWO PROVIDE PRISON PROVIDES US
THE ABILITY TO VOTE ON THE
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING AND
I WILL GIVE YOU THE SPECIFICS.
THAT APPROVES AN ADDENDUM TO
SEIU LOCAL ONE THOUSAND THOSE
ARE STATE WORKERS. REGARDING
EMPLOYEES THAT HAVE BEEN
ASSIGNED TO ASSIST WITH CORBETT
NINETEEN CONTRACT TRACING. AND
PROVIDES ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION FOR THIS PURPOSE. IT
ALSO PROVIDES. FOR ALLOWS US TO
GET OUT THE DOOR FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION IN ONE TIME FEDERAL
STIMULUS FUNDS TO PROVIDE
STATEMENTS TO CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS EXPAND ACCESS TO
CHILD CARE FOR ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. AND PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
PAID NON OPERATIONAL DAYS FOR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS WHO HAVE
CLOSED DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
INCERTAE INCLUDES APPROVING AN
AMMO YOU WITH THE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS UNITED. IN WITHOUT
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU VENTURE WE HEARD THIS IN
BUDGET I JUST WANT TO STAND UP
AND SAY I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THAT THERE'S ONE THING THAT'S
REALLY TOUGH FOR. EMILY'S IS
FINDING A PLACE TO PUT. IT
WOULD HAVE THEIR CHILDREN GO. A
DURING THESE TIMES AND YOU KNOW
WITH ALL OF THE- CHILDREN OF
LEARNING FROM HOME. AND IF YOU
DO STILL HAVE YOUR JOB YOU NEED
A PLACE FOR CHILDREN GO SO
THESE. CHILD CARE CENTERS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT. AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A MO YOU IN HERE I
LOOKED IT OVER IT'S FOR. THOSE
WHO WERE OUT OF CLASS AND I
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE SO I.
URGE AN AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER DOLLY. CENTER
GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I TO RACE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL WANT TO THANK THE
BUDGET CHAIR FOR THE VIGOROUS
DEBATE THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
HAVE ON THIS. PIECE OF
LEGISLATION LAST WEEK- I AGREE
WITH MY SENATORS THE SENATOR MY
COLLEAGUES- COMMENTS FROM
BEAVER. IT ALSO SAYS IT AFTER
YOU KNOW HAVING CHILDREN AT
HOME OR DISTANCE WITH LEARNING
OUR CHILD CARE WITH LEARNING.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO FIND A
CHILD CARE FACILITY THAT WOULD
BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
KIDS- SO I JUST APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT WAS DONE ON THIS BILL
AND I ASKED FOR. AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS BILL. BUT THE CENTER ROVE
MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. HEARING AND SEEING
THAT MADAM SECRETARY BURKE
SKEWS ME SANDERS CAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. YES THANK YOU
AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. WELL
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA. AYE
ATKINS. AYE BATES FIVE BAKER
FIVE FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I PROTECTING HI DALLY
FIVE DODD. FIVE TORONTO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ
FIVE GROWTH. I HERTZBERG AYE
HUESO. HI HER TADO FIVE JONES.
FIVE LAYERED I LEYVA FIVE WIRE
I MELINDA'S FIVE MILLION I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. FIVE A CHILD
BOTH FIVE PAN AYE PORTANTINO I
ROTH AYE RUBIO. HI SKINNER. HI
STERN. HI I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT
HI WHAT KIND OF SKI. I WIENER.
FIVE WILK. HI FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
A ONE OH ONE SENATOR SKINNER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY ONE BY SEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STAYING AND
ACTUALLY LEADING TO COVET
NINETEEN RELIEF AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. CENTERS GONNA.
THANK YOU. MADAM PRESIDENTE
MEMBERS. ONE MOMENT WHERE I
HAVE MANY BILLS 2% FROM A
NUMBER OF THINGS TO A MAKE SURE
HAVE THE RIGHT PIECE OF PAPER
PERCENT. SO THIS BILL IS PART
OF THE GENERAL FEDERAL RELIEF
TRAILER BILL TO THE SENATE TO
IMPLEMENT CHANGES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET.
AND WHAT IT DOES IS PROVIDE
SOME. UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION
CONFORMITY SO THAT WE THOSE
FOLKS WHO ARE ON THE F. DEAD
WITH THE CALL FED ED.
UNEMPLOYMENT CAN- THAT IT WOULD
NOT BE- THAT IT WOULD BE
AUTHORIZED IMMEDIATELY BY THE-STATE AND WAVE THE THIRTEEN
WEEK PERIOD TO TRIGGER OFF- IT
ALSO INCLUDES SOME SLIGHT.
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP IN
CONFORMING CHANGES TO OUR
TENANT RELIEF ACT SO THAT A
CLEAR FIGHTS WERE THE LANGUAGE
SAID UP 280% MEANING THE
COMPENSATION TO THE LANDLORD TO
PARTICIPATE. THE INTENT OF THE
BILL AND IS- IT'S CLEAR IN THE
OTHER LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT
THAT MEANT. THEY WILL RECEIVE
THE LANDLORDS WILL RECEIVE 80%
AND SO WE ARE JUST CLARIFYING
THAT THE UP TO IN FACT MEANS
THE LANDLORDS PARTICIPATING
WILL RECEIVE EIGHTY PERCENT. WE
ALSO FIX ONE. DRAFTING ERROR
WHERE THERE IS A DATE THAT SAID
AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY ONE OR ALL
OTHER DATE SAID AUGUST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND THAT DATE SHOULD
BE AUGUST TWENTY TWO. IT ALSO.
FOR LANGUAGE THAT- WHERE ONE'S
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION WHICH
IS CONFORMITY WITH THE FEDERAL
RULES WOULD NOT BE UTILIZED
AGAINST YOU FOR QUALIFYING FOR
YOUR CAL WORKS ELIGIBILITY. AND
PROVIDES SOME FUNDING TO ALLOW
FIVE MILLION IN FUNDING TO
ALLOW THE FIFTY B. TO CONDUCT
OUTREACH FOR THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS WHICH IS THE NEXT BILL
WE WILL BE ACTING ON IN WITHOUT
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU CENTER SKINNER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SENATOR GORGEOUS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST WANTED
TO ADD MY SUPPORT- TO S. B.
NINETY TWO OR A. B. EIGHTY ONE-
I THINK AS WE'VE GONE THROUGH.
THIS EXTRAORDINARY PROCESS OF
PROTECTING RENTERS THAT WE ALSO
HAD TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT WE
ALLOWED FOR PROVISIONS THAT
WOULD PROTECT LANDLORDS
SPECIALLY- MOM AND POP
LANDLORDS. AND THIS FEDERAL
PASS THROUGH I THINK IT'S GONNA
BE TERRIBLY HELPFUL I STILL DO
BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A
ROLE TO PLAY. THAT THIS MONEY
IS NOT ENOUGH FOR THE NEEDS
THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE THAT
WE MAY CONSIDER HAVING TO
INCLUDE CALIFORNIA DOLLARS IN
ADDITION TO WHAT WE'VE ALREADY
DONE THROUGH THE PASS THROUGH.
BUT I WANT TO THANK- THE
SENATOR FOR BRING THIS FORWARD-
AND WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. THIS IS A GOOD
THING. THANK YOU SENATOR
BORDERS MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
SANDERS CAN I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS ASK FOR YOUR
I. VOTE. WHEN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINSAYE BATES
AYE BAKER. FIVE FOR. AYE
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI
PRETENDING FIVE DALLY I DODD BY
THE RAZA FIVE EGGMAN I GLAZER.
FIVE GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH. FIVE
HERTZBERG FIVE HUESO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I LAYERED FIVE
LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE FIVE
MELINDA'S. MAN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. BY A SHOW BOTH. HI PAN
AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO.
I SKINNER I STERN I UNDERGONE
FIVE WORKOUTS SKI AYE WIENER. I
WILK. HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MELENDEZ. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A SLIGHT PAUSE STATER
SEATS DON'T GO ANYWHERE WILL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU.
MEMBERS WE
ARE WAITING ON A SUPPLEMENTAL
FILE FROM THE ASSEMBLY SO JUST-
HANG IN THERE WITH US.
MEMBERS
BECAUSE WE WANT TO BE EFFICIENT
WITH YOUR TIME I'M GOING TO ASK
EVERYONE TO PLEASE FIND THEIR
SEAT AND WE'RE GOING TO GO TO A
JOURNAL AND MEMORIES SO ONCE
EVERYONE IS SEATED WE WILL
START WITH SENATOR ALAN PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEAT WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO A JOURNAL MEMORIES WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILES. FROM THE
ASSEMBLY. YEAH ROBERT. SENATE
ALLEN PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
WHAT ARE YOU SO MUCH READING
PRESIDENT. I TODAY I RISE TO
TURN. IN THE MEMORY OF JANET
SALTER WHO IS A REMARKABLE
CALIFORNIA PASSED AWAY ON
HALLOWEEN OF LAST YEAR SHE LEFT
BEHIND A LEGACY OF GENEROSITY
SERVICE AND FAMILY. SHE WAS
BORN IN NINETEEN TWENTY TWO.
AND JANET WAS KNOWN TO HER
FRIENDS AND FAMILY IS AN
ENCHANTING LIVELY AND
POLITICALLY ACTIVE WOMEN WHO
INSPIRED THOSE AROUND HER WITH.
HER GENEROSITY AND IMAGINATION.
HI JANET OUR LATE HUSBAND
FORMER BEVERLY HILLS
MERRIMACK'S SALTER. TOGETHER
FOR SIXTY EIGHT YEARS OFTEN
ENTERTAIN WORLD DIGNITARIES AND
US PRESIDENTS INCLUDING GERALD
FORD RONALD REAGAN BILL
CLINTON. JOE BIDEN. IN FACT IN
THE EARLY SEVENTIES THE SALTERS
THROUGH JOE BIDEN AND HIS VERY
FIRST FUND RAISER IN LOS
ANGELES AND CHATTING WITH THEIR
AFTER REFER TO HER FRIEND AS-
BETTER BE PRESIDENT JOE.
FINALLY THAT WISH CAME TRE.
JANET WAS PARTICULARLY
PASSIONATE ABOUT THE ARTS AFTER
GRADUATING FROM OTIS COLLEGE
SHE BEGAN WORKING FOR HUNDRED
ROGERS PUBLICITY AGENCY CANIDS
CARTOONIST COLUMN MYSTERY HILLS
REINVENTED HIS CAREER FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS A TESTAMENT TO HER
WIT CREATIVITY AND ARTISTIC
TALENT. HE CHAIRED THE BOARDS
OF THE BEVERLY HILLS FINE ARTS
COMMISSION THAT BARELY HILLS
THEATER GUILD FOR DECADES YOU
STEP DOWN AT THE TENDER AGE OF
NINETY FIVE. SHE HELPED TO
RAISE MONEY FOR WRITERS AND
ARTISTS WHILE ENSURING ACCESS
TO THE FINE ARTS. FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME. JENNY WAS
KNOWN FOR HER HOSPITALITY AND
IMAGINATIVE PARTIES WHICH
INCLUDE BARK MITZVAHS FOR HER
DOGS. IN THE PSALTER SINGLES
GROUP FOR A LOCAL JEWISH
BACHELORS AND BACHELORETTES.
SHE OPENED HER HOME TO HUNDREDS
OF CHARITIES CANDIDATES
POLITICAL ORGANIZATIONS HELPING
TO RAISE MILLIONS FOR POLITICAL
AND PHILANTHROPIC CAUSES A
LIGHT. HER FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES DESCRIBED HER AS THE
MOST GENEROUS PERSON A NEW.
THING THAT SHE WAS SIMPLY
INCAPABLE OF SAYING NO WHEN
ASKED FOR HELP THE TWO TIME
BEVERLY HILLS MAYOR MY GOOD
FRIENDLY BOSSY. CALLS HER TRUE
GUARDIAN ANGEL OF OUR TIME. SHE
WAS BORN WHEN WARREN HARDING.
WAS PRESIDENT OF HER FIRST VOTE
FOR THE PRESIDENCY WAS FRANKLIN
DELANO ROOSEVELT NINETEEN.
FORTY I SHE WAS A LIFELONG
POLITICAL ACTIVIST AND SHE
CONSIDERED BEING MADE THAT BIG
TIME PUTTING ON A MY NIXON'S
ENEMIES LIST. AS ONE OF HER
LIFE'S GREATEST HONORS. IN THE
FINAL ACTION OF HER LIFE SHE
WAS ABLE TO VOTE FOR HER FRIEND
OVER FIFTY YEARS JOE BIDEN SHE-
PROUDLY WORE HER I VOTED
STICKER AS SHE LAY ON HER
DEATHBED AND I GUESS THE- ONE.
TRAGEDY WASN'T SHE DIDN'T QUITE
MAKE IT THERE TO SEE HIM
ELECTED TO THE PRESIDENCY.
JANET SURVIVOR HER THREE
CHILDREN- PEPPERED SALTER
ADMISSION MIKE SALTER. AND
LAURA SHIELDS TWELVE
GRANDCHILDREN FOURTEEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN INCLUDING THREE
GRANDCHILDREN TO I WENT TO.
HIGH SCHOOL WITH SCOTT DANN AND
MATT. AND IT'S WITH GREAT
SADNESS BUT ALSO JOINED THAT WE
CELEBRATE HER LIFE. SENATOR
ALAN BEFORE YOU PROCEED HERE
NEXT TO JOURNAL MEMORY MEMBERS
WE ARE DOING A JOURNAL MEMORIES
IT IS NOT APPROPRIATE TO BE
TALKING TO OTHER MEMBERS AND
PLEASE IF YOU CAN BE QUIET WE
ARE REMEMBERING THOSE WHO HAVE
LEFT US. SENATOR ALAN.
RECOMMENDED PRESIDENT THIS IS
A- WITH A PAIR OF. OF FOLKS WHO
I WANTED TO ASK OUR SENATE
INJURED IN MEMORY OF. A MEAL I
SAW FIRST OF ALL- BUT ALSO
MICHAEL WOFFORD. SO MIL ALSO
HAS A DEDICATED AND TALENTED
AMERICAN HE PASSED AWAY IN
SANTA MONICA SURROUNDED BY HIS
LOVING FAMILY. JUST RECENTLY I
LIVED FOR NEARLY A CENTURY. I
WAS BORN- JANUARY TWELFTH
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN IN BEIRUT
LEBANON AND HE AND HIS WIFE
MARIE IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED
STATES IN NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN.
TO PURSUE THE AMERICAN DREAM HE
EARNED A BACHELOR OF SCIENCE
DEGREE IN ELECTRICAL
ENGINEERING FROM MANHATTAN
COLLEGE IN NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. AND THEN IMMEDIATELY
WENT TO WORK FOR PEERLESS PUMP.
AS A SHOP ENGINEER AND THROUGH
HARD WORK ROSE THROUGH THE
RANKS TO RETIRE AS PRESIDENT
AND CEO AT THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE. HE CONTINUED HIS WORK AS
THE PRESIDENT AND CHAIRMAN OF
THE HYDRAULIC INSTITUTE. MEAL
IN HIS WIFE MARIE RAISED SIX
CHILDREN TOGETHER. HE MIGHT MY
DEAR FRIEND JEFF- THE MOVED
SEVERAL TIMES ACROSS FIVE
DIFFERENT STATES BUT A MEAL
ALWAYS CALL HOME CALIFORNIA
WHICH HE CONSIDERED GOD'S
COUNTRY BECAUSE OF OUR
BEAUTIFUL WEATHER LIFESTYLE AND
OPPORTUNITIES. HINA'S WIFE
MARIE WERE ALSO PATRONS OF THE
ARTS. THEY WANTED TO SHARE
THEIR LOVE OF OPERA AND
CLASSICAL MUSIC THEY BECAME
MEMBERS OF THE FOUNDER'S CIRCLE
AT THE MUSIC CENTER IN THE
ALLEY OPERA. MEAL IS SURVIVED
BY HIS LOVING WIFE MARIE. HIS
SIX CHILDREN TWELVE
GRANDCHILDREN AND COUNTLESS
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN ASSURING.
THAT HIS LEGACY. AND MEMORIES
WILL BE CELEBRATED BY
GENERATIONS TO COME. NOW WHILE
WE CELEBRATED MEALS LONG AND
WONDERFUL LIFE ON THIS EARTH.
IT IS WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I
MUST ALSO USE THIS TIME TO
HONOR A LIFE. CUT SHORT.
MICHAEL OFFERED HIS GRANDSON
CAMILLE'S GRANDSON PASSED AWAY
ON DECEMBER FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY
THE TENANT TENDER AGE OF TWENTY
FIVE. AFTER A DECADE LONG
BATTLE WITH ADDICTION. EVEN IN
THE SHORT LIFE MIKEY WILL BE
REMEMBERED BY HIS FAMILY AND
FRIENDS FOR HIS SPONTANEITY HIS
LOVE AND HIS BOUNDLESS EMPATHY.
AND SO IT'S WITH GREAT LOVE
THAT WE SAY FAREWELL. TO A MEAL
AND MIKEY. AND THEN FINALLY
HAVE A PRESIDENT IT'S WITH A
HEAVY HEART THAT I LIKE TO ASK
THE SENATE TO TURN IN THE
MEMORY OF TWELVE YEAR OLD MOLLY
STEIN SAPIR. WHO DIED JUST A
FEW DAYS AGO AFTER A DRAMATIC
BIKE ACCIDENT. HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PARENTS AND
CHILDREN FOLLOWED MALISSE
MEDICAL JOURNEY THROUGH HER
MOTHER KAELIN'S TWITTER FEED
SHARING THE UPS AND DOWNS EVERY
PATIENT PARENTS. WORST
NIGHTMARE. MOLLY WAS A ANIMAL
LOVING VEGETARIAN HAD A KEEN
INTEREST IN GOVERNMENT POLITICS
YOU ACTUALLY WANTED TO BE AN
ACTRESS OR POLITICIAN. DESPITE
RECEIVING TREMENDOUS CARE AT
UCLA MALI SUCCUMBED TO HER
INJURIES ON FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH.
I USED TO WORK WITH MOLLY'S
MOTHER WE WERE LAWYERS TOGETHER.
AND- AND THEN. HER FATHER LAWS
ACTUALLY A PARTNER MY WIFE'S
LAW FIRM. AND K. CASE CASE
PRINTER FEE BECAME A VERY
IMPORTANT PLACE FOR LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ALL OVER THE WORLD TO LEARN
ABOUT AND FOLLOW AND PRAY. FOR
THEIR WONDERFUL DAUGHTER. WHO
WAS WEARING A HELMET AND. AND
AND BUT BUT ULTIMATELY I HAD A
TERRIBLE ACTION ON A BICYCLE
AND ULTIMATELY SUCCUMBED TO
THOSE INJURIES AND PASSEDAWAY
AND K. HEAVY SPECIAL WORDS TO
SHARE WITH THE WORLD. MOLLY HAS
BEEN CALLED HOME TO GOD. WHILE
OUR HEARTS ARE BROKEN IN A WAY
THAT FEELS LIKE THEY CAN NEVER
BE AMENDED. WE TAKE COMFORT
KNOWING THAT MOLLY'S TWELVE
YEARS WILL BE WERE WERE FILLED
WITH LOVE AND JOY. WE ARE
IMMENSELY BLESSED. IF YOUR
PARENTS WE KNOW THAT SHE'S
WATCHING OVER US AND SMILING AT
HER TWO BELOVED LITTLE BROTHERS
NAY ANY LIE HER CAT LEROY IN A
DOG CALVIN. MEMBERS I HAVE MY
OWN LITTLE BOY. MY WIFE AND I
HAVE. TEARFULLY FOLLOWED THIS
THIS TRAGIC STORY OF MOLLY. MY
DEEPEST DEEPEST SYMPATHIES GO
TO K. THE ENTIRE STANCE OF A
FAMILY THE KEY LET ISRAEL
COMMUNITY MIND MY HOME
SYNAGOGUE. IT'S A TERRIBLE
TERRIBLE TRAGEDY HE WILL BE
MISSED AND I WANT TO SEND HER
FAMILY A BIG HUG AND OUR
DEEPEST SYMPATHY. THIRTY MINUTE
PRESENT THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU BRING ALL
THE SEAMS FORWARD SO THAT WE
CAN PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED ALL
OF THEM THANK YOU. SENATOR
ARCHULETA THE BACK. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF JOSEPH.
MEATUS WHO IS THE GRANDFATHER
OF ONE OF MY CAPITOL STAFFERS
CAMERON SUTHERLAND. AND IT'S
AMAZING WE WORK WITH OUR
STAFFERS EVERY SINGLE DAY TO
REMEMBER THEY HAVE FAMILY THEY
HAVE FRIENDS THAT BECOME OUR
FAMILY SO CAMERON SUTHERLAND
HAS LOST HIS GRANDFATHER.
MISTER VIEGAS WAS BORN IN
BRAWLEY CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE WAS RAISED BY HIS
GRANDPARENTS. AFTER HIS MOTHER
DIED WHEN HE WAS STILL A VERY
YOUNG MAN. MISTER VIEGAS GREW
UP IN BRAWLEY BUT OFTEN
TRAVELED AROUND THE STATE
DURING THE SUMMER AS A MIGRANT
FARM WORKER. HE WAS DRAFTED AND
SERVED IN THE UNITED STATES
ARMY AS AN INTERPRETER AND HE
SERVED. AND WAS STATIONED THERE
FOUR DOOR HERE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA DURING THE KOREAN
WAR. AFTER THE ARMY MISTER NAY
GUESTS BECAME MANAGER OF
SEVERAL SUCCESSFUL SMALL
BUSINESSES AROUND THE SAN DIEGO
AREA. MR VEGAS WITH KNOWN AS A
WARMING GIVING AND HAPPY MAN A
FAST FRIEND TO ANYONE HE MET
AND CAME IN CONTACT WITH THEM.
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
FIFTY NINE YEARS BEATRICE. TWO
CHILDREN VICTORIA AND LARA AND
SIX GRANDCHILDREN BRITTNEY
CAMERON GABRIELLA CONNIE CAIRO
IS A BALLOT. HE WILL BE SORELY
MISSED AND FOR THESE REASONS I
ASKED TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF A VETERAN JOSEPH VIEGAS.
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE ONCE
AGAIN. TWO WATER IN THE MEMORY
OF HECTOR YOU GOT SAID. HECTOR
WAS A FELLOW VETERAN. WHO
ADVOCATED ON BEHALF OF ALL
VETERANS NOT ONLY IN THE THIRTY
SECOND SENATE DISTRICT BUT
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES COUNTY
IS A CHAIR THE L. A. COUNTY
VETERANS ADVISORY COMMISSION OF
WHICH I SERVED AS CHAIR. YEARS
BACK. IT WAS ALSO A GRADUATE OF
ROOSEVELT HIGH SCHOOLIN BOYLE
HEIGHTS AND CAL STATE LA IN LOS
ANGELES. AFTER SERVING HIS
COMMUNITY S. AND- THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- REPRESENTING
CONGRESSWOMAN LUCILLE ROYBAL
ALLARD. FOR THE PAST ELEVEN
YEARS HE WAS THE DEPUTY
DISTRICT DIRECTOR OF MILITARY
BETTERS LANDS ON FOR
CONGRESSWOMAN GRACE THE
POLITBURO. SERVING AND
REPRESENTING VETERANS COLLEGE
TO THOSE WHO KNEW HIM HE WAS
LEVINE MET FAMILY MAN THAT DEAR
FRIEND A VALUED COLLEAGUE AND A
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT. HE
HELPED TO MAKE THE LIVES OF
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES
BETTER. AND FOR THESE REASONS I
ASKED WE TURN IN THE MEMORY OF
VETERAN HECTOR I WAS OUT THERE.
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE. TODAY
AND IN THE GERMAN IN MEMORY OF
FORMER SIR RIDEAU'S MAYOR AND
CITY COUNCILMAN JIM EDWARDS.
JIM DIED OF CANCER ON SUNDAY
MAY TENTH TWENTY TWENTY AFTER
SERVING THE CITY OF CERRITOS
MAYOR AND CITY COUNCILMAN. A
TEACHER FOR MORE THAN THIRTY
YEARS TRULY A COMMUNITY MAN. HE
TAUGHT AT RICHARD GAHR HIGH
SCHOOL FOR- FOR BEFORE RETIRING
BEFORE HE RETIRED FROM THE ABC
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. HE
ALSO SPENT FOUR YEARS WITH
THERE WOULD BE A COMMUNITY
LEARNING CENTER WORK AS A AS A
PART TIME INSTRUCTOR TO REDUCE
COLLEGE. THE FOURTEENTH YEAR OF
SERVICE SERENO'S COLLEGE- SAID
TEACHER BUT A RESIDENT OF
SURREAL FOR FORTY THREE YEARS
HE WAS VERY ACTIVE IN THE
OPTIMIST CLUB AND- ALWAYS
CONTINUED TO BE WITH. CHILDREN
AND YOUTH IN AND PROGRAMS WITH
CHILD DEVELOPMENT HE GAVE SO
MUCH OF HIS TIME AND EFFORT FOR
CHILDREN. HE SAT ON THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF FISHER HOUSE OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AT THE LONG
BEACH VA HOSPITAL. WHICH OFFERS
LODGING TO VETERANS AND
RELATIVES UNDERGOING TREATMENT
AT THE VA FACILITY. IT ALSO
PREVIOUSLY BEEN A RABBIT BEEN A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE LOS LOS
RETOS YMCA IN SERIE DOES
REGIONAL CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
AS A BOARD OF DIRECTORS MEMBER.
AND THE FAMILY COMMUNITY
GUIDANCE CENTER. VETERANS
COUNCILMEMBER. DISTRIB RICHARD
IN UNITED STATES ARMY DURING
THE VIETNAM ERA. HE WAS ALSO AN
AVID PHOTOGRAPHER VOLUNTEERED
TO SHOOT EVENTS FOR THE
SORORITY ELLIS CITY COUNCIL AS
WELL AS FIRE FIRES- RESCUE
TRAINING- WORKING WITH GRADUATE
SHE- AT THE ACADEMY HE WAS
TRULY LOVED. BY SO MANY AND
RESPECTED BY SO MANY RESIDENTS
TO THE CITY OF THREE ADULT
COUNCILMEMBER EDWARDS IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE CONNIE THE
TWO CHILDREN STACY SCOTT AND
SIX GRANDCHILDREN ONE GREAT
GRANDSON. AND FOR THESE REASONS
I AFTER DURING THE MEMORY A
VETERAN JIM EDWARDS. ADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF LUIGI WERE
NO LESS. WHO SERVED AS MAYOR OF
NORWALK. LUIGI PASSED AWAY ON
NEW YEAR'S DAY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FROM COMPLICATIONS DUE TO
COME OVER A COUPLE OF THE- I AM
HE WAS A PERSONAL FRIEND MADAM
PRESIDENT THEN I WILL GATHER MY
THOUGHTS. BUT HE PASSED AWAY IN
MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY OF COMPLEX
COMPLICATIONS OF THE VIRUS HE
WAS SEVENTY SIX YEARS OLD.
LUIGI WITH THE NORWALK CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER FOR EIGHTEEN
YEARS AND WAS FIRST APPOINTED
THE CITY COUNCIL NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. WHICH WAS THE SON
OF PARENTS THOMAS AND MARK THE-
FOR NOLA WHO IMMIGRATED FROM
ITALY. THE WOULD YOU GRADUATE
FROM NORWALK HIGH SCHOOL IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR WE MEDITATE
WIFE JOANNE. THEY WERE MARRIED
IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX HAVE
THREE CHILDREN AND REMAINED IN
NORWALK TO RAISE OUR FAMILY. A
PROMINENT NORWALK BUSINESSMAN
LUIGI PURCHASED HIS FIRST AUTO
SERVICE STATION WHEN HE WAS
ONLY TWENTY YEARS OF AGE. AND
GARAGES THEREAFTER TOWARD A
TOLL SERVICE THAT SURE OF THE
GENERAL AREA VERY SUCCESSFUL
OVER THE COURSE OF HIS CAREER
HE ALSO FOUNDED AND CO FOUNDED
NUMBER OF NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS PROMOTE. WORTHY
CAUSES INCLUDING THE NORWALK
SANTA CLAUS SLEIGH FOUNDATION.
WHERE LUIGI HOSTED BREAKFAST
WHICH INCLUDED A VISIT FROM
SANTA CLAUS AND GIFTS FOR
CHILDREN THROUGHOUT THE AREA.
HE GAVE SO MUCH TO THE
COMMUNITY. DURING THE HOLIDAYS
LUIGI ALSO PARTICIPATED
PROGRAMS DISTRIBUTED MORE THAN
SIX HUNDRED TURKEYS AND FOOD TO
SENIOR CENTERS EVERY SINGLE
YEAR HIS FAMILY IS ALWAYS
WORKING TOGETHER FOR THE
COMMUNITY HE STARTED FRIENDS OF
THE NORWALK SHERIFF'S STATION
TO HELP FAMILIES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY. WHO WERE
INJURED OR KILLED IN THE LINE
OF DUTY. AFTER THE NINE ELEVEN
ATTACKS LUIGI AND- ERECTED A
MONUMENT DEDICATED THE FIRST
RESPONDERS AND ALSO HELPED
ESTABLISH THE HOMETOWN HEROES.
BANNER THAT FLEW PROUDLY TO
HONOR SERVICE MEMBERS. BOTH MEN
AND WOMEN WHO WOULD YOU AS A
FRIEND AND ADVOCATE ABOVE ALL A
BELOVED FAMILY MAN. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF FIFTY
SIX YEARS WHO AND WHO. HIS SON
THOMAS HIS DAUGHTER'S LEESON
CRISTINA IN ADDITION TO ELEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN AND THREE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. AND FOR THESE
REASONS I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN
TO THE MEMORY OF LUIGI FOR
NOLAN. AND LASTLY MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE. TODAY TO
HONOR THE MEMORY OF DR JEAN
GILBERT JIM PAM MEDIA CHAMPA
MIA JEAN WAS A FRIEND WE- KNEW
EVERYONE NEWMAN TOWN IS JEAN
AND DR JEAN. SHE WAS A FRIEND
OF MINE WHO I MET DURING MY
FIRST CITY COUNCIL CAMPAIGN IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. WAS ALSO
VERY IMPRESSIVE INDIVIDUAL VERY
BRIGHT TALENTED AND TRULY
DEDICATED TO HIS COMMUNITY AND
SERVE THE CITY OF. THE CITY OF
PICO RIVERA WITH HONOR. JEAN
WAS BORN IN DETROIT MICHIGAN
ENSURE OF LOS ANGELES. I'M
SORRY HE MOVED TO LOS ANGELES
AS A SMALL CHILD WE GREW UP AND
RAISED FOUR CHILDREN. AND-
SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN. AFTER ANY
AFTER EARNING DEGREES FROM
LOYOLA UCLA AND A MASTER'S
DEGREE- AND PHD FOR USC JEAN
WENT ON TO WORK AS A SOCIAL
pMETROPOLITAN PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITAL. ANY SAID- HE'S GIVEN
SO MUCH OF HIS LIFE THOSE IN
NEED HE LATER JOINED ALMA
FAMILY SERVICES BECOMING THEIR
CEO AFTER THREE YEARS. IN A
RECENTLY RETIRED AFTER A LONG
AND DISTINGUISHED CAREER
SERVING THE COMMUNITY JEAN
ENJOYED JACK JAZZ MUSIC. AND
PROJECTS EVERY DAY PERTAINING
TO THE COMMUNITY HE WILL BE
SERVING- THE WILL BE SORELY
MISSED- HIS WIFE MARIE. I'VE
TALKED OR THE PHONE AND- SHE'S
SO PROUD TODAY THAT WE'RE
HONORING HIM AND FOR THESE
REASONS I ASKED WOULD TURN IN
THIS MEMORY OF DR JEAN GILBERT
CHAMPION MIA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU CENTER
ARCHULETA PLEASE BRING THEIR
NAMES FORWARD SO THEY CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED MEMBERS
WE HAVE SOME MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. MADAM PRESIDENT I AM
DIRECTED TO INFORM YOUR
HONORABLE BODY THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDED AND ON THIS
DAY PASSED AS AMENDED SENATE
BILL EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
AND SENATE BILL NINETY FOUR.
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS YOUR
HONORABLE BODY TO CONCURRENCE
THAT AMENDMENTS TO PARKER CHIEF
CLERK OF THE ASSEMBLY ABOVE
BILLS ORDERED TWO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS FILE. THANK YOU MA'AM
SECRETARY WE WILL HAVE A
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE FOR EVERYONE
SHORTLY.
MEMBERS YOU ALL HAVE A
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE BEFORE YOU
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM ONE OF SIX SENATOR SKINNER
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY EIGHT BY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT RELATING
TO ECONOMIC RELIEF AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY THE
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU ARE SORRY
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SO. IN
THE BILL THAT WE HAVE SO FAR
ACTED ON TODAY WE HAVE MADE
SURE THAT FEDERAL FUNDS WILL
GET OUT TO OUR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS THE TENANTS WILL BE
PROTECTED FROM EVICTION AND THE
LANDLORD TO PARTICIPATE WILL BE
GUARANTEED 80% OF THEIR OWED.
WE'VE PROVIDED EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL AID FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO HELP
MOTIVATE THEM TO STAY IN
COLLEGE WE PROVIDED NEEDED
MONEY TO OUR FOOD BANKS AND
DIAPER BANKS AMONG OTHER THINGS
AND NOW WE HAVE BEFORE US.
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS BILL AND
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
ESTABLISHES. A GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS FUND WHICH WILL
PROVIDE. A SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR
TAX REFUND TO CALIFORNIA EARNED
INCOME TAX ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS
WHO FILE A TAX RETURN FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TAX YEAR. WE WILL
ALSO PROVIDE A SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR TAX REFUND PAYMENT TO
BUY TEN TAXPAYERS WITH GROSS
INCOMES OF SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND OR LESS WHO FILE A
RETURN FOR TWENTY TWENTY. I
TURN FILERS WHO ALSO QUALIFY
FOR THE EITC WILL BE ABLE TO
APPLY FOR THE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR. E. I. T. C. STIMULUS BY.
THE BILL ALSO ESTABLISHES THE
GOLDEN STATE GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH WILL PROVIDE SIX HUNDRED
ONE TIME GRANT PAYMENTS TO OUR
CAL WORKS FSIS P. AND CAPPY
RECIPIENTS. AND VARIOUS OTHER
PROVISIONS ARE INCLUDED
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THE TIMELY
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS TAX PAYMENTS AND
GRANT PROGRAM PAYMENTS FOR WHAT
THESE. PARTICULAR ITEMS DO IS
PROVIDE RELIEF TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WITH PARTICULAR
FOCUS ON. AS THE L. A. ARE
RECOMMENDED TO US. GROUPS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE FEDERAL
STIMULUS DIRECT PAYMENT
PROGRAMS APPROXIMATELY FIVE
POINT SEVEN MILLION PAYMENTS
MEANING INDIVIDUAL PAYMENTS OR
INDIVIDUAL HOUSEHOLDS WILL BE
MADE TO LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
AS A RESULT OF THIS BILL. AND
WITHOUT MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- I HAVE A
QUESTION THE AUTHORED BY MAY
THURSDAY WE TAKE A QUESTION YES
PLEASE PROCEED THOROUGHLY. IN A
SO THIS IS ON- THE CAPPY
PAYMENTS THOUGH THERE'S A SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION WHICH I
UNDERSTAND THAT SSI AND S. S.
P. AND I TEN FILERS WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A WAY TO TRACK ALL THOSE
FOLKS WHO WE WOULD KNOW- WHO'S
RECEIVING THE BENEFITS BUT THE
CAPPER- IS A WE ARE UNDER THE
EDT. PROCESS WE JUST WENT
THROUGH WE HAD ALL KINDS OF
FRAUD. SO I'M I'M WONDERING HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO LIKE MAKE THE
PAYMENTS AND HOW HOW WOULD THEY
BE QUALIFY THAT'S- A CONCERN I
WAS WONDERING IF YOU HAD. A
SOME INFORMATION OF HOW THAT.
THAT POLICY ACTUALLY WOULD WORK
OUT. SANDERS CAN. THANK YOU D.
CAPPY PROGRAM DOES EXIST AND
WHILE UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE
ALSO EXISTED CAPPY RECIPIENTS
ARM PRIMARILY ARE ALREADY
LOGGED INTO THAT PROGRAM SO
DIFFERENT THAN THE WHAT WE
EXPERIENCE WITH TDD WHERE THERE
WAS A WHOLE NEW SET OF PEOPLE
WHO QUALIFIED AND DUSTY D. HAD
TO PROCESS LOTS OF NEW
APPLICATIONS IN MOST CASES ARE
CAPPY RECIPIENTS ARE ALREADY
FOLKS FOR IN THE CAPPY SYSTEM.
TELL US TWENTY EDT SITUATION
WHERE WE HAD THE FRAUD THEY
EXCLUDED THE- EMPLOYERS FROM
THAT FOR A BIG PERIOD OF TIME
THEY EXCLUDED EMPLOYERS FROM
VERIFYING- SO IN THIS CASE WHO
WOULD VERIFY I'M I'M NOT SAYING
THERE'S THAT. EVERYBODY IS
ELIGIBLE- THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE HURTING THIS WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NO.
ABILITY FOR FRAUD I MEAN I TEN
FATHERS ABSOLUTELY WE KNOW THAT
THEY ARE FILING WE SO WE HAVE A
RECORD. SO JUST A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED THAT THERE COULD BE.
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR FRAUD HERE
DUPLICATIONS MANY DUPLICATIONS
THAT'S THAT'S THE POINT I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE. THAT IN
JUST AT THE PROCESS SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT. SOME OF AN ANSWER
I GUESS I DIDN'T REALLY AYE
MAYBE BECAUSE I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW IT WORKS THAT'S
WHAT I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
IS ACTUALLY HOW IT WORKS- WELL
I WILL DO MY BEST RIGHT NOW TO
ELIMINATE THOSE SINCE I DON'T
PERSONALLY ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM I MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO
GIVE YOU ALL THE DETAIL THAT
YOU. MAY- D. WHAT CAPITAL IS
EQUIVALENT TO FF HI FOUR OR
DOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS WHICH IS
WHY THESE FOLKS ARE ALREADY IN
THE PROGRAM AND IT IS A- THE
OTHER SITUATION IS THAT IT'S A
FAR SMALLER NUMBER. THEN WHAT
EDG WAS HAVING TO PROCESS AND
BEING A FAR SMALLER NUMBER IT
IS EASIER TO DO VERIFICATIONS
THEN OBVIOUSLY WHEN ANY AGENCY
CONFRONTS THE TYPE OF VOLUME
THAT R. E. D. D. SYSTEM
CONFRONTED. ON MY OWN TIME I
APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER I THANK
YOU FOR AYE- AS YOU KNOW THAT
WE'VE WE'VE LOST MIL BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO. FOLKS WHO HAVE
DUPLICATED IN OUR EVEN STOLE
SOMEBODY ELSE'S IDENTITY- IN
OTHER PROGRAMS AND SO- I
APPRECIATE TO THE CHAIR- TRYING
TO EDUCATE ME AND I'M I WANT TO
LOOK MORE FOLLOW UP ON IT BUT I
WANT TO JUST MAKE SURE THAT. NO
THERE IS NO OPPORTUNITY FOR.
ACTUATION THAT THE SYSTEMS THAT
WE HAVE IN PLACE REALLY AREN'T
MADE TO HANDLE IT AND THEIR
THEIR GAMING IT AND THEY'RE AND
THEY'RE DOING IT AT THE
DETRIMENT OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND SO I APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER DOLLY MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NINE CENTER
SKINNER YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU I'M MADAM PRESIDENT I THINK
THAT WE SHOULD FEEL VERY GOOD
ABOUT THIS ACTION AND I WANT TO
THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR.
PUTTING FORWARD THE WHOLE
CONCEPT OF HAVING THE STATE
PROVIDE FUNDS TO OUR LOWEST
INCOME CALIFORNIANS RECOGNIZING
THAT EVEN WITH THE SUPPORT THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
PROVIDED OUR LOWEST INCOME
CALIFORNIANS HAVE REALLY FACED
HARDSHIPS. HAVE HAVE HAD EITHER.
DIPSTICK AND EXPENSES DUE TO
THIS PANDEMIC THAT WERE
UNEXPECTED CHILDREN STAYING
HOME AND HAVING TO PROVIDE FOOD
THEN MEALS THAT OTHERWISE MAY
HAVE BEEN COVERED THROUGH THE
CHILD CARE PROGRAM OR THEIR
SCHOOLS PROGRAM SO MANY
ADDITIONAL BURDENS THAT WERE
PUT AS WE ALL KNOW ON ALL OF US
FOR THIS PANDEMIC BUT FOR
WHICH- THE LOWEST INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. HAVE A MUCH
HARDER TIME RESPONDING TO FOR
THOSE OF US WHO ARE HAVE NOT
HAD TO FACE EITHER A REDUCTION
IN OUR PAYCHECKS OR ELIMINATION
OF OUR PAYCHECKS WHILE THIS
PANDEMIC. HAS BEEN- I WOULD
ADMIT TO ALL OF US.PRETTY
MISERABLE IT HAS BEEN MUCH
HARDER ON THOSE CALIFORNIANS
THAT ARE CONSTANTLY STRUGGLING
TO MAKE ENDS MEET SO I REALLY
WANTED TO GIVE APPRECIATION TO
THE GOVERNOR. TO THE STAFF IN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
STAFF IN OUR BUDGET OFFICES AND
ALL OF THE LEADERSHIP OF OUR
TWO HOUSES AND ALL OF THE FOLKS
WHO WORKED ON THIS. AND OUR
ACTION TODAY AND OUR
EXPECTATION THAT THE GOVERNMENT
GOVERNOR WILL SIGN IT VERY
QUICKLY AND GIVEN THAT IT IS.
FIVE PEOPLE CAN FILE THEIR
TAXES NOW FOR TWENTY TWENTY AND
THIS IS DESIGNED TO BE ABLE TO
ASSIST THOSE PEOPLE WHO FILE
TWENTY TWENTY TAXES IT WILL GET
TO PEOPLE FAST AND THAT'S GOOD
AND IMPORTANT AND I THINK YOU
ALL IN WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI FIVE
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS I BASS.
BAKER FIVE FOR JUST. BRADFORD
FIVE CABALLERO HI CORTESE I
DALLY. DODD FIVE TO RAZA I
EGGMAN I GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ
FIVE GROVE. HERTZBERG HI WITH
SO. HI HER TADO I JONES. LAYARD
I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S. MAN FIVE NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN. BUT CHAU VOTE. FIVE
TEN AYE PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH
FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN HI
I'M BURKE HI WHAT KIND OF SKI I
WIENER AYE WILK I. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
PORGES. DALLY GROVE. JONES
MELENDEZ. NIELSEN. FIVE THIRTY
ONE NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING TO FILE SUPPLEMENTAL
FILE ITEM ONE OH SEVEN- CENTER
SKINNER I'M SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL NINETY FOUR
BY SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT
RELATING TO BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AS WE
JUST ASSISTED OUR LOWEST INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WE ALSO KNOW. THAT
SO MANY OF OUR BUSINESSES HAVE
ALSO GREATLY STRUGGLED IN THIS
PANDEMIC. AND THIS BILL
PROVIDES SOME RELIEF AND I'LL
BE SPECIFIC ABOUT WHAT RELIEF.
IT PROVIDES WAIVERS FOR
LICENSES OF THE BOARD OF
BARBERING IN CARL COSMETOLOGY
AND CERTAIN LICENSEES OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL. AS WE ALL
KNOW BERBERS HERE NAIL SALONS
AND SIMILAR BUSINESSES WERE
PARTICULARLY HARD HIT. AND MANY
OF THEM HAVE BEEN REQUIRED TO
CLOSE FOR MOST OF THIS PANDEMIC
PERIOD. AND THE BILL
APPROPRIATES TWENTY FIVE POINT
SIX MILLION TO BACK FILL FOR
THE BOARD OF BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY TO COVER ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND LICENSES. AND
THESE LICENSES ARE ACTIVE FOR
TWO YEARS SO THE WAIVER COVERS
TWO YEARS OR. ONE LICENSING
CYCLE. AND THEN ON THE ABC.
LIGHT LICENSES AS YOU NO BARS
RESTAURANTS AND VENUES OTHER
VENUES THAT HAVE ABC LICENSES.
HAVE ALSO HAD TO SHUTTER THEIR
DOORS FOR MUCH OF THIS YEAR.
THE BILL APPROPRIATES FUNDING
TO BACK FILL APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY NINE THOUSAND LICENSEES.
PRIMARILY RESTAURANTS AND BARS.
AND THE LICENSEES ARE ACTIVE
FOR ONE YEAR HOWEVER THE WAIVER
COVERS TWO YEARS OR TWO
LICENSING CYCLES. AND I WANT TO
AGAIN EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION
TO THE GOVERNOR. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR THIS
SUGGESTION AND FOR THE STAFF IN
BOTH OF OUR HOUSES WORKING OUT
THE DETAILS SO THAT WE HAVE
THIS BEFORE US IN WITHOUT AYE
ELSEVIER AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I DO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL BUT I DO WANT TO
MAKE- THE COMMENT THAT I
BELIEVE THIS IS JUST EIGHTY
INTENSE. A CRIME OFF THE TABLE
WHAT ARE RESTAURANTS IN OUR
SALONS HAVE SUFFERED- OVER THE
LAST YEAR. I HAVE A STYLIST.
PART OF ME. SORRY SYSTEM
MOTIONING TO FILL IF WE COULD
RAISE YOUR MICROPHONE A LITTLE
BECAUSE YOU'RE HARD TO HEAR. I
HAVE A STYLIST SHE'S A SINGLE
MOM AND HAS TWO KIDS. SHE LOST
OVER TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND BECAUSE SHE WAS NOT ALLOWED
TO OPERATE BECAUSE OF THE
SHUTDOWN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE STATE HOME
ORDER THAT THE GOVERNOR ISSUED.
I'M SURE SHE APPRECIATES HER
FIFTY DOLLARS THAT ARE IN THIS
BILL THAT SHE WOULD GET BACK
OVER A PERIOD OF TWO YEARS. BUT
AGAIN THAT IS SO MINIMAL
COMPARED TO WHAT WAS LOST. THE
SALON OWNER IN WHICH MY STYLIST
WORKS OUT. HER PERSONAL INCOME
WAS REDUCED BY ALMOST SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR BUSINESS INCOME
WAS REDUCED BY ALMOST SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS. BEING
THE SALON OWNER IN OUR PERSONAL
INCOME WAS REDUCED BY ALMOST
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. THIS IS
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF REVENUE
FOR MOSTLY AND WOMEN AND MOST
SINGLE WOMEN I NOTICE IT ALMOST
IN THE SALON THAT I GO TO
ALMOST EVERY PERSON IN THERE IS
A SINGLE MOM. AND I THINK ABOUT
THE MONEY THAT THEY LOST AND
LIKE I SAID I'M SURE THEY
APPRECIATE THIS FIFTY DOLLARS-THAT WILL GO. TOWARDS THEIR
LICENSE FEE FOR THE NEXT- OF
RETROACTIVELY FOR TWO YEARS.
BUT I THINK SOMETHING
DESPERATELY NEEDS TO BE DONE
ABOUT THE REVENUE AND A LOSS
BECAUSE THIS WAS A TAKING. THIS
IS A TAKING BY GOVERNMENT
WITHOUT COMPENSATION THEY WERE
NOT ALLOWED TO OPERATE. I
CALLED A COUPLE OF RESTAURANT
AND BAR OWNERS THAT HAVE IN THE
DISTRICT. AND I TALKED TO ONE
AND HE SAYS THAT HE LOST OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN THE TOTAL TIME FRAME-
ALCOHOL SALES IN RESTAURANTS. A
FOOD AND BEVERAGE. SO THAT
MONEY WAS LOST SO AGAIN I'M
SURE HE'S GOING TO PROCEED HIS
UP TO TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
CREDIT THAT HE WOULD GET FROM
ABC. BUT I DON'T THINK THAT
IT'S ANYWHERE SIGNIFICANT TO
WHAT WAS LOST AND WE HAVE. WE
HAVE NO UNDERSTANDING OR
THERE'S NO DOUBT OF THAT I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO SEE ABOUT THE
SIGNIFICANT LOSS THAT ARE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND RESTAURANT
OWNERS- IN OUR SALON OWNERS
HAVE LOST OR SALON STYLISTS
HAVE LOST DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
I KNOW THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
APPLY FOR P. P. P. LOANS AND
DIFFERENT THINGS LIKE THAT. BUT
JUST TO HAVE THEIR ABILITY NOT
TO MAKE MONEY AND NOT TO EMPLOY
THE ALMOST TWO MILLION IF NOT
MORE. RESTAURANT EMPLOYEES AND
FOOD SERVICE WORKERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. IT'S JUST. SO SAD.
AND SO WHILE I HAVE SUPPORT
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND I
THINK IT'S A VERY MODEST STEP.
TO IT'S A VERY MODEST STEP. TO
HELP SOME OF OUR RESTAURANT
OWNERS IT'S BY FAR DOES NOT GO
AND NEARLY FAR ENOUGH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER GROVE
MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. SEEING CENTER PAM.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS- I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL- I WOULD MAKE NOTE
OF THAT- THIS UP THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IS ONLY ONE OF
A SERIES OF BILLS- THAT- WE ARE
DOING TO PROVIDE RELIEF FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES- AND CERTAINLY
NOT THE LARGEST OF THEM ALL
BUT- I DO APPRECIATE THAT- WE
ARE TRYING TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO SMALL BUSINESSES
EVEN FOR THE SMALLER THINGS
LIKE WE ARE DOING THIS
PARTICULAR BILL THE RECOGNIZING
THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE
LICENSES THAT- BY THE WAY WE DO
NEED WE DO USE THAT REVENUE TO
MAINTAIN THE TYPE OF STANDARDS
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE- FOR
THOSE BUSINESS BUT RECOGNIZING
THAT. SAYS THEY'VE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO OPERATE THAT PERHAPS
IT'S NOT FAIR THAT WE CONTINUE
TO BURDEN THEM WITH THIS
EXPENSES EVEN IF THEY ARE SMALL
COMPARISON TO THE TOTAL LOSSES
BUT ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT WE DO
HAVE MANY OTHER BILLS AS WELL
THAT WE ARE BOTH PASSING TODAY
AND WILL IN THE FUTURE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE
AND OF COURSE CALLING ON THE-
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN MANY DELAYS- FOR
MONTHS AND MONTHS ACTUALLY IN
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION.
WHERE THERE WASN'T ACTION TAKEN
BUT THAT WILL WE ARE LOOKING
FOR HOPEFULLY IT FURTHER
ASSISTANCE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
AND HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND I
RETURN BECAUSE SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
PAN. FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
SO. CAN MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
AND YES I APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO.
POINTING OUT THAT THIS IS ONE
OF A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT WE
ARE DOING. AND IT. BEFORE
ASKING FOR THE AYE VOTE. THE
NEXT VERY SIGNIFICANT THING WE
ARE DOING FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
WILL BE THE VERY NEXT BILL THAT
WE HEAR. THE WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER MAN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS AYE BATES
I BAKER FIVE FOUR JUST AYE
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI
CORTESE FIVE DALLY. I DODD FIVE
THE RAZA FIVE EGGMAN I GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG HI HUESO HI HER TADO.
FIVE JONES FIVE LAYERED I LEYVA
HI MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION I NEWMAN
I NIELSEN BY A SHOW VOTE HI PAN
AYE PORTANTINO HI ROTH I
REVIEWED RUBIO. HI SKINNER AYE
STERN HI I'M BURKE HI MY COUNTY
I WIENER. I WILK I. THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
ROOM TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM OF
ONE OH EIGHT SENATOR SKINNER
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR CABALLERO AND ACTUALLY
DID A SMALL BUSINESSES AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY DAHLE RELATED TO
THE BUDGETS. SORRY ABOUT THAT
SENATE CAREER ON TRYING TO GIVE
YOUR BILL AWAY PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT. I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT S. B. O.
S. B. EIGHTY SEVEN THIS
AFTERNOON THE BILL THAT
PROVIDES ASSISTANCE TO OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO SERVICE
THE ECONOMIC ENGINES OF OUR
STATE. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK OUR PRO TEM FOR HER
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP AND THE
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHORS OF THE
BILL AND THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS
VISION TO CREATE THIS PROGRAM
WHICH THIS BILL EXPANDS. DURING
THE PANDEMIC SOMETHING REALLY
REMARKABLE TO PLACE SMALL
BUSINESSES MANY OF WHOM WERE
HURT AND STRUGGLING THEMSELVES
BEGAN STEPPING UP TO HELP
OTHERS BUSINESSES LIKE RILEY'S
BREWING COMPANY AND MADERA
CONVERTED THEIR OPERATIONS TO
PRODUCE HAND SANITIZER AND
DISINFECTANT. GREATLY HELPING
FIRST RESPONDERS AND THE LOCAL
POLICE DEPARTMENT BATTLING TO
CONTAIN THE VIRUS AT THE HEIGHT
OF THE PANDEMIC OR RESTAURANTS
LIKE THE BLUE FLAME DINER IN
FIREBAUGH AND THAT BE TRUE CAFE
AND HOLLISTER. THE PARTCIPATED
IN THE GRADE PLATES DELIVERED
PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT ARE
VULNERABLE SENIORS RECEIVED
THREE NUTRITIOUS MEALS A DAY
DELIVERED DIRECTLY TO THEIR
HOMES. JUST AS WE HAVE RELIED
ON OUR SMALL BUSINESSES TO
SERVE THOSE MEALS OR PER COFFEE
IT IS NOW TIME FOR THE STATE TO
STEP STEP UP TO SUPPORT. THEM
AND THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
WHO WORK IN THIS IN THESE
BUSINESSES TO PUT FOOD ON THEIR
OWN TABLES. SB EIGHTY SEVEN
FORMALLY ESTABLISHES AND
EXPANDS THE CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS COBIT NINETEEN RELIEF
GRANT PROGRAM THAT THE GOVERNOR
CREATED BY EXECUTIVE ORDER TWO
MONTHS AGO. THIS PROGRAM WILL
PROVIDE GRANTS OF UP TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
QUALIFIED SMALL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFIT MISSION SERVICES.
WITH UP TO TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION ANNUAL GROSS REVENUE
AND ELIGIBLE NONPROFIT CULTURE-
INSTITUTION. SUCH AS SOON. MUSE
AND PERFORMING ARTS COMPANIES.
SMALL BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE HAVE CONTINUED TO
STRUGGLE TO SURVIVE DURING THE
STAY AT HOME ORDERS. RECENT
DATA INDICATES A CLOSE TO ONE
THIRD OF SMALL BUSINESSES WILL
NOT SURVIVE BEYOND THE FIRST
FEW MONTHS OF THIS YEAR WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDS. NONPROFITS
I'VE ALSO BEEN ADVERSELY
IMPACTED AS THEIR RESOURCES AND
FINANCES HAVE DECLINED WHILE
THE DEMAND FOR SERVICES HAS
INCREASED. SMALL BUSINESSES
PLAY A MAJOR ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA'S THREE TRILLION
DOLLAR ECONOMY. BUSINESSES WITH
LESS THAN TWENTY EMPLOYEES MAKE
UP ALMOST 90% OF THE
BUSINESSES. AND THOSE WITH LESS
THAN A HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
REPRESENT 97% OF BUSINESSES IN
THE STATE. AND AS OF NOVEMBER
SMALL BUSINESS REVENUE IS DOWN
THIRTY THREE PERCENT. THIS BILL
APPROPRIATES JUST OVER TWO
BILLION DOLLARS TO FUND THE
PROGRAM INCLUDING FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO NONPROFIT CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS. THE GRANTS WILL
BE ALLOCATED ACROSS AT LEAST
FOUR ROUNDS ONE CLOSE AROUND
USING THE EXISTENCE APPLICANTS
FROM ROUND ONE AND TWO OF THE
PREVIOUS CODE NINETEEN RELIEF
GRANT PROGRAM. ONE ROUND FOR
ELIGIBLE NONPROFIT CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS AND AT LEAST TWO
NEW OPEN ROUND FOR QUALIFIED
SMALL BUSINESSES. THE GRANT
AMOUNTS VARY BASED ON ANNUAL
GROSS REVENUE. ELIGIBLE USES
FOR THE GRANT INCLUDE BUT ARE
NOT ARE NOT LIMITED TO EMPLOYEE
PAYROLL COSTS OR BENEFITS
WORKING OVERHEAD SUCH AS RENT
AND UTILITY PAYMENTS. COST
ASSOCIATED WITH RE OPENING
PLANTS AND OTHER COVERAGE COBIT
RELATED EXPENSES. WE KNOW THAT
OUR BUSINESSES ARE ESSENTIAL TO
THE ECONOMIC ROAD TO RECOVERY
FOR OUR STATE AND SO IT IS
IMPERATIVE WE MOVED TO HELP
THEM WITH SWIFT AND BOLD
ACTION. UNDERSTANDABLY THE
GRANTS IN THIS BILL ARE SMALL
COMPARED TO THE CITY
SIGNIFICANT REVENUE LOSSES ARE
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE SUFFERED
AND YOU'VE HEARD SOME
DISCUSSION. ABOUT THAT ON THE
FLOOR TODAY. MORRIS'S WILL BE
CREATED TO ENSURE THAT THEY
REMAIN ABLE TO STAY AFLOAT
HOWEVER SB EIGHTY SEVEN IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP IN THAT
PROCESS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
CABALLERO MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
US SENATOR MEN. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK. I JUST WANT TO PLUG
THE HARD WORK THAT THE GOVERNOR
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY LEADERSHIP
IS PUT INTO THIS MEASURE I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE BUDGET CHAIR
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SALINAS AND
EVERYONE ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE FOR ALL YOUR EFFORTS
IN THIS VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
BILL I AM PROUD AND HONORED TO
BE A JOINT AUTHOR OF SB EIGHTY
SEVEN THIS IS AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SALINAS JUST MENTIONED
GOING TO BE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
FOR OUR SMALL BUSINESSES WE CAN
SEE A RETURN TO NORMALCY JUST
AROUND THE CORNER. BUT TOO MANY
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE STRUGGLING
TO STAY AFLOAT RIGHT NOW. LIKE
MY COLLEAGUES FROM BAKERSFIELD
AND SALINAS I TOO HAVE HEARD
FROM MANY MANY SMALL BUSINESSES
IN MY DISTRICT. THAT ARE
DISTRACTING TO STAY AFLOAT
RIGHT NOW. WHETHER TERROR
SALONS OR SOFTWARE COMPANIES OR
COFFEE SHOPS AND BARS AND
RESTAURANTS. MANY OF THEM HAVE
HAD TO FACE CLOSING
TEMPORARILY- THEY'RE STRUGGLING
TO HOLD ON TO THEIR EMPLOYEES
THIS PROVIDES A CRITICAL
LIFELINE TO THEM THIS WILL HELP
THIS PARTICULAR BILL AND THE
GRANT SAY PROVIDES WILL HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES STAY OPEN IT
WILL HELP THEM PAY THEIR
EMPLOYEES THIS WILL BE CRITICAL
FOR KEEPING SMALL BUSINESSES
ALIVE. UNTIL WE GET BACK TO
NORMAL WE ALL KNOW THE SMALL
BUSINESSES WILL AB ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL FOR ECONOMIC RECOVERY
AND WE HAVE TO DO ALL WE CAN TO
HELP SMALL BUSINESSES DURING
THIS UNPRECEDENTED. ENDEMIC
DRIVEN DOWNTURN- SO I'M HOPEFUL
THAT THIS PARTICULAR BILL WE'LL
BE THAT LIFELINE AND I'M
GRATEFUL TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
EMPHASIZING SMALL BUSINESSES
AND ALSO NON PROFITS IN THIS
BUDGET PACKAGE. I WANT TO JUST
GIVE A QUICK SHOUT OUT TO THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
APPROPRIATED. IN THIS BILL. FOR
CULTURE NON. MAY OF US AND- IN
ORDER HAVE IMPORTANT PERFORMING
ARTS AND MUSEUMS AND ART
INSTITUTES AND THEY TOO ARE
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW. AND SO
THIS IS GOING TO BE CRITICAL AS
WELL SO I URGE YOU FOR MY VOTE
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO
WORKING IN THIS YEAR BECAUSE
BUDGET TO CONTINUE TO TRY TO
FIND ADDITIONAL WAYS TO HELP
SMALL BUSINESS. THANK YOU
MANAGER. THANK YOU SENATOR MAN
CENTER BORJAS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I GOTTA TELL YOU
FOLKS THIS IS PROBABLY ONE OF
THE MOST INSPIRING ITEMS I'VE
EVER WORKED ON DURING MY TENURE
IN THE SENATE. THAT IS WHY I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH WILL PROVIDE
AN ADDITIONAL. TWO BILLION
RELIEF FUNDS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS-
THEY'VE BEEN IMPACTED BY THE
COCA NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IN
pSB SEVENTY FOR THE KEEP
CALIFORNIA WORKING ACT. WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SALINAS WHICH
SOUGHT TO PROVIDE TWO POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES. THE BILL I THINK.
EARNED MORE SUPPORT THAN FOLKS
IMAGINED YOU'D BE ABLE TO
GARNER. THE BILL WAS CO
AUTHORED BY THIRTY SIX
DEMOCRATS IN TWENTY SEVEN
REPUBLICANS IN BOTH THE SENATE
AND THE ASSEMBLY. THAT IS MORE
THAN HALF OF THE ENTIRE STATE
LEGISLATURE. TWENTY FIVE
SENATORS IN THIS ROOM- CO
SPONSORED THIS BILL SB SEVENTY
FOUR IN FOR THAT. I THANK YOU
IT MEANT THE WORLD TO ME TO MY
COLLEAGUES BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY%
TO THE RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
THAT HAVE SUFFERED- DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. THE BILL ALSO
ATTRACTED SUPPORT FROM MORE
THAN EIGHTY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATIONS CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE CITIES AND COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE MOMENTUM
GENERATED BY S. B. SEVENTY FOUR
DEMONSTRATE THE NEED FOR
GREATER INVESTMENT HELP
STRUGGLING SMALL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS AND I'M GLAD TO SEE
THAT THAT THE FISCAL AMOUNT OF
SB SEVENTY FOUR HAS PROPERLY
BEEN. ARE CONVERTED INTO S. B.
EIGHTY SEVEN TO PROVIDE THIS
MUCH NEEDED RELIEF ESPECIALLY
ON AN EXPEDITED BASIS. I'D LIKE
TO THANK US SENATOR FROM
SALINAS ASSEMBLY WOMAN FROM
ORANGE COUNTY THE MEMBERS OF
THIS BODY OF COURSE TO SUPPORT
THIS. AND RECOGNIZE THE STAFF
WHO WERE INSTRUMENTAL IN MAKING
SEVENTY FOUR HAPPEN THAT OPEN
THE DOOR FOR EIGHTY SEVEN TO BE
A REALITY ON WHICH WERE VOTING
TODAY. JEFFREY RALPH OUR SALLY
COOPER DAVE RAMIREZ A LISA
RIVERA FROM CENTER COUPLE YEARS
OFFICE. CLEAR CONLIN- LIZZY
COULD SAUNA AND JESS WONG FROM
ASSEMBLY WHEN CARDI
PETRIE-NORRIS IS OFFICE. IN
JULIE CELLS MAKING TO SUSAN M.
BLAKE SANTEE FROM MY OFFICE.
THIS HAS BEEN AN EXPERIENCE.
BUT I BELIEVE WE SHOULD
REPLICATE AS FREQUENTLY AS
OFTEN AS HUMANLY POSSIBLE. THIS
WAS A MOMENT WHERE THIS BODY
TRANSCENDED PARTISANSHIP. AND
WE'VE SEEN HOW HYPER PARTISAN
WASHINGTON CAN BE AND WE'RE
CERTAINLY NOT IMMUNE TO IT IN
SACRAMENTO. BUT OUR
CONSTITUENCIES WANT US TO
DELIVER RESULTS IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES DEMAND THESE
RESULTS. THAT IS WHY SB EIGHTY
SEVEN IS SO EXCITING IT ALSO
BROUGHT TO MIND SOMETHING THAT
OUR FORMER CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR
SAID- PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN.
THERE IS NO LIMIT TO WHAT A
PERSON CAN DO. OR WHERE THEY
CAN GO. IF THEY DON'T MIND WHO
GETS THE CREDIT. COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
PLEASE LET'S VOTE HI SB. EIGHTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU SENATOR
BORDERS CENTER BRADFORD. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TO STAND
AS A PROD CO AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK OUR PROTEOME OUR BUDGET
YEAR AND THE INCREDIBLE STAFF
THAT HAS WORKED- TO GET THIS
MEASURE TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY
OTHERS NO DOUBT WE ALL KNOW THE
SMALL BUSINESSES THE LIFE BLOOD
OF OUR ECONOMY OVER 60% OF ALL
EMPLOYEES WORK FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES. SO THAT'S WHY I SAY
THEY ARE SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
MOST DESERVING OF THIS RELIEF
AND IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED AT THIS CRITICAL TIME. I
WANT TO OFFER ALSO EMPHASIZED
IN MY COLLEAGUES THAT WE CAN'T
GO BACK TO BUSINESS AS USUAL
AND OVERLOOKED SMALL BUSINESSES
AND UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
WHAT THIS PANDEMIC HAS EXPOSED
IS WHAT MINORITIES. HAVE KNOWN
HISTORICALLY. THAT MINORITY
OWNED AND WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN DENIED
ACCESS TO CAPITAL AND OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT OTHER BUSINESSES
TAKE FOR GRANTED. THE SAME
CAPITALIN PROGRAMS THAT THEY
USE TO SURVIVE AND GROW THEIR
BUSINESS. AND THIS IS STILL THE
CASE TODAY WHEN IT COMES TO
MINORITIES BEING ABLE TO ACCESS
THIS. CREDIT AND LOANS FOR
THEIR BUSINESSES BEFORE THIS
PANDEMIC A STANFORD STUDY FOUND
THAT 1% OF MINORITY BUSINESS
OBTAIN LOANS IN THEIR FIRST
YEAR COMPARED TO OVER 7% WHITE
OWNED BUSINESSES. THIS SPREAD
THEM BECAUSE ALL THE ONLY
EXACERBATED THAT PROBLEM THAT
HAS EXISTED FOR YEARS LAST YEAR
FEDERAL RESERVE FOUND THAT 70%
OF FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. WERE
TIGHTENING THEIR LENDING
STANDARDS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES.
THAT IS WHY THIS LEGISLATION IS
SO ESSENTIAL AT THIS TIME AND
WHY URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. WE NEED
MORE THAN WHAT IS DONE TODAY
THIS IS ONLY THE FIRST STEP AND
WHAT IS SO CRITICALLY NEEDED TO
KEEP THESE BUSINESSES AFLOAT.
IF WE ARE TO LEARN FROM THE
MISTAKES OF THE GREAT RECESSION
WE MUST GIVE SMALL BUSINESSES
TO RESEARCH THEY NEED TO GROW.
OUT OF THIS ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
WE CAN'T GO BACK TO BUSINESS AS
USUAL PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC.
FOR MINORITY AND WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES WERE FORCED TO
OPERATE AT A SERIOUS FINANCIAL
DISADVANTAGE I LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING THIS LEGISLATION FORWARD
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR AND WE
BUILD UPON WHAT THIS
LEGISLATION THE GOVERNOR HAS
DONE. IN IN IN IN IN IN
PROVIDING HELP FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND I HOPE IT CHIEF.
LONG LASTING AND POSITIVE
IMPACTS TO UNDERSERVED MINORITY
COMMUNITIES I STRONGLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD CENTER RUBIO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'VE AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE TODAY I
ALSO STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT IN
A PROUD AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE
I WANT TO THANK THEM. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CITY NOT.
LEADERSHIP AND EVERYONE HERE IN
THE SENATE FOR THIS MEASURE.
THIS ISSUE IS GETTING CLOSER
AND MORE PERSONAL EACH AND
EVERY DAY THAT THE PANDEMIC
CONTINUES. I WANT TO SHARE THAT
SO MANY OF MY FORMER STUDENTS
CALL ME DESPERATELY. PLEADING
FOR ME TO HELP THEM MOST
RECENTLY ONE STUDENTS THAT
THEIR PARENTS HAVE LOST THEIR-
CATERING BUSINESS. ASKED DURING
A PANDEMIC THEY COULDN'T. GO
OUT AND SERVICE PEOPLE. SO
AGAIN WHEN WE HEAR THESE CRIES
FOR HELP I THINK THIS MEASURE
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. AND I
HEARD ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES SAY
THAT ONE THIRD OF BUSINESSES
WILL NOT SURVIVE. WE NEED TO DO
BETTER. AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GUARDINO STATED. WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO OVERLOOK.
BUSINESSES AND MINORITY
COMMUNITIES. I HEARD YOU KNOW
RECENTLY MY FORMER OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM- THAT'S A
CENTRAL VALLEY TALK ABOUT.
WOMEN SINGLE WOMEN MINORITY
WOMEN AGAIN BUSINESS CONTINUES
TO BE ONE OF THESE VEHICLES
THAT HELPS OUR COMMUNITIES STAY
AFLOAT PROVIDE THE TAX REVENUE
THAT OUR LOCAL CITIES NEED. AND
SO I'M SO PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR AND I HOPE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES SO THEY STAY A
FLOAT. AND IT'S EVEN HARDER
TIMES THESE ARE THE ONES THAT
STEP UP. AND ARE FEEDING PEOPLE
GIVING FREE MEALS TAKING
FEMALES TO OUR SENIORS SO WITH
THAT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. AND THE AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
RUBY CENTER DRAWS. SHARE I ALSO
RISE SUPPORT SB EIGHT SEVEN AND
I THANK THE AUTHOR IN OUR
LEADERSHIP OFFER MOVING THIS
FORWARD AND THE GOVERNOR AS
WELL- THERE ARE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF SMALL BUSINESSES
OWNED BY IMMIGRANTS IN MY
DISTRICT FROM. KOREATOWN TO
BOYLE HEIGHTS TO CHINATOWN-
AND- SO THERE ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THEN WITHIN THE
SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY THERE
ARE SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE
NOT FAMILIAR THAT ARE NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH ENGAGING IN
THIS AND ASKING FOR THE SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED AND THAT OTHERS-
GET- SO I REALLY HOPE AND MAYBE
I COULD ASK THE QUESTION. MADAM
CHAIR QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR
CERTAINLY THANK YOU JUST WANT
TO ASK A QUESTION THE AUTHOR IS
GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE OR A SENSE
OF HOW ARE WE GOING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS ASSISTANCE
THAT'S SO BADLY NEEDED
ESPECIALLY. WITHIN IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES OR- BUSINESS OWNERS
WHO ARE NOT FAMILIAR AND NOT
COMFORTABLE- WITH PARTICIPATING
IN AND THE GOVERNMENT PROCESS
THIS WAY WHAT CAN WE DO OR WHAT
CAN BE DONE TO MAKE SURE IT
GETS TO THEM AS WELL THANK YOU
SENATE CABALLERO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MATTER PRESIDENT THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION SO ONE OF
THE- ONE OF THE REQUIREMENTS IN
THIS PROGRAM IS THAT. THE THE
CONTRACTOR WHO IS L'INDUSTRIE
HAVE RELATIONSHIPS AND-
PARTNERS IN EVERY SINGLE COUNTY
THAT ARE- PART OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF HELPING SMALL
BUSINESSES AND SO- THOSE
PARTNERS HAVE BEEN VERY ACTIVE
IN GETTING OUT THE WORD ABOUT
THE PROGRAM BUT WHAT I THINK IS
IMPORTANT IS THAT WE- DO THE
GRASS ROOTS. BOB CONTACT WHAT
I'M DOING RIGHT NOW IS I HAVE
TWENTY SEVEN CITIES AND IN MY
DISTRICT AND I'VE WEARING CAN
IN CONTRACT WOULD HAVE A IN
CONTACT. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A-
A VIRTUAL. AND WE'RE GOING TO
USE A- THAT CAN BE UTILIZED TO
PASS OUT EVERY SINGLE BUSINESS
WITHIN A BUSINESS OWNER. SO
THAT WE CAN GET TO COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND THE LANGUAGE THAT
THEY FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH WITH
ACCESS TO INFORMATION ON HOW
THEY THEY CAN ACCESS THE SMALL
BUSINESS GRANT PROGRAM. SO I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE GRASSROOTS EFFORTS GOING
OUT THERE AND WE CAN DO THAT
THROUGH OUR OWN OFFICES BUT
ALSO THROUGH THE- THAT BOX
UNDER CONTRACTED CDFI IS AND-
BUT BUSINESS ORGANIZATIONS THAT
WE HAVE AND ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. BUT YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THERE ARE
SOME. BUSINESSES THAT ARE NOT
CONNECTED TO ANY KIND OF FORMAL
INSTITUTION AND IT'S GOING TO
BE IMPERATIVE THAT WE GET THE
WORD OUT NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO
IS THAT WE ALSO HAVE. IN
ANOTHER BUDGET ISSUE THAT
THAT'LL COME UP LATER IN THE
YEAR WE HAVE A- MICRO BUSINESS
GRANT PROGRAM IN THOSE ARE
GOING TO BE THE SELF EMPLOYED
VERY VERY SMALL BUSINESSES. AND
THAT'LL BE A DIFFERENT ON A
DIFFERENT PLATFORM IN A
DIFFERENT OUT REGION SO LET'S
STAY IN TOUCH SO WE CAN.
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE
REACH REAL DEEP INTO THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE THAT'S OUR
GOAL. THANK YOU SARAH CABALLERO
THANK YOU CENTER DRAWS THEM
SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TODAY I STAND AS A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB EIGHTY
SEVEN AND I WANT TO COMMEND
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM FOR THIS
EFFORT I'M SOMEBODY THAT
BELIEVES A BIPARTISAN POLICIES
LEAD TO THE BEST SOLUTIONS
THEY'RE BETTER AND THEY'RE
LONGER LASTING AND THIS IS JUST
ONE EXAMPLE OF COURSE I'D BE
REMISS WITHOUT MENTIONING THAT
SB SEVENTY FOUR. BY MY FRIEND
FROM FRESNO SPONDE THIS- SB
EIGHTY SEVEN THAT WE'RE TO BE
SUPPORTING TODAY SO WITH HIS
VISION AND HARD WORK ALONG
WITH- THE FINE SENATOR FROM
SALINAS WHILE WORKING ACROSS
THE AISLE TO BUILD A COALITION
NECESSARY. TO BRING HAVE THIS
RIGHT UP TO THE TOP. ASSEMBLY
IMPORTANT ALSO WHEN IT
KNOWLEDGE INTAKE- THE PRO TEM
AND HER STAFF FOR ALL THE WORK
AND NEGOTIATING THE FINAL
DETAILS WITH THE GOVERNOR. AND
AS MANY OF US IN THIS ROOM IS
ALREADY MENTIONED THIS IS NOT
ENOUGH. BUT IT'S A START. AND
IT'S A GREAT START BECAUSE IT
WAS DONE WORKING TOGETHER IN A
BIPARTISAN MANNER WHICH IS WHAT
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA EXPECT
FROM US. SO WITH THAT. I'M SURE
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A UNANIMOUS
VOTE TODAY WHICH ISN'T IT'S
GOOD THING BUT THIS IS JUST A
FIRST STEP. AND I AGAIN ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
WILK CENTER DOLLY. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS IS A
GREAT PIECE OF LEGISLATION I AS
A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER WORK
WITH A LOT OF OTHER SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND- NOT SEE OR
SHARE WITH YOU THAT. THE
STORIES WE'VE ALL HEARD AND OUR
NEIGHBORS IN THOSE THOSE WHO
HAVE CAME HERE AND STARTED
BUSINESS AND WE HEARD ABOUT THE
IMMIGRANTS THEY'RE LIVING THEIR%
DREAM AND THE SWEAT EQUITY THAT
THEY HAVE IN THEIR BUSINESSES.
IT IS JUST UNBELIEVABLE AND THE
PAIN THAT THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH
WITH OUR EMPLOYEES I COMMEND
THE IPARTISANSHIP AND THE
WORK. AND I WANT TO JUST.
MANSION THAT THE YOU KNOW THE
PRO TEM SAID TODAY THAT THIS IS
A STARTING POINT WE'RE WORKING
ON ALL THESE BILLS. TO TRY TO
HELP OUT CALIFORNIANS AYE. I
JUST WANT TO THANK GOD THAT WE
HAVE. MEGAN A WORLDWIDE
CORPORATIONS IN OUR STATE THAT
ARE. CREATING THIS TAX BASE
THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE AVAILABLE
TO US. TO DO THIS RIGHT NOW.
BUT LONG TERM. YOU KNOW THIS IS
A SHOT NORM. WE CANNOT CONTINUE
FOREVER TO BE ABLE TO. PUT OUT
THESE FIRES EVEN FROM THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WE ARE PRINTING.
OR CREATING MONEY. THAT HAS NO
BACKWARDS YOU GONNA SEE
INFLATION. LIKE WE'VE NEVER
SEEN IN MY OPINION BECAUSE
WE'RE INFUSING SO MUCH. THAT
CASH INTO OUR SYSTEM. SO THE
REAL LONG. THE REAL LONG TERM
PROJECTS FOR. THIS BODY IN IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE GOVERNOR
IS TO FIGURE OUT A WAY THAT WE
CAN GET OUR BUSINESSES BACK
GOING SAFELY. AND ACTUALLY LET
THEM SUSTAIN AND BILL WILL NOT
HAVE TO RELY ON- THESE FUNDS
THAT ARE COMING IN FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND US BUT
FOR NOW. I KNOW WE MUST DO
THIS. BUT I WOULD ENCOURAGE
MEMBERS TO WORK TOGETHER TO.
GET THE SMALL BUSINESSES THEY
ARE THE BACKBONE. OF
CALIFORNIA- AND OUR NATION-
BACK ON THEIR FEET ACTUALLY
OPERATING WITH WITHOUT HAVING
TO USE ASSISTANCE SO AGAIN I
APPLAUD. THE MEMBERS AND THANK
YOU ENERGEN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER DOLLY CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY SEVEN AND
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO FOR HIS
VISION AND LEADERSHIP.
INCLUDING THIS- PROCESS
STARTING THIS PROCESS LAST
YEAR- I THINK I'D LIKE TO THINK
YOU MIGHT ALSO LIKE TO THINK
SENATE PRO TEM FOR MAKING SURE
THAT THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION-
ME TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO NEGOTIATE
WITH THE GOVERNOR. SO THAT THIS
THIS RELIEF WHICH IS MUCH MORE
SUBSTANTIAL THAN THE LICENSE
FEE WILL BE ABLE TO- WE CAN
OFFER IT TO OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE REALLY BEEN
STRUGGLING OVER THIS LAST YEAR
DURING THE CODE LOCKED DOWN.
OBVIOUSLY I'D LIKE TO THINK- MY
COLLEAGUE AND SENATOR CAFIERO
FOR HER INPUT ON THIS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. OFTEN FEEL LEFT OUT AND
WHEN LEGISLATION IS PASSED IT
TENDS TO BENEFIT SOME OF OUR
LARGER REGIONS. AND I JUST
APPLAUD THE SENATOR FROM
SENATOR CAFIERO FROM AND FROM
THE MADERA MID MERCED AREA. TO
YOU AND JOIN US IN THIS FIGHT
TO RECOGNIZE IT AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WHEN WE STICK TOGETHER
GOOD PIECES OF LEGISLATION CAN
HAPPEN. I KNOW ALL OF YOU- HAVE
RESTAURANTS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE SUFFERING
INSIDE YOUR DISTRICTS. AND THIS
IS A GREAT STEP FORWARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR BUSINESSES HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY. TO AND HELP.
ELIMINATE SOME OF THE LOS THAT
THEY FACED OVER THE LAST YEAR
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
URGE A NO VOTE ON THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU CENTER
GROW MEMBERS. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. C. AND
HEARING THEM SENATE. MY CLOTHES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE SPEAKERS THAT- SPOKE TODAY
ON THE FLOOR. THIS IS REALLY
BEEN A TEAM EFFORT AND I WANT
TO THANK EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
YOU FOR SIGNING ON. EARLY ON TO
SB SEVENTY FOUR AS WELL AS
SIGNING ON TO. THIS BUSY BILL
AS WELL WE COULDN'T HAVE DONE
IT WITHOUT YOU AND QUITE
FRANKLY I THINK. ON ALL OF YOUR
EFFORTS AND YOUR SECURE
SIGNATURES MAKE THE MADE A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN- CREATING A TWO
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLAR-
PACKAGE IN THE END THAT'S WHAT
IT. IT WILL EVENTUALLY BE WHEN
ALL IS SAID AND DONE- THIS AS I
SAID IT'S BEEN A TEAM EFFORT SO
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I HAVE
RECOGNIZED THE STAFF AND I WANT
TO THANK GOD. MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM SENATOR FROM FRESNO FOR
DOING THAT- WE COULD NOT HAVE
GOTTEN TO THIS POINT THIS
QUICKLY. WITHOUT THEIR EFFORTS
ON. AND SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THEY HEAR ME LOUD AND CLEAR HOW
HOW THANKFUL I AM- BUT LET ME
LET ME JUST SAY THAT THIS
REALLY IS THE FIRST STEP. AND
WE'RE TAKING A NUMBER OF STEPS
BUT THIS IS THE FIRST STEP IN
TRYING TO ACHIEVE AN ECONOMIC.
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. AND OVER THE
NEXT BUT THIS UPCOMING YEAR. I
EXPECT THAT WE'LL SEE SOME
BILLS START TO PUT NEW
REGULATIONS OR NEW REQUIREMENTS
ON SMALL BUSINESSES. WHEN I ASK
YOU TO THINK CAREFULLY BEFORE
WE- TAKE THOSE STEPS BECAUSE-
THEY'RE HURTING AND THEY'RE
REALLY STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW AND
I THINK WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
MAKE SURE WE- WE- WE SEE THEM
ON A STRONG FOOTING. ARE THAT
THEY ARE ABLE TO OPERATE AND
START TO CREATE THE- ECONOMIC.
A THAT'S NAY TO BE ABLE TO
BRING PEOPLE BACK SO THAT THEY
CAN START WORKING. AND IF WE
CAN DO THAT THEN WILL WILL HAVE
ACHIEVED WHAT WE WANTED WE
ACHIEVE WHICH IS THAT. WOULD
HELP WILL HAVE OUR ECONOMY BACK
WILL HAVE THE REVENUE COMING
AND WILL HAVE PEOPLE BEING ABLE
TO. PAY THEIR BILLS PAY THE
RENT- AND THAT'S ALL THAT'S
EVERYTHING I THINK THAT ALL OF
US WANT TO SEE AFTER THIS
PANDEMIC SO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR SPEAKING TODAY THANK%
YOU FOR BEING SUCH GREAT
SUPPORTERS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR CABALLERO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA. I
ATKINS. FIVE BABIES. I BAKER.
FIVE FORGES. ON HI BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO HI CORTESE HI DALLY
HI DODD FIVE TERRAZZA HI EGGMAN
FIVE GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW.
HI HERTZBERG I HUESO. HUESO I
HER TADO I JONES FIVE LAYERED I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ
FIVE MILLION I NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN. I A TROUBLED I CAN
FIVE PORTANTINO HI ROTH. HI
RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER. HI STERN
HI UNDER HI FOR CALLOUSLY HI
WIENER AYE WILK HI. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO. WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR ALAN NOT
AT HIS DESK I THINK HE IS GOING
TO ANNOUNCE A Q. BUT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALAN AND EQ WILL BE
MEETING A ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS TO
DISCUSS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES FOR ALL OF THE
COMMENTS AND ALL OF THE WORK
THAT WE HAVE DONE TO GET. US TO
THIS MOMENT TODAY OUR NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
THURSDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY FIFTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT NINE AM
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
WILL BE ADJOURNED BUT WE WILL
PROCEED TO CENTERS REQUEST TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY. WE WILL
ROUTE WE WILL RECONVENE ON
THURSDAY AT NINE AM HAVE A
GREAT REST TODAY MEMBERS.
AND
TO STAY PLEASE STAY AT YOUR
DESK AND- NO TALKING PLEASE WE
ARE JOINING IN MEMORIES.
SENATOR BATES IF YOU WERE
PROCEED TO THE PODIUM HERE. AND
YOU HAVE TEN MINUTES TO DO YOUR
JOURNEY IN MEMORIES. AS SOON AS
EVERYONE HAS EITHER LEFT OR
SEAT AT THEIR DESK I WILL ASK
YOU TO PROCEED OKAY. SENATOR
BATES PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I DO HAVE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY SAID I'D LIKE
TO BEGIN WITH SOMEONE- FOR ON
THE OF SHERIFF SANDRA HUTCHENS-
IT'S HARD TO DO THIS BECAUSE
SHE WAS A VERY GOOD FRIEND AND
SHE DID PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY
FOURTH AFTER A LONG BATTLE WITH
BREAST CANCER MATCH HAS BEEN
COVERED IN THE NEWS. ABOUT
SANDRA BAT- I'D LIKE TO PUT IT
ON THE PUBLIC RECORD HE WAS AN
INCREDIBLE PUBLIC SERVANT OF
THE HIGHEST ETHICAL STANDARDS
THE FIRST FEMALE SHARE OF AN
ORANGE COUNTY SHE REBUILT THE
DEPARTMENT DAMAGED BY THE
PRESS. PREDECESSOR HAVE TO
BECOMING SURE OF WAS NOT A
TYPICAL ONE. ESPECIALLY IN A
FIELD THAT WAS SEEN AS AN OLD
BOYS CLUB. SHE WENT FROM A HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATE IN LONG BEACH
TO A PHARMACY TECHNICIAN. INTO
AN ICE CREAM SCOOPER. WELL
TAKING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CLASSES IN HER EARLY ADULT
YEARS. HE THEN WORKED AS
SECRETARY IN THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
BUT ULTIMATELY WANTED TO HELP
ENFORCE THE LAW. FIVE FOR THE
SHERIFF'S ACADEMY AND EARNED A
JOB AS A DEPUTY IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. AND ROSE THROUGH
THE RANKS AND BY TWO THOUSAND
THREE WAS NAMED DIVISION CHIEF
OF HOMELAND SECURITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF WHICH I WAS A
MEMBER AT THAT TIME. WAS
LOOKING FOR SOMEONE TO FILL THE
TWO YEARS REMAINING ON THE TERM
OF THE SHARE OF. WHO HAD
RESIGNED DUE TO CORRUPTION
ALLEGATIONS. CENTER HUTCHINS'S
ONE OF THE MANY PEOPLE WHO
APPLIED TO BE THE NEW SHERA. WE
WERE VERY IMPRESSED WITH HER
CREDENTIALS FOR PRINCE
PRESENTATION. AND VOTED TO. A
POINTER. I WORK CLOSELY WITH
HER ON MANY PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUES DURING HER TENURE TO
HELP RESTORE TRUST TO THE
DEPARTMENT. SHE WAS VERY VERY
HUMBLE PUBLIC SERVANT EVEN
THOUGH SHE HELD THIS VERY VERY.
IMPORTANT IN COUNTY WIDE JOB
AND LIKE TO BE A MAN STYLE.
LADIES ARE YOU WANT TO BE
CALLED SANDY NOT SURE OF. THE
WE ENJOYED A MUCH TIME
TOGETHER. WE DID NOT ALWAYS
AGREE ON EVERYTHING BUT SHE WAS
ALWAYS RESPECTFUL AND I HAVE TO
TELL YOU VERY CONVINCING ABOUT
HER POINT OF VIEW. SHE WAS IN
BODY AND SPIRIT FULLY INVOLVED
IN BEING THEIR SHARE OF
POSSIBLE ORANGE COUNTY. UPSKIRT
ZERO DHANGAR SAID IT BEST ABOUT
SHARE OF HUTCHINS TENURE. HE
SAID HE RESTORED OUR PRIDE GIVE
U BACK OUR DIGNITY AND REBUILD
TRUST WITH THE PEOPLE WE SERVE.
SO ON BEHALF OF ORANGE COUNTY
RESIDENTS BY ASSET MANAGER
NATURE OF QUESTIONS MEMORY. IN
EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO HER
LOVED ONES INCLUDING HER
HUSBAND LARRY THANK YOU. MY
NEXT ONE IS FOR ACTRESS CLORIS
LEACHMAN. I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF CLORIS LEACHMAN
WHO PASSED AWAY IN ENCINITAS.
ON JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH AT
THE AGE OF NINETY FOUR. HE WAS
A TRAILBLAZING AND INCREDIBLY
TALENTED ACTORS WHO EXCELLED IN
A VARIETY OF PROJECTS AND I
THINK MANY OF US REMEMBER HER
AND ENJOYED ON MANY OF THE OF.
THE- MANY OF THE- I THINK THAT
SHE WAS INVOLVED WITH THE IBM
BERIA'S TV SHOWS ARE CERTAINLY
ON ON THE BIG SCREEN SHE IS
PERHAPS BEST KNOWN FOR EARNING
AN OSCAR FOR HER ROLE IN THE
MOVIE THE LAST PICTURE SHOW IN
WINNING EMMY AWARDS DURING A
TELEVISION CAREER THAT
STRETCHED BACK TO THE MARY
TYLER MOORE SHOW. SHE WAS BORN
IN THE MORNING IN NINETEEN
TWENTY SIX THE OLDEST OF THREE
GIRLS HER MOTHER ENCOURAGED HER
IN THE ARTS AND SHE EVENTUALLY
ACTIVATED COMMUNITY PLAYHOUSE
WHICH EARNED HER A SCHOLARSHIP
TO STUDY DRAMA AT NORTHWESTERN
UNIVERSITY HOWEVER SHE LEFT
NORTHWESTERN TO ENTER BEAUTY
PAGEANTS WHERE SHE EARNED THE
MISSED CHICAGO TITLE AND
COMPETED IN MISS AMERICA SHE
THEN MVED TO NEW YORK TO STUDY
VOICE AND DRAMA AT THE ACTORS
STUDIO AND APPEARED ON SEVERAL
BROADWAY SHOWS. EVENTUALLY
LANDED ON TV AND THE MOVIES
WHERE SHE BECAME VERY VERY
FAMOUS COLORS LEACHMAN IS
SURVIVED BY HER CHILDREN MORGAN
ADAMS DINA AND GEORGE SIX
GRANDCHILDREN AND SEVERAL GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN I ASK THAT WE
INTERNET. HER MEMORY THANK YOU.
PLEASE BRING THEIR NAMES
FORWARD TO THAT THEY MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED.
SENATOR BAKER. SENATOR BAKER
YOU MAY PROCEED. GOVERNMENT
ENSURE MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HONOR SOME FOLKS
AT THE THIRTEEN RECENTLY PASSED
THE DREAMERS CONTRIBUTE TOWARD
GREATER PENINSULA COMMUNITY. WE
LOST MY FRIEND CATHERINE STROH
IN JANUARY TWENTY FOURTH WITH
THAT IN THE SERVICE AND
COMMUNITY I COME FROM IN THE
PARK. SHE LEVEL APART IS OUR
NEIGHBORS CITY COMMISSIONS
INCLUDING ON THE PLANNING
COMMISSION. THE HOUSING
COMMISSION. THE TRANSPORTATION
MASTER PLAN OVERSIGHT AN
AVERAGE COMMISSION. READY FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NEW CATHARINE
HE'S A PUBLIC AFFAIRS FOR
DECADES IN DIFFERENT POSITIONS.
GOOD IS A PUBLIC AFFAIRS
MANAGER FOR PARKS LOCKHEED
MARTIN IN THE DAIRY COUNCIL.
THE SERVER OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. HE
WAS VERY GENEROUS WITH HER TIME
WITH SEVEN ENERGY ESPECIALLY
WITH THOSE SEEKING HER GUIDANCE
WHEN RUNNING FOR OFFICE. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN SENDING CONDOLENCES
HER HUSBAND BILL DEMPSEY HER
FRIENDS FAMILY AND LOVED ONES.
ALSO TAKE A MOMENT TO HONOR THE
MEMBERS CAROL CONROY FOR
POSTMASTER CEMETERY OF THE
PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER
THIRTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY. SHE
GAVE A LEGACY OF PUBLIC
SERVANTS WHO SERVE. THE SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT HER
FATHER AND GRANDFATHERS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE FAMILY. I WAS SO
PROUD OF HER IRISH HERITAGE.
CAROL SOMEONE WHO HERSELF IN BY
THE BEST IN PUBLIC SERVICE. I
TOOK GREAT PRIDE IN HER CAREER
THE UNITED STATES POSTAL
SERVICE WHICH STARTED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE. THROUGH
THE YEARS SHE WORKED FOR THE U.
S. P. S. IN SAN FRANCISCO SAN
CARLOS NOT VIEW PALO ALTO DALY
CITY IN THE WESTERN REGION
HEADQUARTERS. CAROL HAD A HUGE
OTHER SAN MATTEO. THE LARGER
PENINSULA. THREE ON NUMEROUS
NONPROFIT BOARDS INCLUDING
COMMUNICATE PATH CEMETERY
COUNTY HEART WALK. CEMETERY
AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. AT
THE GROCERY AT PARTICULAR
FOUNDATION BOARD. IF YOU
CARILLO KNEW SHE BLED ORANGE
AND BLACK SHE WAS AT WORK OR
VOLUNTEERING CAL TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS GAMES SHE'S A
LONGTIME SEASON TICKET HOLDER.
HER BIGGEST PASSION YOUNG
PEOPLE. SHOULD HAVE SEEN YOUNG
PEOPLE SUCCEED AND WAS ACTIVE
FOR YEARS THE SEVENTY OF POLICE
ACTIVITIES LEAGUE. I THANK YOU
CHAMPION THE GANG RESISTANCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING GREAT
PROGRAM. DURING HER TIME ON THE
CEMETERY A PATH. THIS IS OFTEN
THE RESOURCES TO GET OFFICERS
TO ENGAGE WITH EVERY SINGLE
FIFTH GRADERS CEMETERY. RIGHT
EFFORTS FOR NAY BUT WHO KNOWS
HOW MANY STUDENTS LIVES THIS
PROGRAM AFFECTED. HE TRULY
BELIEVE THAT EDUCATION WAS THE
GREAT EQUALIZER AND YOU SAW
TENSION EVERY SINGLE YOUNG
PERSON THAT SHE MET. IT'S A
HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES TO
CAROL'S EXTENDED FAMILY MOST
PRESSURE SISTERS KATHLEEN PEGGY
AND EMORY. THE BILL TO RECENTLY
ALSO LOS MARSHALL CHILD FROM
SUNNYVALE TO PANCREATIC CANCER
THIS IS WEEKEND. THE VALLEY
FORGE STAGE FOR PANCREATIC
CANCER FOR SIX MONTHS EXITING
ALL HIS DOCTORS EXPECTATIONS.
PART OF THE FINANCIAL MODEL AND
A SWITCH RAID INVOLVED IN
NUMEROUS COMPANIES. HE'S A
FORMER BOARD MEMBER OF THE
SENATE BILL DEMOCRATIC CLUB AND
A MODEL FOR PROGRESSIVE VALUES.
HE WAS A VETERAN AND ACTIVISTS
CATHOLIC FAITH. WAS THE LAMEST
MINISTER WITH THE SAN JOSE
CATHOLIC DIOCESE. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN SENDING HEALING THOUGHTS
TO EVERYONE WHO LOVED MARTIAL.
WE LOST AN API TRAILBLAZER
EGGMAN ROSALYN FEW KNOWN AS RAS.
YES IN JANUARY AT THE AGE OF
NINETY FOUR. SHIPBORNE SHANGHAI
ATTENDED UC BERKELEY HAD A LONG
CAREER CFO OF ARCHITECTURAL
FIRM SB T. ASSOCIATES. AMONG
HER MANY CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
COMMUNITY I WOULD HIGHLY TO OF
ROSS'S BIGGEST PASSIONS. ROSTER
OF THE GREATER SEVENTY
COMMUNITIES SO MANY WAYS MOST
NOTABLY SUPPORT NEVER SELF HELP
FOR THE ELDERLY WHICH SHE
JOINED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR.
SELFHELP FOCUSES ON SERVING AND
EMPOWERING API OLDER ADULTS
THAT LIVE ON THE NORTHERN
PENINSULA. SHE ALSO LAUNCHED
THIS SPRING BY PROGRAM IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE THOUSAND
YOUNG WOMEN IN OUR NATIVE
CHANCY PROVINCE FROM ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL TO UNIVERSITY. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN SENDING CONDOLENCES
HER DAUGHTERS DEBBIE AND JACKIE
AND GRANDSON SAM. FINALLY I'M
SADDENED BY THE PASSING OF RUN
FOR YELLOW JUST A FEW DAYS AGO.
A GOOD FRIEND AND A LONGTIME
RESIDENT REDWOOD CITY. RON WAS
A MEMBER DIVERSE INTERESTS.
PRESSING SERVES AN ATTORNEY AND
COUNSELOR NUMBER START UPS AND
TECH COMPANIES. HE'S ALSO AN
ACTIVIST CO FOUNDER OF THE
VOTER GENOME PROJECT AND SERVED
ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTER PROJECT.
ALWAYS A TRUE BELIEVER IN THE
POWER OF EDUCATION. HE SERVED
ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR
HE WAS NEW SCHOOL AND SCHOLAR
MATCH. IS A LONG TIME MEMBER OF
THE NONPROFIT GRANT MAKING
GROUP I STARTED CALLED FULL
CIRCLE. I WORKED IN OUR
EDUCATION GRANTMAKING.
ITALIANIZATION HE PLAYED A FULL
CIRCLE BANDRA RETREATS.
ADDITIONALLY THE DOCUMENTARY
PRODUCER MOST OF THE ON THE G.
WORD WHICH EXPLORED WHAT
GIFTEDNESS LOOKS LIKE THE
VARIETY PEOPLE IN DIFFERENT
POINTS IN THEIR LIVES. HE'S A
PROUD GRADUATE GRADUATE ACROSS
UNIVERSITY AND ATTENDED CORNELL
FOR LAW SCHOOL. IF YOU'RE
DELIVER POLITICS OUR COUNTRY
AND IS CONSTANTLY HOSTING BUSY%
PARTITIONS ALONG WITH HIS WIFE
MARGARET. RUTTED INFECTIOUS
LOVE FOR LIFE RECOGNIZED BY ALL
WHO INTERACT WITH THEM IT WAS
AMAZING AND DEDICATED FATHER.
ON THIS RUN PLEASE JOIN ME
SENATE CONTROL SYSTEM AB ONE
WHO LOVED HIM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SENATOR PLEASE BRING
THEIR NAMES FORWARD TO THE
DEATH SO THAT THEY CAN BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED.
SENATOR BRADFORD. SENATOR
BRADFORD YOU MAY PROCEED THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY TO SOME AMAZING
INDIVIDUALS TOOK PASSED OVER
THE LAST YEAR FIRST LET ME
START WITH A FRIEND AND
NEIGHBOR MISTER ALICE FEARS
BETTER KNOWN BY SWEET TEA BUT
ALL THAT LOVE THEM AND KNEW HIM
MISTER FEARS WAS A TREMENDOUS
MEMBER OF THE HOLLY PARK
COMMUNITY WHICH I RESIDE. WHO'S
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE KASHMIR
GATEKEEPERS- NEIGHBORHOOD WATCH
PROGRAM BUT HE WAS AN
INCREDIBLE FAMILY. MISTER FEARS
SERVICE COUNTRY IN THE ARMY.
AND AFTER LEAVING THE MILITARY
HE BECAME A POSTAL WORKER CARRY
MAIL. BUT HE WAS A SHREWD
BUSINESSMAN AND HE INVESTED HIS
MONEY WSELY AND OPEN A SERIES
OF LIQUOR STORES IN SOUTH LOS
ANGELES AND THEN WENT ON TO
INVEST IN REAL ESTATE. BECOMING
A BROKER AND A DEVELOPER.
LEAVES BEHIND THEM- TWO
CHURCHES MEMORIES INCREDIBLE
WIFE VIRGINIA. FALL FOR AMAZING
KIDS GORDON SURE L. NATALIE AND
LISA ALL OF MINE HAD
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET AND KNOW
AND NATALIE AND LEASE AND I
GREW UP TOGETHER- AND A
GRANDFATHER AND GREAT
GRANDFATHER AS WELL. HE WAS A
TREMENDOUS COOK A LEGACY
DISAGREED INDIVIDUAL HE WILL BE
SORELY MISSED HE WAS A MAN OF
GOD A MEMBER OF THE BIBLE IN
RICHMOND- CHURCH IN INGLEWOOD
UNDER PASTOR SHIP OF- BAM
CRAWFORD. AND SO WHAT OUT. ANY
ADDITIONAL FURTHER DO I JUST
WANT TO THANK HIM FOR THE
FRIENDSHIP. FOR THE HONOR TO
CALL HIM A FRIEND FOR ALWAYS
SUPPORTING ME IN WHATEVER
ENDEAVOR I WAS INVOLVED IN IN
THE CITY OF GUARDINO WHEN I WAS
ON THE CITY COUNCIL WHEN I RAN
FOR THE STATE LEGISLATURE HE
ALWAYS. AFFORDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A GREAT
CONVERSATION IN PLACES SIGN IN
HIS YARD SO THANK YOU AND
YOU'LL BE MISSED. NEXUS
MISSISSIPPI VON MCDANIELS-
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S LIVED IN
GUARDINO FOR ALMOST FIFTY YEARS
RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER FROM
WHERE I GEW UP. ON HER KIDS
AND I USE THAT AN ARTSY WERE
CONTEMPORARIES WE GREW UP
TOGETHER MISS MCDANIELS WAS A
NURSE LIKE MY MOTHER SHE WORKED
AT. USC MEDICAL CENTER AND THE
BURN UNIT AND SHE DEDICATED
OVER FORTY YEARS OF OUR LIFE.
OF SERVING PATIENTS IN A UNIT
AT THE FACILITY SHE WAS A GREAT
NEIGHBOR ACTIVE ON OUR BLOCK
CLUB AS WELL- AND JUST. A WORD
OF ADVICE- AND I COULD JUST RUN
INTO MISS MAKE GENESIS A FEW
MONTHS BEFORE HER PASSING A
LAST YEAR- LOW EATERY RIGHT
AROUND THE CORNER FROM MY
HOUSE. WHEN WE WERE BOTH ORDERS
FOOD AND- SO MS MCDANIEL'S
FEELS SORELY BE MISSED AND- THE
HOLLY PARK COMMUNITY IN THE
CITY OF GUARDINO SOUL. BUT SHE
LEAVES- HER CHILDREN.
GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
CHARACTER CHILDREN TO CARRY ON
HER MEMORY AND HER LEGACY AND-
A LFE OF CARE GIVING. IN
COMPARISON. NEXT MOOSE DOROTHY
MATO KICK MUCH. BETTER MCCANN
I'M SORRY MISS THEME SOMEONE I
ALL WELL ON I'M SORRY FOR THAT-
BETTER KNOWN AS MOTHER MCKAY IN
THE NEIGHBOR. A WOMAN WHO. JUST
FALL INTO AT PRETTY ELEMENT THE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL THAT I TO A
MEMBER. E. T. A. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY A BUSINESS WOMAN
WHO OWNED A SALON- THE PER
SERVICES THE KING FOR DECADES
SHE WAS A WIFE SHE THE MOTHER
TO THE GROW. GREAT GRANDMA
SHE'S COMPASSIONATE NEIGHBOR
SPACE- WHO ALWAYS- WORDS ADVICE
FROM ANY WHO'S- HER COUNSEL AND
ALWAYS IF SHE SAW ME IN A SHE-
ALWAYS WAVE TO ME TO HAVE ME
COME AND ALWAYS HAD A COLD FOR
SOME THE WHEN I WAS PRECINCTS
AND SHE TO SEE A HER HUSBAND
ALWAYS STATED THE YOU KNOW EVEN
AFTER ASK. TO SIGN IN YARD IT'S
THOSE TYPE AND OF WHO INVOLVED
IN THERE CAN BUT FOR THE ONES
IN THERE FOR. THE TENSION BUT
JUST TO THE THING IN MAKING.
THAT THERE WAS REPRESENT AND
THEREFORE WERE. MISS MCCANN
WITH STEPHANIE EXAM SEE LEE
BEHIND HER SO LAMONT INCREASE.
AND ARE LEADERALL THREE WHO
ARE FOR OF MINE- GREAT
GRANDKIDS AS WELL AS- A GRAND
SONS- ONE OF WHICH I WAS
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO COACH JASON.
ENOUGH FOR SO. THERE AND DEAR
TO ME AND MISS. MCHALE WILL
SORT BE MISSED BUT NEVER
FORGOTTEN AND HOLLY PARK
COMMUNITY THE CITY OF. NEXT IS
A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE SURELY
HAVE TO CALL WE MAY. AFTER YOU
GRADUATE A LOS MICHAEL AND
MILLER. IS MIGHT NOT RING.
FAMILIAR TO A LOT OF FOLKS THE
NAY WARREN MILLER DOES. HE'S
NOT ONLY THE SUN THE GRAN OF
AFTERNOON JUDGE AND CALIFORNIA
HIS GRAND AS WELL AS IS SIR. IN
THE CAL. COURT FOR YEARS AND HE
TO IN HIS FOOTSTEPS AS A JUDGE.
WHAT EXTRAORDINARY OR HE WAS OF
THE ALTERNATIVE PUBLIC THE-
DEPARTMENT WITH L. A. K. FOR
YEARS WERE HIS PASS FOR. JUST
AND I SEE SPENDING OF MY FREE
TIME LAW. MIKE MILLER NEWPORT
ROOM HE WAS MASTER- WITH HIS
ARGUE HE- DID IT WITH SUCH
CHARM IT WAS A LITTLE BIT OF
SEKAC WAY- A LITTLE HUMOR- OF.
LAWYER AND HE'S OF THE RARE OF
RARE A THIRD GEN. AS WELL AS
SISTER ROBIN. THE MILLER SLOAN
WHO IS THE JOB SO MILLER BETTER
KNOWN AS- TO IS FOR. AGAIN WAS
IN DRESSER- FIVE CLOSING FEW
BUT IS PASS. WAS FAT CAR SO MY
KID EVERYTHING FROM FOR POINT
OWES TO. PORSCHE'S TO COURT-
AND SO HE HE WILL BE MET-
SORELY BY WIFE SHE MILLER WHO
IS THE JOB IN HIS DAUGHTER AND
HIS GRAND CHILDREN CARRY ON HIS-
MEMORY STILL THRILLER YOU WILL
BE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR MORE
PORN THANK YOU YOU WHAT YOU'VE
DONE AND ARE JUST SYSTEM THE
MAKE SURE FIGURE APPROVALS FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR. THANK YOU.
FIVE NEXUS BRUSSEL NO. ANOTHER
NEIGHBOR OF MINE. BEDSIDE NO
HARM FOR OVER YEARS MY LIFE SHE
LOW RIGHT ONE OF FROM ME. SHE
WAS A MAY- IN- SHE TO PART OF
THE KASHMIR'S CARE. BLOCK CLUB.
BUT SHE WAS A DEVELOP OF. WOMAN
OF CRY- PART OF THE UNITED
WOMEN'S METHODIST ONE CLUB.
WHERE SHE WAS PRESIDENT- CHURCH
THE HOW PARKING METHODIST
CHURCH SHE SIR FAITHFULLY. DECK.
SERVICE OF OTHERS AND TO OTHERS
AND THAT'S WHAT SHE DID HER
ENTIRE LIFE- JUST A VOLUNTEER
ANY TIME YOU NEED IT HELP.
NEEDED WHATEVER BEST WAS ALWAYS
THERE FOR YOU- ANYTIME I RAN
FOR OFFICE HE WAS CALLING ME
SAID WORDS A CAMPAIGN OFFICE I
WILL BE THERE AND- SHE WAS A
FAITHFUL- VOLUNTEER FOR ME BUT
SO MANY OTHER PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY. SHE LEAVES BEHIND.
THE I LOVE GRANDKIDS TRENT.
COURTNEY AND TRAVIS- GREAT
GRAND KIDS A SISTER MADELINE
AND HER AMAZING NIECE LORI SO
ON BEHALF OF THIS. CITY OF
GARDENA WILL MESSRS WELL BUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE WE WANT TO. ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF BASALT NO AND HER
INCREDIBLE LIFE- THAT SHE
LIVED. AND LOVED THE LORD.
NEXUS DOT WILLIE- JOE. BETTER
KNOWN AS DR J. IN THE CITY OF
COMPTON. DR JONES IS A FORMER
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PRESIDENT AS WELL AS A MEMBER
THE COMPTON CITY COUNCIL. HE
WAS THE EDUCATOR PASSIONATE
ABOUT EDUCATION HE WAS A MEMBER
OF THE UNITED METHODIST CHURCH-
IN COMPTON- LOYAL- FOLLOWER OF
THE LORD A INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS A
FAMILY MAN AND A FATHER
GRANDFATHER. AND JUST A ALL
AROUND GOOD INDIVIDUAL WHO
CHAIRS THE EDUCATION HE STARTED
OF A SCHOLARSHIP FOUNDATION
ACCOUNTING COMMUNITY COLLEGES
STILL LIVES ON TODAY. HE'S
LEGACY WAS NO. MIXING WORDS
WITH DOCTOR JONES THE WASN'T ON
ALL LOT OF TALK BUT WHEN YOU
SPOKE PEOPLE HE GAVE GREAT
ADVICE ALL THE TIME AND I HONOR
AND- JERSEY FRENCH IS TO IT.
PENN STATE DID ME TO I SAW THAT
YOU IF I NEEDED. CREATED BY.
FOR THOSE OF US- WHO WERE IN.
OF DOC. REALLY HELLO JONES
KNOWN AS DR J. HE WILL BE
SORELY AND- THIRTY FIFTH SENATE
DISTRICT. NEXUS FIRST LADY
LAURA NOR WOULD- MISS NOR WOULD
IT IS A I MATTER THE YOUNG AGE
OF A LOT OF SHE LIVED IN MY-
SHE WAS THE WIFE OF PASTOR
CHARLES NO. AND SHE WAS THE
MOTHER OF A LINE. GLANTON
ANTHONY AND SHE NOR AND ALL OF
LINDA- BUT SHE LIKE A
SURROGATE MOTHER TO ALL OF US.
HER HOME WHEN WAS THERE WITH
ALL OPEN THERE WAS FULL A MEAL
IN YOU WERE HOME YEARSTHE- SHE
HAD A CAREER IN THE PULSE
SERVICE BUT MORE IMPORTANT SHE-
AD A LIFE. OF HONORING GOD-
SERVING HER WHO WAS A PAST. AT
THE SIX COMMUNITY BAPTIST
CHURCH AND LOS. AND SHE LOOKED
GREAT LIFE AND SHE WILL BE
MISSED BY ALL THAT KNEW HER HER
FAMILY HER NEIGHBORS ON WILKIE-
AND THE HOLLY PARK COMMUNITY OF
GARDENA. AND I'M HONORED TO
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY. THEN WE
HAVE A INDIVIDUAL THAT I MET.
SOME TWENTY YEARS AGO- A LITTLE
OVER TWENTY YEARS AGO MISTER
LARRY KLAYMAN. AXTON FLINT
JUNIOR MISTER FLOOD OF ELDORADO
CARDROOM LICENSE IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. SO MUCH
OPPOSITION TO FOLKS IN THE
COMMUNITY BUT I HAD OPPORTUNITY
TO MEET MR FLYNT AND GET TO
KNOW MISTER FLYNN HAS AN
INCREDIBLE BUSINESSMAN BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY A PASSIONATE HUMAN
BEING ONE OF THE GREATEST
DEFENDERS OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT THAT I'VE EVER MET A
INDIVIDUAL WHO ALWAYS HAD SAGE
ADVICE AND SOMETHING FUNNY TO
SAY HE WOULD OFTEN CALL ME OUT
OF THE BLUE AND SAY HEY STEVE I
DON'T SEE YOUR NAME IN THE
PAPER NOW. I LIKE CONTROVERSY
YOU'RE NOT CONTROVERSIAL ENOUGH
FOR ME. BUT WE GOT ALONG GREAT
HE WAS A GREAT BUSINESSMAN FOR.
THE CITY OF GUARDINO WORK HE
NOW HAS A COMPONENT TO CAR
ROOMS HUSTLER CASINO. AND LUCKY
LADY. AND- IT'S OFTEN SAID
DON'T JUDGE A BOOK BY ITS COVER
I WOULD SAY DON'T JUDGE A
MAGAZINE BY ITS COVER- ONE OF
MR FLINT'S CLOSEST FRIENDS I
WAS INVITED TO HIS OFFICE ONE
DAY AND YOU HAPPEN TO BE ON THE
PHONE AND IT WAS WITH JERRY
FALWELL AND THEY WERE CARRYING
ON LIKE THE BEST OF FRIENDS
WHICH THEY WORK SO- AGAIN
MISTER FLAT WAS A SHREWD
BUSINESSMAN AND A VARIETY OF
AREAS AND- HE WILL TRULY BE
MISSED IN THE CITY OF GARDENA
HE'LL BE TRULY MISSED IN THE
PUBLISHING WORLD. AND HE'LL BE
MISSED IN DEFENSE OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. SENATE PLEASE BRING
THEIR NAMES FORWARD SO THAT
THEY CAN BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED.
MR PRESIDENT I
RISE TO REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF FIVE YEAR
CITIZENS FROM THE SANMON
CENTRAL AND THE SALINAS VALLEY.
EACH INDIVIDUAL'S CONTRIBUTIONS
TO SOCIETY SHALL SURVIVE THEM.
TODAY I ASK THE RETURN OF THE
MEMORY OF LUCILLE BARN TO
PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY. LUCILLE
BARNES CAME FROM HUMBLE AND
INDUSTRIOUS BEGINNINGS SHE
SPENT HER CHILDHOOD PERFORMING
BACKBREAKING FIELD WORK. WHERE
SHE DEVELOPED A HARD WORKING
SPIRIT THE FOLLOWED HER
THROUGHOUT HER LIFE TO SAY THAT
LUCILLE BARNES WAS A FEARLESS
TRAILER TRAILBLAZER WOULD BE AN
UNDERSTATEMENT. SHE WAS A ROLE
MODEL FOR WOMEN IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY BECOMING THE FIRST WOMAN
MAIL CARRIER IN MERCED HISTORY
WHERE SHE WORKED FOR ELEVEN
YEARS BEFORE RETIRING. HE
FAITHFULLY SERVED ON THE
MOSQUITO ABATEMENT BOARD FOR
TWENTY SIX YEARS AS THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN FEMALE
TRUSTEE. LUCILLE BARNES SIMPLY
COULD NOT BE STOPPED IN HER
RETIREMENT HE FORMED THE BARNES
TECH SERVICE PROVIDING TAX
PREPARATION AND ACCOUNTING
SERVICES WHICH CAME AS NO
SURPRISE TO FAMILY AND FRIENDS
TO KNOW HER WISH TO KNOW AN
INNOVATOR. SHE BRAVELY
CONFRONTED THE BERRIER SOCIETY
TRIED TO PLACE ON HER AMONGST
HER MANY WONDERFUL
CONTRIBUTIONS LUCILLE BARNES IS
SURVIVED BY A SISTER TWO SONS
TWO DAUGHTERS ELEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN. TWENTY THREE
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN AND TWO
GREAT GREAT GRANDCHILDREN AND
MANY MORE FAMILY MEMBERS AND
FRIENDS HE WAS AN INTREPID
LEADER AND ROLE MODEL FOR HER
FAMILY AND WOMEN EVERYWHERE.
REST IN POWER. MISS LUCILLE
BARNES. I REYES AGAIN HONOR THE
MEMORY OF CHARGE HUDDLESTON WHO
PASSED AWAY ON SO TWENTY
TWENTY. HE WAS A BELOW
BUSINESSMAN ORGANIZER AND
ADVOCATE IN THE COMMUNITY OF
MERCED CALIFORNIA. CHARLIE
HUDDLESTON WORKED TIRELESSLY TO
PRESERVE HISTORY'S PAST LESSONS
WHILE SERVING AS A AS A MENTOR
TO MANY CURRENT RESIDENCE HIS
TRANSFORMATIVE LEGACY IN THE
MERCED COMMUNITY INCLUDES
GALVANIZING THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY TO ADVOCATE FOR A
STREET DEDICATED TO THE MEMORY
OF MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
AND INITIATING THE FIRST
JUNETEENTH CELEBRATION OF
FREEDOM. MR ADULTS HUDDLESTON
SPENT HIS LIFE EDUCATING AND
UPLIFTING THOSE AROUND HIM BY
ORGANIZING FREQUENT EVENTS THAT
BROUGHT THE COMMUNITY TOGETHER
ACROSS ALL AGE GROUPS. HE
BELIEVED THAT CHILDREN ARE THE
FUTURE AND MADE A CONTINUOUS
EFFORT TO SPREAD HIS WISDOM TO
YOUNGER GENERATIONS RAISING
MONEY TO SUPPORT USE CAUSES AND
EMPHASIZING. THE VALUE OF AN
EDUCATION. MISTER HUDSON SOLID
AS A POWER OF THE CAN FOR HIS
DEDICATION TO YOU. HE WOULD
OFTEN GO INTO THE COMMUNITY AND
TRANSPORT STUDENTS TO SCHOOL IN
AN EFFORT TO KEEP THEM OUT OF
TROUBLE. HE WENT ABOVE AND
BEYOND TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CHILDREN HAD A CHAMPION IN
THEIR CORNER THANK YOU MISTER
CHARLIE HUDDLESTON FOR YOUR
DEDICATION TO SERVICE AND
COMPASSIONATE MAN MENTORSHIP. I
RISE TODAY TO ASK THAT THE
SENATE ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY
OF TOSHIKI YOUR ANTHONY. ANTI
MATSUI AN OUTSTANDING FOR TO
CULTURAL. BUSINESSMAN COMMUNITY
LEADER AND PHILANTHROPIST WHO
IS COMMITTED TO CULTIVATING
BEAUTIFUL FLOWERS AND YOUNG
MINDS. THE ART OF THAT
GARDENING BROUGHT MR MUCH SO WE
TO THE SALINAS VALLEY FROM
JAPAN. WHERE HE PURCHASED FORTY
ACRES OF LAND TO ESTABLISH THE
MUCH TO A NURSERY. HE WAS A
PIONEER IN THIS FIELD GROWING
WORLD RENOWNED CHRYSANTHEMUMS
WROTE ROSES AND EVENTUALLY
MARKETS AND SO IF YOU ENJOY A
BEAUTIFUL ORCHID YOU CAN THANK.
MR MATSUI WHO DEVELOPED A
STRATEGY TO BE ABLE TO GROW
THEM COMMERCIALLY. HIS BREADTH
OF KNOWLEDGE AND IMPECCABLE
BUSINESS ACUMEN ALLOWED MUCH WE
NURSERY TO FLOURISH BECOMING
ONE OF THE NATION'S MOST
CELEBRATED BURKE AND PRODUCERS.
MR MONTHS WE HAD A VISION FOR
EXCELLENCE THAT STAND SPANNED
FAR BEYOND HIS SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESS AND INTO THE
COMMUNITY. HE ESTABLISHED THE
MUCH SO WE FOUNDATION TO
SUPPORT UNDERSERVED STUDENTS IN
THE SALINAS VALLEY IN MONTEREY
COUNTY. THE FOUNDATION GIVES A
FULL RIDE SCHOLARSHIP TO A
STUDENT EVERY YEAR FOR EACH
PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL IN MONTEREY
COUNTY AND IS CHANGING
COUNTLESS LIVES DISTRIBUTING
MORE THAN EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS. THE COLLEGE BOUND
STUDENTS. MR MUDZURI WAS
EXCEEDINGLY GENEROUS MAKING THE
LARGEST DONATION TO A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY
IN THE FORM OF TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF FARMLAND. TO
THE HARTNELL COMMUNITY COLLEGE-
SHE'D GO. MIGHT SWEEP AWAY I
DECEMBER ELEVEN TWENTY TWENTY
AND SURVIVED HIS LOVING OF
SIXTY YEARS. CHILDREN AND- HE
WILL BE MET BY MANY BUT HIS
GENEROSITY LIVES ON IN THE
HEART OF THE SALINAS VALLEY.
THANK YOU MR MUDZURI FOR ACTING
AS A BEACON OF HOPE IN OUR
COMMUNITY TO STUDENTS. THAT
NEEDED A LEG UP. TODAY I RISE
TO REMEMBER THE LEGACY OF
JUSTIN JOSEPH AUSTIN ST IN USE
A CONNOISSEUR IN THE HOLLISTER
COMMUNITY WHO SHARED HIS
PASSION. FOR THE ART AS A
TEACHER. IT PERFORMANCE
PERFORMER AND INSPIRATION
FONDLY KNOWN AS MR- JOSEPH
AUSTIN FOUNDED THE RANCHO.
RANCHO SAN WHO'S THE MIDDLE
SCHOOL BAND PROGRAM OFFERING
TRUMPET LESSONS AND FACILITATED
A POSITIVE INTRODUCTION FOR
PEOPLE OF ALL AGES TO MUSIC IN
THE HOLLISTER AREA. HE WAS
STEADFAST IN HIS DEDICATION TO
HIS STUDENTS HIS TALENTS GAVE
HIM THE ABILITY TO TAKE. TO
MAKE MUSIC ACCESSIBLE TO
EVERYONE NO MATTER THEIR LEVEL
OF EXPERTISE HE RETIRED FROM
TEACHING AFTER FORTY SIX DIED
AM GEARS AND FOUNDED YET
ANOTHER MUSICAL VENTURE MISTER
OH'S ACADEMY THE FINE ARTS
ACADEMY IN DOWNTOWN HOLLISTER.
IS ACADEMY BECAME A SAFE HAVEN
FOR MUSICIANS OFFERING
FELLOWSHIP AND TRAINING FOR
PEOPLE WITH A SHARED PASSION.
NOT SEPARATE JOSEPH AUSTIN ON
BEEN FOR HIS MUSE. AND HE SAID
QUOTE. YOU CAN PLACE FOR. AND
DO OTHER AT FOR SURE TO OF TIME.
BUT ME IS SOMETHING YOU CAN DO
UNTIL YOU'RE OLD AND GRAY.
MISTER AUSTIN ST EMBRACED HIS
ROLE AS A LEADER HE WAS MORE
THAN A TEACHER HE USED MUSIC TO
CREATE A COMMUNITY. MUSIC
REPRESENTED LOVE IN EVERY PART
OF HIS LIFE HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS DEVOTED WIFE AND DAUGHTER
WHO HAVE FOND MEMORIES OF
PLAYING A SUPPORTIVE ROLE IN
HIS CAREER. MR AUSTIN SEND
DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO MUSIC AND
TRIUMPHANTLY SHARED HIS
ENTHUSIASM AND SKILLS WITH THE
WORLD TO INSPIRE MUSICIANS ALL
OVER THE CENTRAL COAST COAST I
ASKED THE SENATE. TO ADJOURN IT
IS MEMORY TODAY. AND FIND.
ARRIVED TODAY TO ASK THAT THE
SENATE ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY
OF SURELY LOVER AUTO WHO PASSED
AWAY ON APRIL TWENTY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY. A DEDICATED
HUMANITARIAN SURELY ELABORADO
WAS CELEBRATED LOCALLY AND
GLOBALLY FOR HER DETERMINATION
TO LEAVE THE WORLD A BETTER
PLACE THAN SHE FOUNDED. HER
WORK EARNED HER A VARIETY OF
HONORS INCLUDING THE BEN AND
MADDIE AND TAE MEDAL FROM POPE
BENEDICT THE SIXTEENTH. THE
HONOREE AWARD FROM THE AMERICAN
CANCER SOCIETY THE LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT AWARD FROM THE
ALLIANCE ON AGING. THE PANTHER
AWARD FROM THE CHRISTIAN
BROTHERS FOUNDATION THE
PHILADELPHIA PHILANTHROPIC
AWARD FROM SALINAS VALLEY
MEMORIAL HOSPITAL AND THE
NATIONAL PHILANTHROPY AWARD.
SHE WAS A DEVOUT WOMAN A CIVIL
SERVANT A MOTHER A SISTER A
DAUGHTER A WIFE A GRANDMA
MOTHER AND A FAITHFUL MEMBER OF
ST JOSEPH PARISH IN SPRECKELS
CALIFORNIA. DESPITE HER
SPECTACULAR ACHIEVEMENTS AND
MANY COMMITMENTS SURELY
ELABORADO CONSIDERED YOUR
FAMILY TO BE HER GREATEST PRIDE
AND JOY. HE IS SURVIVED BY A
LOVING HUSBAND OF FIFTY NINE
YEARS THREE SONS THREE SIBLINGS
AND FIVE GRANDCHILDREN. SURELY
LABRADOR TOUCH THE LIVES OF
EVERYONE SHE CAME INTO CONTACT
WITH HER SELFLESS SERVICE
SERVICE HAS LEFT ITS IMPACT ON
THE WORLD. THANK YOU FOR
BELIEVING IN HUMANITY COMMUNITY
AND LOVE MRS LOVER OUT OF.
THESE FIVE INFLUENTIAL LEADERS
OF THE TWELFTH SENATE DISTRICT
WILL BE MESSED IN THE WORDS OF
RALPH WALDO EMERSON. TO LEAVE
THE WORLD A BIT BETTER WHETHER
BY A HEALTHY CHILD A GARDEN
PATCH OR A REDEEMED SOCIAL
CONDITION. TO KNOW THAT EVEN
ONE LIFE HAS BREATHED EASIER
BECAUSE YOU HAVE LIVED THAT IS
TO HAVE SUCCEEDED. I ASKED. TO
BE INJURED IN THEIR MEMORIES
TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
CAFIERO PLEASE BRING THEM FORZA
THEY CAN BE MEMORIALIZE SAID.
ROGER FOR TAKING CENTER COURT
DATE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT.
IT'S WITH DEEP SADNESS THAT
ARISE NECESSARY TO ADJOURN HIM
OF REV BUILDING REVENUE MANAGER
PRIEST ORDAINED IN NINETEEN FOR
SIX WAS DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
SOCIAL JUSTICE PROGRAMS A
PUBLIC SERVICE PARTICULARLY IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY REMINDERS
ACTIONS AND BODY THE ESSENCE OF
CHRISTIANITY AND THAT HE WORKED
TIRELESSLY FOR THOSE IN NEED
AND WOULD HELP ANYONE
REGARDLESS. OF THEIR FAITH OR
BACKGROUND. THE GENERAL LOVE
WHAT HE DID A LITTLE VOTER TO
OTHERS. THIS TO WAS TO THE
SERVICE THE OWNERS. WHICH LED
HIM TO SERVE ON SEVERAL
COMMISSIONS AND BECOME ACTIVE.
WITH LABOR UNIONS. WHETHER
ATTENDING A MEETING OR
PROTESTING HE WAS FULLY
COMMITTED TO FAIR TREATMENT FOR
ALL I ASKED THE SENATOR IN THE
MEMORY OF REVENUE BILL LEDGER.
THANK YOU. IT IS WITH DEEP
SADNESS THAT I RISING NOW
SYSTEM THE TWO GERMAN IN THE
MEMORY OF DAVE MICHELETTI. WHO
PASSED AWAY UNEXPECTEDLY
EARLIER THIS YEAR FOLLOWING
HEART ISSUES MISTER MICHELETTI
WAS A TREASURED COMMUNITY
MEMBER. THIS CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB SILICON
VALLEY WERE IMMENSE. HE SERVED
ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF
THE CLUB FOR ELEVEN YEARS.
INCLUDING TWO TEN YEARS AS A
CHAIR OF THE BOARD. MR MCCARTY
WAS A GENEROUS SUPPORTER. IN
MANY WAYS ANY ALWAYS LOVE TO
SAY. IT'S FOR THE KIDS. AS A
CONCLUSION TO ANY CONVERSATIONS.
NOT ONLY WAS MISERICORDIA
SHINING OF WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
A GREAT SERVANT TO A BECAUSE AN
ORGANIZATION. HE ALSO OF SAN
JOSE IT WAS DEEPLY COMMITTED TO
HIS COMMUNITY. I ASKED THE
PERSON ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY.
OF DAY MEDICAL. A WITH THE
ABSURD. IT IS A OUR RIGHTS IN
ESTES TO J. MEMBER OF JEAN BARR
CALL KNOWN AS- JIM THE TAX MAN
BURKE. PASSED AWAY IN. PRIOR TO
PAST. MISTER BARBECUE BEEN
DOING. FOR THE AREA COMMUNITY
FOR OVER SO. YEARS IN NINETEEN
FORTY EIGHT MISTER BURKE BARBET
BEGAN A PROFESSIONAL BASEBALL
CAREER. PLAYING FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO SEALS. HE WOULD THEN
GO ON TO PLAY FOR THE SANTA
ROSA ROSE BUDS. IN GREENVILLE
RIVER RATS- IN THE INDEPENDENT
LEAGUES. HE WAS THEN TAKEN
STRONG RIGHT HAND START DOWN
THE PATH. AS A PROFESSIONAL
BOXER. FOR BEGINNING LOOK AT
CAREER. AS A TWO PER. WITH ONE
OF HIS BEST FRIENDS. HE SERVED
TO ALONG OF ME FOR MANY YEARS
ON THE BOARD OF LINCOLN LAW
SCHOOL IN SAN JOSE. PASSED THE
SENATE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY. OF
JAMES BARBER. ARIZA NECESSARY
TO JOURNEY THE MEMORY OF FRED
HERSCH. WHO SADLY PASSED AWAY
LAST DECEMBER DUE TO
COMPLICATIONS FROM A STROKE. MR
HIRSCH WAS A LABOR LEADER AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER IN THE
HEART OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY HE
VIEWED AS COST CONSCIOUS WORK
NOT AS THE WORK OF ONE PERSON
ALONE BUT AS A PRODUCT OF A
HISTORY OF A SET OF IDEAS AND
OF A COLLECTIVE OF PEOPLE
FIGHTING TOGETHER. MR HIRSCH
WAS A KEY ORGANIZER FOR LABOR
CIVIL RIGHTS AND ANTI WAR
MOVEMENTS. IN SUPPORT OF IT
SIGNAL SOCIAL MOVEMENT THAT
SPRUNG UP IN THE SOUTH BAY AREA.
MR HURST IS SURVIVED BY HIS
PARTNER MARTIANS THREE DOLLARS
AND A PLETHORA OF LOVING
GRANDCHILDREN. PASSED THE
SENATE ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY
MEMORY OF FRED HERSCH. I
RESIDENTS THE SENATE TO JUROR
IN THE MEMORY OF LEON TALLEY.
WHO LOST BATTLE WITH LAST MONTH.
MISTER TELLY VOLUNTEERED FOR
UNITED STATES ARMY IN NOVEMBER
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO WHERE HE WAS
ASSIGNED TO THE NORTHERN ISLAND
HOKKAIDO OF JAPAN IT WAS THERE
WHERE HE MET THE LOVE OF HIS
LIFE. PUTS A CO OHTANI AND THEY
WERE LATER MARRIED IN THE
AMERICAN EMBASSY IN TOKYO. OVER
THE COURSE OF THIRTY YEARS IN
THE ARMY MR TELL HIT TWO TOURS
IN KOREA TWO TOURS IN VIETNAM
ONE TOUR IN OKINAWA. OKINAWA
AND ONE TOUR IN GERMANY IN THE
NINE DIFFERENT STATES. AFTER
LEAVING THE UNITED STATES ARMY
MISTER TALLY WENT ON TO WORK AT
KAISER ELECTRONICS
INDIVIDUALLY. RETIRED FROM THE
AEROSPACE COMPANY ROCKWELL
COLLINS. IN HIS RETIREMENT MR
TODD BECAME A PRE MERE MEMBER
AND VOLUNTEER THE SAN JOSE
JAPANTOWN LIONS CLUB. YES OF
THE SENATE ADJOURNED. IN MEMORY
OF ME ON TELLY. SO ARISE SENATE
TO EACH THE MEMORY OF A FRIEND
NO MONTH. THE TREASURE PASSED
AWAY LAST TO CORONA CALLED.
MISTER MONTEL WAS IN PERFORMER
A WHO MARCHED ALONG SCISSORS.
FOR THE RIGHTS OF. MISTER
MONTEL WAS ALL A LONG TIME AND
MUSE. FOR A CREW COME SINGLE
WHICH IS SPANISH FOR THE FORMER
THEATER IN SANTA BAUTISTA IT
WAS PARTICULARLY FOR ROLE. AS
THE AS SON. MISTER OIL WILL BE
BEHIND IS YOUR SON ROBERT WE
OFFER SAYING FORM GUITAR FOR
OVER THREE. I RESPECTFULLY THAT
SENATE. IN MEMORY OF KNOWING
MONTHS. AND FOR IT IS WITH DEEP
SO THAT ARE RISING ASSISTANT TO
JOE THE MEMORY OF SICK. ST
INCHES. SIX INCHES WAS LEVEL
SHOW BORN HOSTED PARENTS.
MISTER SANCHEZ WHO GREW UP
WORKING THE FIELDS AS A FARMER
WOULD EVENTUALLY SERVE IN
MULTIPLE ROLES IS ELECTED
OFFICIAL INCLUDING ON THE GORY
COUNCIL AS MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
GILROY. IN ON THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. HE
ALSO SERVED AFTER THE ON THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT BOARD FOR NUMBER OF
YEARS. MISTER SANCHEZ WAS A
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT TO SAY
THE LEAST SERVING A TOTAL OF
FIFTY FIVE YEARS IN PUBLIC
OFFICE. HE DID HIS BEST TO
ENSURE THE PROSPERITY OF HIS
COMMUNITIES. HE DIED IN HIS ONE
HUNDRED FIRST YEAR. IN IT IS A
SOMEWHAT. INTERESTING THAT
HIGHWAY ONE OH ONE ALONG THE
STREETS OF GILROY IS NAMED
AFTER HIM. HIS IS SURVIVED BY
HIS THREE SIBLINGS FIVE
CHILDREN AND THIRTEEN
GRANDCHILDREN. I ASKED AGAIN
RESPECTFULLY THAT THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF SIX
INCHES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
FORWARD TO THE DEATH SO THAT
THEY CAN BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED. CENTER DRAWS OF.
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I ASKED TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF THE FOLLOWING UP
MANY INDIVIDUALS UNFORTUNATELY
WHO PASSED AWAY IN MY IN MY
DISTRICT. FIRST IT'S TIME FOR
DODGER BASEBALL AFTER SEVENTY
ONE YEARS IN THE DODGER
ORGANIZATION TOMMY LASORDA
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF
NINETY THREE. AS THE MANAGER HE
LED THE DODGERS TO TWO WORLD
CHAMPIONSHIPS FOUR NATIONAL
LEAGUE PENNANTS AND EIGHT
DIVISION TITLES THE SORT OF
CAME OUT OF RETIREMENT TO LEAVE
THE U. S. OLYMPIC BASEBALL TEAM
TO A GOLD MEDAL IN TWO
THOUSAND. AND HE WAS ENSHRINED
IN THE BASEBALL HALL OF FAME AS
A MANAGER IN HIS FIRST YEAR OF
ELIGIBILITY IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN HE ALWAYS CLAIMED THAT HE
BLED DODGER BLUE AND MORE SO
WHEN THE DODGERS WON THE WORLD
SERIES THIS PAST FALL. ONE OF
HIS MEMORABLE CODES QUOTES WAS
I SEE FROM THE BOTTOM. I SAY
FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART BUT
IF YOU DON'T ROOT FOR THE
DODGERS YOU MAY NOT GET INTO
HEAVEN. KAMALA SORT OF NOW IN
DODD HIM AND- ON JANUARY
SEVENTH FORMER LOS ANGELES
COUNCILMAN TOM LABONTE PASSED
AWAY AT THE AGE OF SIXTY SEVEN
HAVING REPRESENTED THE FOURTH
COUNCIL DISTRICT FOR FOURTEEN
YEARS HE SPENT NEARLY FORTY
YEARS AS THE ULTIMATE GOOD WILL
AMBASSADOR AND HISTORIAN FOR
HIS. CITY OF ANGELS. ONE GOMEZ
KING YANIS ON TUESDAY NOVEMBER
ELEVENTH WE LOST A FRIEND A
BRILLIANT SCHOLAR ACTIVIST AND
POET WITH THE PASSING OF DR ONE
GOMEZ KENYANS. HE WAS BORN IN
TIJUANA MEXICO AND REYES IN
BOYLE HEIGHTS HE EARNED DEGREES
FROM UCLA WHERE HE SERVED ON
THE FACULTY FOR ALMOST FIFTY
YEARS. CONDUCTED RESEARCH AND
TAUGHT COUNTLESS STUDENTS WHO
LATER BECAME LEADERS IN THEIR
CAREERS HE WAS A TRUSTEE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. THE BOARD THE
MOTHER OF ONE STOP IMMIGRATION
AND CO FOUNDER OF THE LEFT IN
THE MUSEUM AND KEY ADVISOR
INFORMING SIMI AS COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS IN MY DISTRICT. ROSE
OCHI. THE GUY OVER. MY TO WAS
AN ATTORNEY CIVIL RIGHTS ACT
AND POLITICAL STRATEGY. WHO
SHATTERED NUMEROUS GLASS
CEILINGS HE WAS THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN WOMAN COMMISSIONER ON
THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
COMMISSION. THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN WOMAN ASSISTANT U. S.
ATTORNEY GENERAL. HE WAS BORN
AT THE HISTORIC JAPANESE
HOSPITAL IN EAST LA. BUT OUR
FORMATIVE YEARS HAPPENED AS SHE
AND HER FAMILY WERE. INTERNED
IN AN AMERICAN CONCENTRATION.
CAMPS DURING WORLD WAR TWO. HE
JOINED MAYOR TOM BRADLEY WHERE
SHE DEVELOPED THE USE OF FORCE
POLICY AFTER YOU LOVE AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN WAS
KILLED BY THE LAPD. IN NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN PRESIDENT BILL
CLINTON NAMED OCHI THE FIRST
ASIAN AMERICAN WOMAN TO SERVE
AS THE ASSISTANT GENERAL.
ATTORNEY GENERAL LEVEL. ROBERT
TOMASZ ALMOST ENJOYED A LONG
AND DISTINGUISHED CAREER AS A
SUCCESSFUL ATTORNEY BUT NEVER
FORGOT WHERE HE CAME FROM. HE
WAS BORN IN KINGSBURG. HIS
FAMILY WORKED IN THE FIELDS HE
WAS PART OF A GROUP OR LATINOS
INTEGRATED PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES
DURING THE SIXTIES. HE WAS A
LONGTIME PARTNER WITH THE
PRESTIGIOUS FIRM OF ALREADY
MORAL GOAL AND GOLDBERG. HE WAS
A VOLUNTEER DEAN AND PROFESSOR
OF PEOPLE'S COLLEGE OF LAW.
AMONG THE STUDENTS RUN DOWN
YOU'LL BE AT I GO SAID
GILBERT'S THE L. AND ME. BUT MY
THING IS WHY THE SPENT SAID AND
EARLY. NINETIES FROM TO. TEACH
CLASSES FOR LEGAL APPRENTICE AT
THE U. OF W. IN LA PAZ. UNTIL
KNOW DALY WAS BORN TO MAKE IN
PASSED AWAY FROM CLUB IN
NINETEEN. WE BOTH STARTED
ARGUING CAREERS IN THE LADIES
GARMENT WORKERS UNION AND HE
WENT ON TO FOUND BE A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL UNION OF
HEALTH CARE WORKERS. HERE TO
REPUTATION AS A- TOUGH DEFENDER
WORKERS RIGHTS THROUGHOUT HIS
SEVENTEEN YEARS IN OFFICE IN
THE UNION. SELA MARCOS ALMOST
TWENTY SAID IT WAS A TELLEMENT
TREE. CHARGE NURSE AT HOLLYWOOD
PRESBYTERIAN MEDICAL BUSHY
FOUGHT ON THE FRONTLINES
AGAINST COVERT NINETEEN. DO THE
DUE TO THE LACK OF P. B. E.
SUPPLIES AT THE TIME. THE ONLY
HAD A SURGICAL MASK FOR HER
PROTECTION. SHE GOT THE VIRUS
AND TRAGICALLY PASSED AWAY. AND
SHE IS- UNDER FELLOW SEIU
MEMBERS WERE. VERY SAD TO LOSE
HER AS A NURSE THAT WENT ABOVE
AND BEYOND TO HELP OUR
PATIENTS. KATHLEEN STEPHENS IS
REMEMBERED AS A LONGTIME
VOLUNTEER PUBLIC SERVANT
WORKING AS A PTA PRESIDENT
EAGLE EAGLE ROCK SCHOOL. HE
ORGANIZED EFFORTS LIKE
OPERATION CLEAN SWEEP. A TOY
DONATION PROGRAM FOR ORPHANS IN
TIJUANA. NEIGHBORHOOD WATCH AND
THE SOFTBALL COACH AT THE LOCAL
PARK HE IS SURVIVED BY HER.
HUSBAND BRUCE THEIR SON JACOB'S
DAUGHTER AMBER AND THEIR
GRANDDAUGHTER. THE NEW NEW
ISN'T OF SALVADOR FOR OVER
THREE THAT FORTY TO AND- THAT
EMERGE FAMILY HAD I TO SEE. THE
NON. GROUPS LIKE THAT IS
SENTENCE. HE ALSO MADE COUNTRY
TO THE- PROCESS. SERVING AS REP
FOR CAL. CALIFORNIA'S SEN
SPEAKER FIVE ON FIVE YOUNG
MILLIONS PRESENT PRO TEM. OF
THE SENATE UP. CALTRANS TO
SENATE KEVIN DE LEON. UNTIL
YUBA OUT BAD MIGRATE TO THE
UNITED STATES FROM MEXICO. IN
THE MID NINETY NINE. ANY THEY-
HE HELPED EMIGRATE WORKERS MAIL
OF DOLLARS IN UNPAID WAGES
ADVOCATED FOR DRIVER'S LICENSE
AND TRAIN THOUSANDS OF
GRASSROOTS LEADERS. AND FINALLY
LET THE COORDINATION OF MAY DAY
MARCHES AS DIRECTOR ORGANIZING
FOR CHIRLA. HE UNFORTUNATELY
DIED OF COALBED ON JANUARY
TWENTIETH. RUDY SALAS CO
FOUNDER OF THE LATIN R&B BAND
ERA AND A MEMBER OF THE SOUL
GROUP INTO. IF YOU'RE THIS
RADIO AND EIGHTY YOU MAY HAVE
BEEN SLOW DANCING TO ONE OF THE
L. AS VEGAS HITS. A REMAKE OF
THE INTRUDERS SONG TOGETHER.
THE OTHER ONE SELECTED AS BEST
R&B VOCAL GROUP BY. BILLBOARD-
PERFORMED ONSTAGE WITH J. BROWN
MICHAEL JACKSON CHICAGO AND
MANY OTHERS HE SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE ANGELA. AND THEIR CHILDREN
STEVE. FOR ALL FORTY YEARS
STEVE HELPED SHAPE LOS ANGELES
SKYLINE TRANSFORM POLICY AND
POLITICS. AND SET THE STANDARD
FOR WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A
TRUSTED ADVOCATE. HE FOUNDED
THE APHRIA CONSULTING GROUP AND
WON THE APPROVAL OF MORE THAN
TWO BILLION DOLLARS WITH THE
BONDS FOR VITAL SERVICES. IN
THE CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD HE
HAD A PERFECT RECORD OF WINNING
CANDIDATES CAMPAIGNS AND BALLOT
MEASURES. AND LAST REGULAR
CHEESE WAS A MEMBER OF THE
SOUTH OF SEVERAL LATINO CIVIC
AND NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS.
AND RAISE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR ORGANIZATIONS WITH A
SPECIAL FOCUS ON CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES HE IS SURVIVED BY A
SON VINCENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MANAGER.
THE LEGISLATIVE
BEGIN JUST GO FOR. BY I RISE IN
THE GERMAN IN MEMORY OF CHURCH
FRIENDS AND CONSTITUENTS IN MY
DISTRICT THE FIRST I JOIN IN
MEMORY FOR CAROLINE AND SWITH
SMITH WHAT'S LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA SHE WAS BORN MAY
SIXTEENTH NINETEEN SIXTY THREE
AND ARBOR MICHIGAN ATTENDED
EVER AT HIGH SCHOOL IN LANSING
AND EARNED HER ASSOCIATE OF
SCIENCE DEGREE IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE HE WAS A POLICE OFFICER
AND DETECTIVE BEFORE SHE MOVED
TO LONG BEACH OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO AND TOOK AN ACTIVE
ROLE IN CREATING A TAPESTRY OF
COMMUNITY PROJECTS THAT
CONTINUES TO SPREAD THROUGHOUT
THE CITY. AND SHE SAID THE
NEWMAN- NUMEROUS BOARDS AND
REACHING THE LIVES OF THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
ALL COMMUNITIES IN LONG BEACH
SHE FOUNDED TWO ORGANIZATIONS
THANK GOD I FOUND YOU A
NETWORKING PLATFORM FOR WOMEN
TO SHARE IDEAS AND RESOURCES
AND FALL OFF SPECIALTY A
COMMUNITY MARKETING AND SPECIAL
EVENTS SERVICES BUSINESS HE
PASSED AWAY UNFORTUNATELY ON
NINETEEN CAROLINE WAS COMMITTED
TO HER FAITH. HER HUSBAND HER
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY. NEXT AT
LIKE TO TURN IN MY FOR ME
UNICEF SO LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA. EUNICE NOTICE AUTO
SERVED AS THE FIRST FEMALE
MAYOR AND FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN
MAYOR OF LONG BEACH. FROM
NINETEEN EIGHTY TO NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO AND PASSED AWAY JUST
RECENTLY AT THE AGE OF NINETY
NINE. THE DAUGHTER OF JAPANESE
PERRANCE. SUCCULENTS OUR MADE A
NOTE I. THOUGHT IT WAS ON ALSO
THE FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN WOMEN
TO SERVE AS A MAYOR OF ANY
MAJOR AMERICAN CITY SHE SERVED
ON THE COUNCIL UNTIL NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX INCLUDING THE TWO
YEARS WHEN SHE WAS MAYOR. AFTER
LEAVING COUNCIL. COVER GEORGIA
GOVERNOR GEORGE DEUKMEJIAN
APPOINTED HER TO THREE STATE
COMMISSIONS AND PORT PRESIDENT
GEORGE H. W. BUSH APPOINTED HER
TO THE NATIONAL ADVISORY
COUNCIL. ON ACTED EDUCATIONAL
RESEARCH IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
SHE WILL BE MISSED. NEXT I'D
LIKE TO TURN IN MEMORY FOR ALL
THESE SOLEIL SOON YOU SEEN.
BELL CAL. A LEASE A LESSEE. WAS
ONE OF THE FIRST LEBANESE TO
ARRIVE IN THE CITY OF BELL IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE. HE CAME
WITH LITTLE TO NOTHING BUT JUST
HE AND HIS WIFE HE WENT FROM
SELLING USED ITEMS AT THE LOCAL
SWAP MEET TO DEVELOPING A
THRIVING FAMILY BUSINESS THAT
SUPPORTED HIS FAMILY. HE DID
NOT JUST LET HIS FAMILY AND HE
LOVED THE CITY OF BELL AND YOU
LOVE SELA SOUTHEAST L. A. HE
LEAVES BEHIND HIS WIFE THREE
SONS WHICH IS THE MAYOR OF ONE
OF WHICH IS THE MAYOR BELLE
ISLE EASILY JUNIOR. NINE
GRANDCHILDREN. AND COUNTLESS
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE LOST A
ROLE MODEL HIS EXAMPLE OF HOW
TO LIVE WITH COMPASSION.
EMPATHY AND LOVE FOR EVERYONE.
NEXT I'D LIKE TO TURN IN MEMORY
FOR HENRIETTA COMEY ANA. LONG
BEACH CALIFORNIA. HENRIETTA
ATTENDED POLY HIGH SCHOOL AND
WAS VERY ACTIVE IN THE
PERFORMING ARTS HAVING PLAYED
THE TENOR SAXOPHONE AND
CLARINET. IN MARCHING BAND AND
PIANO IN JAZZ BAND. LATER IN
LIFE SHE BECAME A CARE GIVER
FOR PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
IT WAS APPARENT THAT PROVIDING
CARE FOR OTHERS WAS WHAT SHE
MEANT TO DO IN LIFE. HE PASSED
AWAY AND WAS UP. UNFORTUNATELY
PASSED AWAY IN TWENTY TWENTY
MAY FIRST AT CITY OF HOPE
SURROUNDED BY HER SIX CHILDREN
JENNIFER JERRY EDWARD JOSEPH
HEATHER AND ROBERT. AND WILL BE
MISSED. NEXT A DEAR FRIEND
ELLEN GRACE CAME GOOD IN A GAL
CALIFORNIA ALLEN WAS KIND
HEARTED AND A BELOVED MOTHER TO
MATEUS AND WIFE TO CHRIS A DEER
DEPENDABLE FRIEND THAT LEFT
THIS WORLD MUCH TOO EARLY. SHE
WAS FULL OF POSITIVITY AND
LIGHT A LOVER OF THE OUTDOORS
AND EIGHTIES MUSIC. SHE WAS
ALSO A SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER FOR K. THROUGH TO
CALIFORNIA USED IN ORANGE
COUNTY. HE SUDDENLY PASSED AWAY
IN AUGUST TWENTY THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY AND WILL BE DEARLY
MISSED. NEXT W. LEFT AND GREG
O'DONNELL WE ARE CALIFORNIA.
GABRIELLE WAS BORN IN LIMA PERU
IN NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT SHE WAS
THE MOTHER OF LONG BEACH MAYOR
ROBERT GARCIA. AND MY SENATE
STAFFER JACOBA DONALD. GET
REALLY CAME TO THE U. S. WITH
DREAMS OF A BETTER LIFE FOR HER
FAMILY. SHE WORKED AS A MAID
CLERK AND OTHER JOBS UNTIL SHE
LANDED AS AN ASSISTANT IN A
CLINIC. THAT JOB AGAIN HER
LIFELONG CAREER IN HEALTH CARE.
HE MERRY GREG O'DONNELL WHO
ALSO PASSED AWAY IN NINETY WHO
PASSED AWAY JUST RECENTLY. HE
MARRIED SHE MARRIED HIM IN
NINETEEN NINETY THREE AND LATER
GAVE BIRTH TO HER SECOND SON
JACOB. GREGG WORKED HARD FOR
HIS FAMILY STARTED OUT HIS
PHONE SUCCESSFUL SMALL
BUSINESSES THE CONTRACTOR. WITH
HIS BROTHERS FOR MOST THIRTY
YEARS GABRIELLE ALSO WORKED AS
A SECRETARY AND MEDICAL
ASSISTANT. AND SHE WAS A PROUD
MEMBER OF SEIU U. H. W. IT WAS
HER LIFE'S WORK TO SUPPORT
NURSES DOCTORS AND MEDICAL
PERSONNEL. GREG WITH THE KIND
AND GOOD HEARTED MAN AN AMAZING
FATHER AND GRANDFATHER. AND THE
BEST HUSBAND TO GABBY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THEIR MEMORY AND
OFFER OUR SINCEREST.
CONDOLENCES TO THEIR FAMILY.
LASTLY MARIA LUZ THE LIGHTS
IDEA THAT FROM WHEN CALIFORNIA.
DEAR MOTHER. WOULD COUNCIL JOSE.
HE IMMIGRATED THE U. S. AND- SO
NINE. MARRYING THE LOVE OF HER
LIFE SO JOSE SO MUCH A SENIOR.
HERE TWO CHILDREN AS A JUNIOR
AND CARMEN. SHE WAS A WONDERFUL
HARDWORKING HOUSEWIFE AND
LOCALLY WELL KNOWN AVON LADY.
ALWAYS INVOLVED IN HER
COMMUNITY. AND HER CHILDREN SHE
PASSED IN AUGUST TWENTY FIRST
OF LAST YEAR. AFTER ABOUT A
BILL PRINCE WITH BREAST CANCER.
SHE WILL ALSO BE CLEARLY. WILL
BE GREATLY MISSED THANK YOU.
THURGOOD'S AUSTIN YOU SO MUCH
WE'LL BE WORKING WITH YOUR
STAFF TO BE ABLE TO GET OF THE
GENERATOR CARE WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. WE BELIEVE WE HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL MEMBER WHO WILL BE
PRESENTING AN INTERNAL MEMORY
TODAY AND THAT'S GOING TO BE
YOUR MAJORITY LEADER CENTER
HERTZBERG. GIVE US A FEW
MOMENTS.
ALL RIGHT. OKAY RIGHT
THE. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN
THE SENATE WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO RECONVENE HERE WITH MAJORITY
LEADER HERTZBERG. WITH HAYES A
GERMAN MEMORY MR MAJORITY
LEADER. SENATORS JOIN ME TODAY
AS I RISE TO COMMEMORATE THE
LIFE OF SHERMAN OAKS
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL MEMBER
RUNS IF RON WAS BORN ON.
FEBRUARY TWELFTH NINETEEN
THIRTY SEVEN PASSED AWAY ON
APRIL THIRTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
FROM COMPLICATED COMPLICATIONS
RELATING TO COVE IT. RON HAD
LIVED IN SHERMAN OAKS SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE HE WAS ON
THE NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL FOR
OVER TEN YEARS AFTER HIS CHART
TERM AS COUNCIL PRESIDENT RON
LATER SERVED AS CHAIR THE
PLANNING AND LAND USE
COMMITTEE. OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCIL MANY PEOPLE CARE BUT
RON WAS ALWAYS ONE OF THOSE WHO
TURNED HIS PASSION INTO ACTION.
IF WE HAD A CHANCE MEETING WITH
RON WE KNEW WE WOULD BRING IS
AND HAND OUT AND POWER POINT
BREEZE. THE CARE DEEPLY ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION IN THE QUALITY
OF LIFE AND SHERMAN OAKS. RON
WAS COMMITTED TO SERVING HIS
COMMUNITY. AND WE KNOW THAT
SHERMAN OAKS WILL MISS HIM.
SENATORS I RISE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS TODAY ABOUT MR LOS
ANGELES TOM A BUNCH TOM WAS A
TITAN OF OUR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY WHO DIED
ON JANUARY SEVENTH AT THE YOUNG
AGE OF SIXTY SEVEN. ALMOST
CERTAINLY A FORCE OF NATURE
BRING HIS UNBRIDLED CHARISMA
AND INTELLIGENCE TO BEAR ON A
HOST OF PROJECTS FOR LOS
ANGELES. OUR BELOVED CITY. B.
D. IN HIS HEART AND THE CITY
WAS FULL OF LOVE FOR HIM TOM
WAS THE SEVENTH OF EIGHT BOYS
BORN IN SILVER LAKE
NEIGHBORHOOD IN NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE. HE WAS A FORTY YEAR
VETERAN OF LOS ANGELES POLITICS
STARTING OUT WITH THE GREAT
COUNCILMAN JOHN FERRARO FOR
WHOM HE WORKED FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS. AND YOU SEE HE WENT ON
TO HOLD FOR ANOTHER FIFTEEN
YEARS. AT ITS CORE HE WAS
INCREDIBLY DECENT MAN. WHO
WANTED TO TRULY CONNECT WITH
EACH AND EVERY MEMBER OF HIS
COMMUNITY. HE EMBODIED ABOUT
WHAT'S BEST IN PUBLIC SERVICE
AND THAT WILL BE HIS LEGACY. HE
LOVED HISTORY HE LOVED LOS
ANGELES ST AND CALIFORNIA ST HE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
BRIGITTE HIS TWO SONS. AND FIVE
OF HIS BROTHERS. SENATORS IT IS
WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE
TODAY TO COMMEMORATE THE LIFE
OF AN INCREDIBLE PHILANTHROPIST
AND COMMUNITY ADVOCATE. RUTH
MOSS. RUTH WAS A DEAR FRIEND ON
DECEMBER THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
SHE PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY
INFANCY NO HOME AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY SIX WITH THE BELOVED
HUSBAND GEORGE AT OUR SIDE. SHE
WAS BORN INTO A NAVAL FAMILY
AND LIVED IN HAWAII DURING THE
ATTACK. ON PEARL HARBOR. SHE
ARRIVED IN LOS ANGELES IN
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN AND SINCE
THEN WAS AN ANGELINO THROUGH
AND THROUGH. SHE ATTENDED NORTH
HOLLYWOOD HIGH IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY IN OUR SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY AND THEN TO U.
S. C. THE JOYS. MOVES GEORGE
WERE MARRIED FOR SIXTY SIX
YEARS AND TOGETHER THEY RAISED
THREE KIDS KAREN STEVEN AND MY
DEAR FRIEND RICHARD. THEY LATER
WELCOME FOUR GRANDCHILDREN
THREE GREAT GREAT AND THREE
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. RUTH WAS
WELL KNOWN FOR COMMITMENT TO
PHILANTHROPIC CAUSES SERVING ON
THE NATIONAL BOARD OF THE ADL
THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE THE
VENICE FAMILY CLINIC. AND THE
DANCE GALLERY WHO'S ALSO
PRESIDENT OF THE UCLA. MEDICAL
CENTER AUXILIARY ALONG WITH
GEORGE SHE ESTABLISH THE ADL
DANIEL PEARL AWARD AND
SUPPORTED MEDICAL RESEARCH
PROJECTS INCLUDING THOSE. AT
UCLA JULES STEIN EYE CLINIC.
WITH WAS OUTGOING KIND FUNNY.
OVERALL AN EXCEPTIONAL PERSON I
WAS PROUD TO KNOW HER AND WE
WILL MISS HER IMMENSELY.
SENATORS I RISE TO CHURN IN THE
MEMORY OF DR MARLENE BAIN. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES WROTE THAT SHE
CARVED A UNIQUE NICHE IN STATE
GOVERNMENT THROUGH A BLEND OF
INTELLIGENCE ORGANIZATION AND
SOFT SPOKEN CHARM. IF ANY OF
YOU DO DOCTOR BANE I'M SURE YOU
HAVE YOUR OWN DESCRIPTIONS TO
ADD I CERTAINLY DO. BUT TO ME
SHE WAS A PILLAR OF LOS ANGELES
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
COMMUNITIES A LOCAL LEADER IN A
JEWISH COMMUNITY AND A TIRELESS
CHAMPION FOR CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE- SHE ALSO HAPPENED TO
BE THE WIFE OF FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TOM BAIN. OF
TEARS AND WHOSE CHAIRED THE
RULES COMMITTEE A DISTRICT THAT
I WOULD LATER HAVE THE HONOR TO
DISTINCT HONOR TO REPRESENT.
FORMER SPEAKER WILLIE BROWN
OFTEN REFERRED TO HER AS QUOTE
THE GOOD SIDE OF TOM CLOSE
QUOTE. AND WHEN SHE PASSED AWAY
MARLENE CARRIED ON WITHOUT
MISSING A BEAT. SHE CONTINUED
HER MISSION TO APPROVE THE
COMMUNITY SHE CALLED HOME UNTIL
HER PASSING ON JANUARY TWENTY
THIRD TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY
ONE SHE WAS SUROUNDED BY A
BEAUTIFUL FAMILY IS SURVIVED BY
THREE CHILDREN INCLUDING MY
GOOD FRIEND DEAL RUSTING. HER
SON WHY NO MRS MOTHER DEARLY
AND SIX GRAND CHILDREN.
SENATORS TODAY I INJURED IN THE
MEMORY OF LANE SHERMAN MOTHER
OF CONGRESSMAN BRAD SHERMAN AND
A WELL RESPECTED FIGURE. AS A
DEMOCRATIC PARTY VOLUNTEER
SINCE THE MID NINETEEN SIXTIES.
LANE WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
PHILADELPHIA PENNSYLVANIA. AS A
YOUNG GIRL SHE JOINED HER
FATHER WORKING WITH THE U. S.
FORCES TO REBUILD JAPAN. IN THE
AFTERMATH OF WORLD WAR TWO. I
GRADUATED FROM UCLA AND BUILD A
LIFE WITH A COLLEGE SWEETHEART
MARIE SHERMAN IN MONTEREY PARK.
WHEN REACHED PASSED AWAY IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES LANE MOVED
PORTER RANCH IN OUR BELOVED SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. HE WAS AN AVID
VOLUNTEER DONOR TO JEWISH
CAUSES AND PROGRESSIVE CAUSES
THE THIRTY YEARS SHE WAS A
STALWART SUPPORTER OF HER SON.
AND IN HIS OWN POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS ONE OF THE MANY OF
WHICH I AM CERTAIN HE WOULD NOT
HAVE WON WITHOUT HIS MOTHER'S
HARD WORK. LAINE PASSED
PEACEFULLY ON OCTOBER ELEVENTH
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY AT THE AGE
OF. NINETY ONE IN RECEDED. HE
IS SURVIVED BY HER SON
CONGRESSMAN BRAD SHERMAN HER
DAUGHTER AUDREY SIX
GRANDCHILDREN THREE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND EVEN A ONE
GREAT GREAT GRANDDAUGHTER.
SENATORS ON JULY TWENTIETH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY LOST ONE OF ITS
GREATEST CHAMPIONS. ALBURN SEN
THE FORMER LA CITY
COUNCILMEMBER AND PERHAPS ONE
OF THE MOST POTENT FORCES FOR
PROGRESS IN OUR COMMUNITY
PASSED LAST SUMMER AT THE AGE
OF EIGHTY NINE HE LEFT A LEGACY
THAT WE WILL REMEMBER IN THE
VALLEY FOR GENERATIONS HOW WAS
DUBBED AS MR EARTHQUAKE FIRST
THE NATION'S APPROACH TO
SEISMIC SAFETY THROUGHOUT THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES. IN
ORGANIZING THE CITY'S FIRST
INTERNATIONAL EARTHQUAKE
CONFERENCE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY ONE
HE SERVED IN THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY THE
SANFORD OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL RAIL
AUTHORITY AND THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS. AT THE END OF THAT
YEAR HE WAS PRESENTED WITH THE
JULIAN C. DIXON AWARD A DEAR
FRIEND OF MINE FOR HIS
TRANSFORMATIVE AND VISIONARY
WORK IN TRANSPORTATION HOUSE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO LOS ANGELES IN
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY COULD
FILL VOLUMES. AND ONE IS
FRIENDS WITH HIS FAMILY AND MY
COLLEAGUES TO NOTE THAT HIS
WORK THAT FOR HIS WORK WE ARE.
FOR EVER GRATEFUL. SENATORS
EACH ME IN A JOURNEY IN THE
MEMORY OF FULLY BABY FUENTES
WHO PASSED AWAY ON SEPTEMBER
TWELFTH TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY
ALL OF US KNOW HIS GRANDSON
PREVIOUSLY SERVED IN THE
ASSEMBLY BUT WHEN THIS SENIOR
STARTED HIS EXTRAORDINARY
JOURNEY WHEN HE WAS BORN IN
MEXICO ON FEBRUARY TWELFTH
NINETEEN TWENTY SIX HE WAS THE
SECOND SON OF FIFTEEN CHILDREN.
AT THE VET AT A VERY YOUNG AGE
HE WORKED IN THE FIELDS AND
ATTENDED TO ANIMALS AND CROPS
M. I. NINETEEN FIFTY ONE BELIEF
THEY ARRIVED IN THE NORTH THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AND BEGAN
TO SETTLE IN THIS COMMITTEE IN
THE COMMUNITY OF COLINA HE WORK
FOR THE LABOR UNION TO HELP
BUILD THE VA HOSPITAL IN NORTH
HILLS THE PALMDALE AIRPORT AND
INSTALLATIONS OF THE SEWER
SYSTEMS ACROSS THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY. IN NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT
MISTER TWENTY SPEAK AND TO WORK
ON A NEW CONSTRUCTION PROJECT
THE GENERAL MOTORS PLANT WE
WORK FOR THIRTY YEARS ASSEMBLY
AND INSPECTING CARS FULLY PAY
WAS AN ACTIVE CITIZEN AND
PARTICIPATED IN THE ELECTION OF
SEVERAL LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS
MY DEAR FRIEND CONGRESSMAN TONY
GOT OF THIS ARE NEW UNITED
STATES SENATE OX BUT THE IN HIS
OWN. IS A SAID STATUS AND
COUNCIL MEMBER FELIPE A POINT
THIS HIS DAUGHTER YOLANDA POINT
THIS IS AN OUTSTANDING PUBLIC
SERVANT AND A CLOSE FRIEND THAT
SHARES HIS LEGACY WITH HONOR
AND RESPECT SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE OF FIFTY YEARS FIFTY THREE
YEARS OR SOMETHING THAT IS KIDS
AND OVER TWENTY GRAND. AND
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. SENATOR
TODAY JOURNAL THE MAY OF OUR
SUITE. ALBERT WAS KNOWN FOR
BRINGING LIFE INTO OLDER BILL
RIGHT THEM IN CREATE OFFICE
THAT HAVE SINCE SERVICE HOW.
THE NUMEROUS HIGH PROFILE COME.
HE PARDON PARDON MY DEAR FRIEND
CRAIG DARIA. AHEAD OF HIGHLY
VENICE IN MAY PER. UNDER THE
HOT BASS OCCIDENTAL
ENTERTAINMENT GROUP HOLDINGS.
AT OF SERVICE EVERY MAJOR
STUDIO NETWORK IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY. ROBERT
WAS ALSO A KIND PHILANTHROPIST
IS ENDEAVORED FOCUSED ON
VETERANS KIDS. BIOTECHNOLOGY
AND OTHER VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES IN NEED. COUNTLESS
ORGANIZATIONS OF HONORED HIM
FOR CIVIC AND HUMANITARIAN
EFFORTS HE WAS A HERO OF
HOLLYWOOD IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE. AND IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN YOU RECEIVES HONORARY
DOCTORATE DEGREE FROM TECHNI ON
UNIVERSITY WHICH IS IN ISRAEL
HIS MEMORY WILL LIVE ON AS AN
INCREDIBLE MARK. ARE BEST
REFLECTED IN HIS COMMENT JUST
COMMITMENTS YOU MANAGE CHERRY
IN CAUSES THAT AFFECTED. PEOPLE
OF ALL. BACKGROUNDS AND FACE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR SURGERY LATER WE ARE
GRATEFUL ARE A JOURNEY MEMORIES
ARE COMPLETE WE WILL BE
RECONVENING THIS COMING
THURSDAY THE TWENTY FIFTH AT
NINE AM THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
HAVE A GOOD NIGHT.